WELL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE PLEASE COME TO
THE HEARING IS A LITTLE PAST
ONE THIRTY. AND WE HAVE MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE RIGHT NOW. THAT
ARE READY TO BEGIN. IN THE
LETTERS B. AND SON AND THEIR
FIRST UP. SO PLEASE NOT HOLD UP
YOUR- YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
HERE AND ON TIME.
WHILE WE WAIT
FOR THE OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THAT ARE ON THE COMMITTEE- TO
COME TO THE COMMITTEE I WILL
THERE'S A LOT OF PROTOCOL WE
NEED TO GO THROUGH AND SO I
WILL OPEN IT UP SO WE DON'T
WASTE ANY TIME AND GO THROUGH
PROTOCOL. SO I WILL OFFICIALLY
OPEN UP. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FOR THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- LEGISLATIVE YEAR.
WELL IF. AND I'M CALLING THE
MEETING TO ORDER. WE NEED A FEW
MORE MEMBERS TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- UNTIL THEN UNTIL WE GET
A COUPLE MORE HERE WE WILL
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. AGAIN THIS
IS THE FIRST HEARING AID
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY. BUT FIRST LET US BEGIN
WITH OUR HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS. UP
DUE TO THE CONTINUED STAY AT
HOME ORDER WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON WE
ALSO REQUIRED THAT MASS B.
WARRANT AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
BE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFIED WHETHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM. TODAY WE'RE IN THE
CAPITAL ROOM. FOUR TWO ZERO TWO
FORTY TWO OH TWO. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF IN A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET SPACING- ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITOL. FOR THOSE
HERE IN THE ROOM AND FOR THOSE
HERE IN ROME IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN THE BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND I WILL
ASK. THAT YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH YOUR
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING WILL RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THE UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING
LIMITING. IT ELEVATOR USE TO
ONE PERSON AT A TIME. FOUR B.
FOR W. B. R. WITNESSES- THIS IS
ONLY TO MENTION IF THERE ARE
ANY I DON'T KNOW WHAT WBR BUT
ALWAYS THIS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THE CAPITAL BUT IN ROME- ONE
TWO SEVEN IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM OUTSIDE
THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME
BILL WITNESSES MAKING USE OF
OUR VIDEO WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS. WHICH ARE
LOCATED IN THE CAPITAL THE
CORRESPONDING ROOM FOR OUR
HEARING IS ROOM. ONE TWO SEVEN
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. DOES
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASKED HIM QUESTIONS. FOR
DIALING WITNESSES. WILL ALSO
BRING. THE USERNAME MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN LET ME DO THAT ONE
MORE TIME EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO.
ZERO TWO AGAIN THAT'S ONE.
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV ST. IF
YOU'RE CALLING AND PLEASE DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING%
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO PLACE IN
Q. BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE ABOUT. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST INTO SMART. DEVICES
TO REDUCE TO SOUND DISTORTION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS IF
YOU'RE A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU REMAIN ON THE LIVE
LINE. AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. THREE SEVEN OUR FOUR
AGAIN THAT'S. 916-319-3744 IF
YOU'RE HAVING DIFFICULTIES AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY
TO HELP I. ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH TO POSITION.
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING. WITH US OUR AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. I BELIEVE MADAM SECRETARY
WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL. JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY.
OUR CAN WORK HERE. SANTIAGO
SEATTLE HERE WICKS LEE QUORUM
IS PRESENT I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR NEWEST MEMBER AND
OUR NEWEST MEMBER TO THE TO THE
ASSEMBLY ON TO PUBLIC SAFETY MR
ALEX ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX LEE.
MMHM MISTER SINGER TOO I JUST
LOCAL. WELL I MISS TO SEE R.
TWO WE ALSO WANT TO WELCOME YOU
HERE- HE'S THE YOUNGEST OF THE
YOUNGEST AND THE NEWEST OF THE
NOTICE OF. HE'S GOT YOU
PROBABLY ABOUT. I WON'T GO INTO
THAT. OFF CALENDAR TODAY WHICH
OFF CALENDAR AND ON THE- OFF
CALENDAR- MISTER YOU TWO TWO
EIGHT- MISTER RODRIGUEZ THAT
WAS ITEM NINETEEN. THAT
RECEIVING STOLEN PROPERTY
FIREARMS HE PULLED FROM THE
CALENDAR. SO ITEM NINETEEN HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. NOW
WILL GO TO THE PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR. I DON'T NUMBER ONE AB
THREE FOUR ONE. BOERNER HORVATH
CREDIBILITY OF WITNESSES SOCIAL
MEDIA CONTENT- ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB FIVE ONE FIVE CHEN A
TRESPASS AND THESE ITEMS ARE
ITEMS THAT WERE IN THE ORDER
THAT WE WERE GOING TO HEAR THEM
TODAY. I DON'T NUMBER SEVEN AB
FIFTY SEVEN GABRIEL. LAW
ENFORCEMENT HATE CRIMES. ITEM
NUMBER TEN. AB THREE THREE ONE
BY JONES SAWYER ORGANIZED DEATH
WITH AN URGENCY. AB ELEVEN I
MEAN ITEM ELEVEN AB FOUR EIGHT
THREE OUR JONES SAWYER PEACE
OFFICERS CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
CENTER EXPOSITION PARK- ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN A. B. FIVE FOUR
SEVEN MCCARTY MCCARTY SKEWS ME
MR MCCARTY. ARE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS RIGHTS. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWO SIX TWO
PATTERSON HUMAN TRAFFICKING
BARKER TORTOR RELIEF FOR
VICTIMS THOSE ARE THE SEVEN
ITEMS THERE ON A PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ACCEPT IT CONSENT
CALENDAR. HELLO THEIR SECOND
FROM RB K. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LACKEY ABOUT MADE THE MOTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REBEKAH POWER
CAN. HAS SECONDED CALDERON ON
THE ON THE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR YES ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT GO JONES SAWYER HI
JONES SAWYER IRAQI LACKEY I
BARRICADE HAN BACKING HAD A
CORK ALL RIGHT QUICK HI
SANTIAGO SAY R. TO C. ARE TO
AYE WICKS. LEE THE I. CONSENT
HOLDERS ABOUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN APPROVED. AND
AS OUR USUAL PROCEDURE AT THE
BEGINNING OF A OF A CYCLE WE
ALSO NEED TO HAVE A DOCKED THE
COMMITTEE RULES MEMBERS AND
THEIR STAFF RECEIVED THEM LAST
WEEK THERE IS ALSO A HARD COPY
AVAILABLE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IF THERE
IS NONE OUR MOTION TO ADOPT A
PROPOSED COMMITTEE RULES WILL
BE ACCEPTED. MOVED BY REBEKAH
BARKING UNCERTAIN BUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALEX LEE. ON THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE ROLLS JONES
SAWYER CHEN SIR HI LACKEY
LACKEY I BARRICADE HAN ERA CAN
I A CORK. QUIRK I SANTIAGO THEY
ARE NOW HI THE ARE TOO HIGH
WICKS LI LI I. THANK YOU- SO
TODAY OUR GOAL IS TO GO THROUGH
THE AGENDA AN ALPHABETICAL FILE
ORDER WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
ON ME WITNESSES THIS OF COURSE
WILL HAVE A TIME OF FIVE
MINUTES PER SIDE TWO WITNESSES
PERSATUAN AND SPLIT UP IN TWO
AND A HALF MINUTES OR ONE
PERSON IS ONE MINUTE AND A
PRETTY GOOD FOR MINUTES. THEY
GET FOUR AND A HALF MINUTES IN
A HALF. A MINUTE- JUST AS LONG
AS YOU DON'T GO OVER FIVE
MINUTES AND SO OUR FIRST UP. IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELL IT THE
NEXT TWO BILLS ARE SIMILAR
BONTA AB TWO SIX THREE. OUR
NOTE I WAS ON CONSENT SO MR
BONTA HAS ONE ON CONSENT AND
THE SECOND ONE. AB. THREE TWO
NINE. THE SIX THREE WERE. RIGHT
NOW PERHAPS. OKAY I'M SORRY MR
BONTA YOU HAD TO BOOK. I TRY TO
HELP YOU. REALLY DID. WHAT EVER
YOU READY TO BE AT. BUT THIS IS
NOT. HELLO THE COMMITTEE. YEAH
COMMITTEE. SHE I. DON'T HEAR.
RAVELLO TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
WE SHOULD BE FINE. SUCH TRY
THIS AGAIN ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWO SIX THREE PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES WITH AN URGENCY.
AMERICAN THAT'S A GOOD SIGN MR
BONTA. OUR ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS WELL. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE WITNESSES SO IF YOU HAVE
WITH THIS DESK- I DO AND JUST
QUICKLY THIS ISN'T THE HEALTH
OVERSIGHT AND LET LEADERSHIP IN
DETENTION ACT IT TAKES STEPS TO
CLARIFY THAT ALL FIVE DETENTION
FACILITIES IN THE STATE MUST
ABIDE BY STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS THIS ONE PROVED
PUBLIC HEALTH CREATE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR PRIVATE
DETENTION CENTERS AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF BY PHONE DR
PARVEEN PARMAR AN EXPERT WITH
PHYSICIANS FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
YUNIS CHAU SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE ACLU NATIONAL
PRISON PROJECT- WILL MAKE BRIEF
PRESENTATIONS.
THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE THE BIKE TO WORK HERE
AND- IF THE WITNESSES ARE
AVAILABLE- AND YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE THEIR TESTIMONY THE BRIEF
CEREMONY. THE CATEGORY ON THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR- ARE MR
BONTA IS AB TWO SIX THREE. DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TO SHOULD BE. YOU
SHOULD BE AT LEAST ONE WITNESS
FROM THE SANDY ONE OF FROM THE
DOCTOR PARVEEN PARMAR MD. AND
UNITS THAT- FOR A YES I'M HERE
HI OKAY. STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR PARVEEN
PARMER I AM AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF CLINICAL EMERGENCY
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S KECK
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND CHIEF OF
THE DIVISION OF GLOBAL
EMERGENCY MEDICINE. I AM ALSO%
AN EXPERT WITH PHYSICIANS FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS AN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND THAT IS CO
SPONSORING THIS BILL AS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS BRINGING
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO IMMIGRATION
DETENTION POLICY AND PRACTICE.
I PROVIDE ROUTINE CLINICAL CARE
TO INCARCERATED PATIENTS AND A
DEDICATED JAIL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT AT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY GENERAL HOSPITAL. I ALSO
CONDUCT RESEARCH FOCUSED ON
THAT AND POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES
AMONG INDIVIDUALS IN ICE
DETENTION FACILITIES
NATIONWIDE. THAT'S I'M ALSO
FAMILIAR WITH ICE'S NATIONAL
DETENTION STANDARDS AS THEY
APPLY TO THE HEALTH OF
INDIVIDUALS IN ICE DETENTION.
AS AN EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN I
HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT
OF PUBLIC NINETEEN ON OUR
COMMUNITY IN LOS ANGELES AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO I
COME TO THIS COMMITTEE WITH A
SINCERE HOPE TO MITIGATE
FURTHER HARM AND DEATH IN OUR
STATE FROM THE VIRUS AND IT'S
MULTIPLE HEALTH RELATED
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
CONSEQUENCES. EIGHTY TWO SIX
THREE IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION NEEDED TO HOLD
PRIVATE PRISON CORPORATIONS
ACCOUNTABLE WITH RESPECT TO HOW
THEIR FACILITIES IMPACT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. THE ACTIONS
AND OPERATIONS OF THESE PRIVATE
ACTORS HAVE VERY SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES. FOR PEOPLE HELD
IN THEIR CUSTODY THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THESE FACILITIES ARE
LOCATED. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
PRONOUNCED IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE IMMINENT THREAT POSED BY
THE PANDEMIC. ATTRACTING PEOPLE
IN CONGREGATE SETTINGS IS
CRITICAL TO OUR STRUGGLE TO
CONTAIN CODE NINETEEN. RESEARCH
IN THE JOURNAL OF THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION HAS
ESTIMATED THAT NINETY OUT OF
THE ONE HUNDRED LARGEST KOBE
NINETEEN CLUSTER OUTBREAK HAD
TAKEN PLACE AND CARCERAL
SETTING LIKE DETENTION
FACILITIES. THESE OUTBREAKS NOT
ONLY THREATEN THE LIVES OF
THOSE WHO ARE DETAINED OR
WORKING INSIDE THE FACILITIES
THEY CAN QUICKLY OVERWHELM THE
MEDICAL RESOURCES AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE AT LEAST
SIX PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES AND OUR STATE WHICH
CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITH LITTLE
REGARD FOR PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
EMPLOYEE SAFETY. DISTURBING
REPORTS CONTINUE TO EMERGE
THESE PRIVATE CORPORATIONS HAVE
IGNORED REQUESTS BY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
IMPLEMENTED POLICIES THAT HARM
HEALTH BY IGNORING WELL
ESTABLISHED MEDICAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE WITH IMPUNITY.
IN A PARTICULARLY CHILLING
TESTIMONY EMANCIPATED OTAY MESA
DETENTION CENTER OPERATED BY
CORECIVIC REPORTED TO
RESEARCHERS AT HARVARD MEDICAL
SCHOOL AND PHYSICIANS FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. THAT QUOTE THE DOCTOR
WOULD NOT COMMENT UNTIL YOU
WERE VERY VERY SICK ALMOST AT
THAT DOOR AND CLOSE. HE ALSO
STATED HE WAS MADE TO SIGN A
DOCUMENT WAIVING THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE DETENTION
CENTER IF YOU WERE TO GET SICK
WITH KOBE NINETEEN. MY OWN
EXPERIENCE EVALUATING HEALTH
OUTCOMES IN ICE DETENTION
FACILITIES HAS SHOWN ME THAT
SUB STANDARD HEALTH CARE AND A
LACK OF ATTENTION TO PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE IS A CONSISTENT
AND LONGSTANDING PATTERN OF
BEHAVIOR IN THESE PRIVATELY
OPERATED ICE FACILITIES. THIS
IS A PATTERN THAT WILL NOT
CHANGE WITHOUT CLOSE OVERSIGHT
AND REGULATORY CONSEQUENCES. AS
A RESEARCHER. I INTERVIEWED
THOUSANDS OF PAGES AND DETAILED
DOCUMENTATION REGARDING THAT
AND I DETENTION FACILITIES OVER
THE PAST DECADE REPEATEDLY OUR
RESEARCH CAME OUT LINKS DIRECT
TO DELIVERY AND SUB STANDARD
MEDICAL AND PSYCHIATRIC CARE IN
PRIVATE FACILITIES. THE
FACILITY ROUTINELY VIOLATE I
DID OWN HEALTH STANDARDS. YOU
HAVE TO HAVE MINUTES LEFT YOU
WILL LEAVE SOME TIME FOR MR. OR
DID YOU READ. CERTAINLY I CAN
WRAP UP- AT THE CORE OF THIS
BILL IS A RECOGNITION THAT WE
MUST EMPOWER LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO ACT
DECISIVELY IN ORDER TO PROTECT
OUR STATE AND STARES OUT OF
THIS PANDEMIC AND THAT'S WHAT
AB TWO SIX THREE DOES THIS BILL
CUTS THROUGH THE CONFUSION AND
LACK OF CLARITY AND GET PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS A UNIFORMITY TO
SECURE ALL THE TENSION
FACILITIES UNDER UNIFIED
STANDARDS. FOR THESE REASONS I
ENCOURAGE YOUR VOTE IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CHAU ACLU. YES HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. GREAT HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS EUNICE CHOU AND I'M
A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
ACLU'S NATIONAL PRISON PROJECT
WE WORK ON BEHALF OF IMMIGRANT
DETAINEES FACING
UNCONSTITUTIONAL CONDITIONS OF
CONFINEMENT. IN THE PAST YEAR
I'VE SERVICE COUNSELING OVER
FORTY CASES TEN OF WHICH A
CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT ON BEHALF
OF IMMIGRANT DETAINEES FACING
THE THREAT A SERIOUS ILLNESS OR
DEATH BECAUSE OF COVERED
NINETEEN. I'M ALSO THE AUTHOR
OF SEVERAL REPORTS REGARDING
THE TREATMENT OF DETAIN PEOPLE
IN IMMIGRATION DETENTION
FACILITIES NATIONWIDE. AS PART
OF THIS WORK FIVE VISITED
DOZENS OF BILLS VISIBILITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
INTERVIEWED HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
ABOUT CONDITIONS OF CONFINEMENT
AND IMMIGRATION DETENTION.
EIGHTY TWO SIXTY THREE IS AN
ESSENTIAL LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT THE LIVES OF VULNERABLE
PEOPLE IN IMMIGRATION
DETENTION. IN THE LAST YEAR
TWENTY ONE PEOPLE DIED IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION
FACILITIES THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SPENDING FIFTEEN YEARS. AND
THOUSANDS MORE HAVE CONTRACTED
CODED NINETEEN DUE TO THE
FAILURE OF DETENTION OPERATORS
TO ENSURE SAFE CONDITIONS IN
DETENTION. CALIFORNIA CAN AND
MUST DO MORE WE HAVE SEEN
REPEATED PATTERNS OF NEGLIGENCE
AND MISCONDUCT BY PRIVATE
DETENTION OPERATOR CALIFORNIA
WHILE IMMIGRANT DETAINEES MIGHT
BE IN THE LEGAL CUSTODY OF ICE.
A FEDERAL AGENCY CALIFORNIA HAS
CLEAR AUTHORITY TO REGULATE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF PEOPLE AND
DETENTION FACILITIES INCLUDING
THOSE HOUSING DEMOCRATS. STATE
AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAS THE POWER TO
REGULATE HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
THESE PENSION FACILITIES
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
OPERATED OR OWNED BY PRIVATE
PRISON CORPORATION. HOWEVER
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
ISSUE AND THE INVOLVING LEGAL
LANDSCAPE IS QUITE COMMON FOR
STATE AGENCIES TO LIMIT THEIR
ABILITY OVER THE FACILITY. AND
A PRIVATE OPERATORS. TWO EIGHTY
TWO SIXTY THREE WILL NOT ONLY
BENEFIT PEOPLE IN IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTERS BUT ALSO THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN AMERICA TO
THIRTY ANSWER ANY COMMUNITY.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
IN FACILITIES OWNED AND
OPERATED BY PRIVATE PRISON
CORPORATIONS. OFTEN HAVE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO LOWER
WAGES AND CUT CORNERS ON
HEALTHCARE FOR DETAIN PEOPLE AN%
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY CARD FOR
WORKERS. THIS IS TRUE AT THE-
TEAMMATES SAID DETENTION
FACILITY IN SAN DIEGO WHICH IS
RUN BY CORECIVIC A PRIVATE
PRISON CORPORATION. THE CAME
INTO IS NOTABLE BECAUSE IT WAS
THE SITE OF THE FIRST DETAINEE
DEATH IN THE COUNTRY RESULTING
FROM CORPORATE NINETEEN LAST
YEAR. BUT IT'S ALSO A PLACE FOR
CORECIVIC ORDERED MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE GUARDS NOT TO WEAR
MASKS I THINK THAT IT WOULD
COST TO BE REMINDED HEANEY'S
AND FAILED TO PROVIDE EVEN THE
MOST BASIC. PP OR HIDING SUPPLY.
SUPPORT STAFF AND THE TEAM.
YOUR MOTHER PROTECT. EIGHTY TWO
SIXTY WOULD MAKE. THAT OSHA
REGULATES ARE ADEQUATE FOR THE
ABILITY. COULD YOU PLEASE WRITE
OUT A CHECK IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF WORKERS. WE URGE YOU-
AND SHE PASSED EIGHTY AT-
THIRTY AT G. SIXTY THREE IT IS
URGENTLY NEEDED DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO SAVE HUMAN LIVES
AND CLARIFY THE ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OVER TWENTY TO THIRTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU ARE
THERE. ANY WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM. I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON
ON THIS MATTER AB'S. TWO SIX
THREE. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN DE. VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
EIGHTEEN ANTI DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SIXTY THREE POINT ONE ZERO
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SIXTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN
ZERO NOW. MESSAGE SHARE THE
CLIP WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHTEEN IN
Q. BUT FOR C. ONE MOMENT SIR.
WHY NUMBER ONE TWELVE DEADLINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL DOCTOR FINALLY THE ACLU
IN CALIFORNIA HELLO I GOT THE
RULES FOR ME TO USE HIS NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. AND THAT'S
PROBABLY ALL THE TIME WE HAVE
FOR RIGHT NOW SO IF YOU JUST
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
THAT'S FOR EVERYONE TO SPEAKING
TODAY. OTHERWISE WE'LL BE HERE.
AND POSITION. ARE YOU FOR OR
AGAINST. SO YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD
AT GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS MIKE
A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WITH THE
SUPPORT FOR AGAINST. LINE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LINE NUMBER
ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS
ON HOW THAT WOULD ON WITH
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA. THE
SPONSORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LIE NUMBER ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOTIFIABLE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT TO COMMENT COMES FROM
THE LINE OF ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
BIG NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE OF
AND SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE OF THE FIFTY SIX ZERO YOU
MAY NOW. THE LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS AT
THE MARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ENTERNEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE OF SIXTY NINE
THAT IS MY NUMBER SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. YEAH
YOU'RE GONNA ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT TIME IT
COMES FROM THE LINE OF ONE TO
THIRTY ONE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. BRIAN
HOPE FOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
SECURE JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE OF
ONE TO FOURTEEN THAT'S MY
NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM A LINE OF ONE THIRTY
EIGHT THAT'S MY NUMBER ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE OF ONE
THIRTY FIVE THAT'S FINE NUMBER
ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI RIGHT NOT TO WORRY
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY WHAT THE
WORST YOU COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO
SIX THREE. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
SUPPORT COMES FROM THE LINE OF
SEVENTY FOUR THAT'S MY NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR PEOPLE HAD.
CAPTION TO BURN ON BEHALF OF
BOTH THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TAYLORNATE
BLIND PUTS THE PORT IS ONE ZERO
SIX THAT'S ONE ZERO SIX PEOPLE
HAD. SHE YES HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN'S HAVING
SOMEONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAN AFFECT HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN OUR NEXT LINE FOR
SUPPORT IS ONE OF FORTY THREE
YEARS PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
JACKIE GONZALEZ WAS IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ADVOCATES CULT COMPLEX
IN THE BILL STRONG SUPPORT YOU
CAN'T THANK YOU. ENTERNEXT
KLEIN IS ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TARI GILBERT FOR
DOCTORS FOR CAMP CLOSURE WAS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND OUR NEXT LINE IS ONE
OF FOUR ZERO THAT'S ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON%
CALL QUERY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SIX THREE. THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT LINE FOR SUPPORT IS NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS EDWIN THAT MONICA'S
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT DIRECTOR
BUT THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE WORK INJECTED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX
THREE. THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT
LINE IS ONE TWENTY NINE ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARK OF GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND ARE
NOT A LINE IS THE ONE OF FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
RHONDA GRAILS CROWDED SOMETHING
HAPPENED ON THE ON THE TAP I
KNOW DON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT SUPPORT
LINE IS ONE OF FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. CHINESE MY NAME IS MERRY
MARINO CONCERN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB
TWO SIXTY THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM. AND OUR NEXT LINE IS
ONE ELEVEN ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. K. WILL
GO TO THE NEXT LINE IS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MERRIAM
SHAHADA ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES HUMAN RIGHTS
INITIATIVES IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SIXTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND OUR FINAL
IN SUPPORT IS ONE OF FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS JIM
WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SIXTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AS CHAIR MEMBERS
TRYING SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER SHERMAN. AND IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIXTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN
Q. THE COUPLE COME UP HERE HOLD
ON WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER.
NINETY SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MAY BE ON MUTE. OKAY. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY MORE COMMON IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU OPERATOR- FROM
WHAT I HAVE HERE THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANY ROOM. AND NO ONE'S MADE
AN ATTEMPT ON THE VIDEO. AND IF
THERE'S NO ONE AROUND ARE THERE
ANY IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM. AND EIGHTEEN
UP EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWO SIX THREE.
THEY MAY BE ON THE LINE. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION AB TWO SIXTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IT
IS ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I DO
NOT SHOW ANY OPPOSITION
RESEARCHER THANK YOU. YOU MAY
GO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ONE AB TWO
SIX THREE. SEEING NONE YOU YOU
MAY CLOSE MR BONTA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BY ON THE. YES
OKAY YOUR COLLEAGUES AND STUFF-
NOW DO WE HAVE TO MAKE GOING
JUST I THANK YOU AND- WARM
GREETINGS TODAY- THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE BIPARTISAN BILL
THAT IMPROVES OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
ESPECIALLY DURING A PANDEMIC
AND CREATES NEEDED
ACCOUNTABILITY- WHERE IT'S BEEN
PROVEN THAT IT'S REQUIRED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. MR BONTA. ON THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND RYAN
SHERMAN I'M URGING EVERY MEMBER
HERE TO VOTE UNANIMOUSLY. FOR
A. B. TWO SIX THREE. VENTURE
MAY CALL VOTE. AB TWO SIX THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
HI JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY
LACKEY I BARRICADE HAND BACK HE
HAD A QUIRK. QUIRK HI SANTIAGO
C. R. TWO C. R. TôI WICKES.
WICKES HI LI LI HI THAT
MEASURE. THAT MEASURE PASSES MR
BONTA YOU MAY GO ON TO AB THREE
TWO NINE BAIL. THANK YOU- AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES AND
STAFF AND THANK YOU FOR THE AYE
VOTES IN THE LAST BILL I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AB THREE TWENTY
NINE. IS A BILL TO
FUNDAMENTALLY REFORM
CALIFORNIA'S PRETRIAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ON BEHALF OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS WERE HELD IN
JAIL PRE TRIAL EVERY YEAR
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE POOR.
THE MONEY BAIL SYSTEM PENALIZES
POVERTY SETTING A PRICE ON A
PERSON'S ACCESS TO PRE TRIAL
RELEASE BASED ON THE SIZE OF
THEIR WALLET NOT THE SIZE OF
THEIR RISK ON ANY GIVEN DAY IN
CALIFORNIA 63% OR ROUGHLY FORTY
SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE
STATE'S JAILS ARE AWAITING
TRIAL OR SENTENCING. AND 97% OF
THEM. MAKE BAIL WHO MAKE BAIL
YOU THE BAIL AGENT TO SECURE
THEIR RELEASE THIS MEANS THAT
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
ACCUSED OF CRIMES AND UP PAYING
A FEE. TO STAY OUT OF JAIL
BEFORE EVER BEING FOUND GUILTY
BY A JUDGE. OR BY JURY. IT IS A
BROKEN SYSTEM. THAT DOES NOT
MAKE US SAFER OR LOWERED
INSTANCES OF FAILURES TO APPEAR
IN COURT. IN MY VIEW IT IS
UNFAIR UNJUST AND UNSAFE. LAST
APRIL IN AN EFFORT TO REDUCE
OVERCROWDING IN JAILS AND
POTENTIAL. PROFIT NINETEEN
OUTBREAK THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ENACTED AN EMERGENCY ZERO BAIL
ORDER. THAT DEMONSTRATES A
VIABLE ALTERNATIVE TO KEEPING.
PEOPLE IN JAIL PRE TRIAL. AFTER
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DISCONTINUED THEIR EMERGENCY
BAIL SCHEDULE THIRTY ONE
COUNTIES COVERING 80% OF
CALIFORNIANS. ENACTED THEIR
OWN. EMERGENCY ZERO BAIL
SCHEDULES AB THREE TWENTY NINE.
BILLS ON THE BURTON C. BELL
SCHEDULE SET BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. TO BUILD A MORE
EFFECTIVE AND A MORE JUSTICE
SYSTEMS. THE BILL REFORMS MONEY
BAIL NOT BY ELIMINATING IT BUT
RATHER SETTING BAIL AT ZERO
DOLLARS FOR MISDEMEANOR. AND
NONVIOLENT FELONY. CHARGES FOR
ALL OTHER. CRIMES THE NEW
LEGISLATION WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
CREATE A UNIFORM. BELL SCHEDULE
WITH STANDARD BAIL AMOUNTS
STATEWIDE. SO THEY'LL BE
CERTAIN C. AND CONSISTENCY
AMONG OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AB THREE TWENTY NINE WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE PEOPLE WHO PAY BILL TO
RECEIVE A REFUND. MINUS A SMALL
SURCHARGE THAT IS RETAINED BY
THE BILL ON COMPANIES. IF THE
CHARGES ARE NEVER. IF CHARGES
AGAINST THE ARE DRAW. OR IF IT
TEN ALL MANNED COURT
APPEARANCES MEANING THEY APPEAR
AT ALL TIMES AND THEY'RE
REQUIRED. CURRENTLY BILL
COMPANIES HAVE BUILT AN
IMMENSELY PROFITABLE INDUSTRY.
THROUGH THE CURRENT SYSTEM
CLICKING HIGH FEES USUALLY ON
AVERAGE 10% OF THE FULL BELUM
OUT. THE AVERAGE WILL NOT
CALIFORNIA 5000010% IS FIVE
THOUSAND. WELL RARELY
FORFEITING BONDS POSTED TO THE
COURT. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER A
CASE IS DISMISSED OR IF CHARGES
ARE NOT ULTIMATELY FILED OR IF.
THEY'RE DROPPED. THE BILL
COMPANY KEEPS ITS PREMIUM.
INDIVIDUALS PAY THESE PREMIUMS
BECAUSE THE ALTERNATIVE IS
WORSE. BEEN STUCK IN JAIL TO ME
LOSING A JOB. LOSING A CAR
LOSING A HOME LOSING A FAMILY
MEMBER. IF THEY AREN'T- IF THEY
HAVE CUSTODY OF A SMALL CHILD
NO THE ONLY A PARENT WHO CAN DO
THAT. THE JAIL HOUSE DOOR
SHOULD NOT SWINGS OPEN AND
CLOSE BASED ON HOW MUCH MONEY
SOMEONE HAS. THERE IS NO
DISPUTING THE PRESENT SYSTEM
WRONGLY TREAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
RICH. AND GUILTY. BETTER THAN
THOSE WHO ARE POOR AND INNOCENT.
IN MY VIEW THE STATUS QUO IS
INDEFENSIBLE AND WE CANNOT
DEFEND THE INDEFENSIBLE. IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. MONEY
BAIL APPEAR IN MY EYES IS AN
EQUAL JUSTICE. AND WE MUST
CONTINUE OUR FIGHT FOR EQUAL
JUSTICE. UNDER THE LAW. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
AB THREE TWENTY NINE SO WE CAN
CREATE A FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA
THAT EMBRACES SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE. THE
FEATURE THAT ELIMINATES BLATANT
DISCRIMINATION. AGAINST THE
POOR AND MAKES US SAFER. THANK
YOU. I HAVE A AS A WITNESS
ESTEBAN UNIONS REPRESENTING TO
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION. A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES IS MR NUNEZ ON THE
PHONE AND. YES SIR AND YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES. OKAY MEMBERS OF
THE. OKAY I'M NOT A BIG MUCH OF
THE TIME I WON'T USE ALL THE
FIVE MINUTES- BUT ADDS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA SAID MY NAME IS AS
BY NEW YEAR'S I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF ADVOCACY AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION ALSO KNOWN
AS A R. C. A. R. HE WORKS TO
END MASS INCARCERATION
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE HEALTHY
AND WHOLE THEIR SKIN POWERS
FORMERLY AND CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO DRIVE BY
PROVIDING A SUPPORT NETWORK
COMPREHENSIVE REENTRY SERVICES
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO ADVOCATE
FOR POLICY CHANGE. THERE ARE
GRASSROOTS POLICY ADVOCACY WE
ARE DEDICATED TO TRANSFORMING
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO
THAT IT IS MORE JUST EQUITABLE
FOR ALL PEOPLE. HE HAS WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO REFORM
CALIFORNIA'S PRE TRIAL SYSTEM
PREMIERED NEARLY FIVE YEARS NOW
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN EQUITY
FAIRNESS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE I WANT TO
GROUND UP IN A STORY BEEN
ERRORS YOU MEMBER. WHO SADLY
IT'S UNABLE TO BE WITH US TODAY.
RIGHT THE KOBE BAD RAP THANK.
IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR. BELL
SCHEDULE FOR PEOPLE BEING
CHARGED WITH LOWER LEVEL
OFFENSES ENACTED MEMBER WHO HAD
BEEN INTERNALLY STRUGGLING.
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES WAS
ARRESTED AND CHARGED WITH
VANDALISM. HIS BAIL WAS SET
WELL BEYOND THE MEANS OF WHAT
HE COULD AFFORD AND TRUTH BE
TOLD THIS YOUNG MAN WAS IN DIRE
NEED OF HELP AND SUPPORT
SERVICES. NOT COUNTY JAIL. A
WEEK LATER HE WAS MURDERED IN
COUNTY JAILS. WHAT HE REALLY
NEEDED WAS WRAPAROUND SERVICES
AND COMMUNITY SUPPORT BACKED OF
A R. C. OFTENTIMES LOW LEVEL
OFFENSES ARE CRIMES OF
DESPERATION AND OUTRIGHT YOU
WILL. NOT ONE THAT SIGNALS THE
FUTURE OF LIFE OF CRIME THE ONE
THAT SIGNALS THAT THEIR VERY
BASIC NEEDS ARE NOT BEING MET.
COUNTY JAIL CANNOT ONLY BE
TRAUMATIZING BUT EXACERBATES
UNDERLYING TRAUMAS IN
CONDITIONS IT'S NOT A PLACE OF
HEALING REHABILITATION OR
MATURATION. HOW DID YOU KNOW
THE PLACE WHERE YOU ARE QUICKLY
STRIPPED OF YOUR DIGNITY AND
CONTRACTS. IT'S A NATURAL THE
PROJECT THRILLED WITH DESPAIR
AND STEER. CLEAR OF WHAT LIES
AHEAD. YOUR EMPLOYER WOULD
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU HAVEN'T
SHOWED UP TO WORK HERE YOUR
CHILDREN WILL END UP IN THE
SYSTEM BECAUSE YOU ARE N JAIL.
HERE THAT YOU MAY BE FORCED
INTO A PLEA BARGAIN BECAUSE YOU
KNOW OUR SYSTEM HAS STOPPED
STOCKYARD AGAINST YOU OR WORSE.
DEATH ROBEL ORDER TEMPERED.
ALTHOUGH IT AND WANTED EFFECT
FROM APRIL TO JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY UNDER THIS ORDER WE DID
SEE A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION
COUNTY JAIL POPULATION ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND WE SAW NO REAL
SPIKE IN CRIMES FOR THOSE
OFFENSES WHICH WERE ZERO BELL
ELIGIBLE. YES FIFTY DATA SHOWS
A STATEWIDE DECREASE OF 30% AND
COUNTY JAIL POPULATIONS BETWEEN
FEBRUARY AND MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S
BELL SCHEDULE WAS ELECTED IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY I'VE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA SAID
THIRTY ONE COUNTIES WHICH
ACCOUNT FOR CLOSE 280% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION KEPT
INFORMED ZERO BELL SCHEDULE IN
PLACE. WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT
IF THEY KNEW THEY WERE IN A
BURDEN IMPACTS OF OBSCENE
SPIKES IN CRIME FOR THE WORK. A
REPORT PUBLISHED LAST OCTOBER
BY THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE
OF CALIFORNIA PROVED THAT THERE
WAS NO MAJOR SPIKE IN CRIME FOR
THOSE OFFENSES WHICH ARE YOUR
ABOUT ELIGIBLE. FOR THE MORNING
ANALYSIS BY KTVU WHICH ANALYZED
FIVE AREA COUNTIES ALAMEDA SAN
FRANCISCO CONTRA COSTA EMETERIO
IN SANTA CLARA FOUND THAT. IN
THE TIME CALIFORNIA HAD
INSTITUTED A ZERO BILL POLICY.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 3212% OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ALLOWED TO BAIL OUT FOR FREE
WERE REARRESTED. DURING ROUGHLY
A ONE TO TWO MONTH PERIOD WHICH
IS SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN
CALIFORNIA'S RECIDIVISM RATE
AND EVEN CONNECTION RIGHT. THE
PRETRIAL JUSTICE INSTITUTE
REPORTS THAT THE COST OF
SUPERVISING A PERSON IN THE
COMMUNITY LOS. WHAT HAD BEEN A
TRIAL IS 10% THAT OF THE COST
OF KEEPING THAT PERSON IN JAIL.
WHAT DATA THAT. WOULD DATA
SHOWING THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE RELEASED PRE TRIAL DO
NOT RE OFFEND AND THAT VERY
LITTLE IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
THEY SHOW UP TO COURT ON TIME.
THESE COSTS BOTH HUMAN AND
FINANCIAL. I JUST JUSTIFIABLE.
IT IS FOR THIS REASON THAT WE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION ALONG
WITH OUR PARKERS SPONSORS AND
SUPPORTERS URGE YOU TO VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THREE TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY
ARE THERE ANY. WITNESSES IN THE
INSTANCE OF. ANY WITNESS IN THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM IN
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES ONLINE
THERE IN SUPPORT. AT&T YOU MAY
ALLOW THE MEN. YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE'RE GOING TO THE LINE OF
ONE ZERO EIGHT THAT'S ONE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
CHRISTOPHER RESPONSIVE WITH
WESTERN CANNELLA POVERTY WE'RE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSORS BILL.
THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT SUPPORT
COMES FROM THE LINE OF ONE ZERO
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS JANICE
O'MALLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT SUPPORT
COMES FROM THE LINE OF SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AN OUTLINE NUMBER
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
SELAMAT CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT LINE IS
NUMBER NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ANYWAY WHAT
DOES THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. INTERNET
FLYING IN SUPPORT OF MY NUMBER
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. CANACCORD ARE MALAM
HAPPENED THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT LINE OF LINE NUMBER SIXTY
SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANTHONY DIMARTINO WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHTEEN DEFICITS
PROUD COSPONSORED EIGHTY THREE
THREE NINE AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA MARCHESI
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND OUR NEXT SUPPORT FLYING IS
ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BURKE FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS. THANK YOU. HELLO
NEXT LINE IS THE ONE HUNDRED
THAT'S ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE HAD.
YEAH COULD NOT CERTAIN AND IS
GOING TO HAVE TO. TERMS
COMPARABLE JUSTICE WERE
ACTUALLY A TWEENER CONDITIONS
PUT THE OVERALL DIRECTION THE
CORD TO CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSION
WITH THE OFFICE TALK ABOUT THE
SUGGESTED. CHANGES TO THE
LANGUAGE OF WITHOUT. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT LINE OF THE ONE FIFTY
TWO THE FINAL BILL ONE FIFTY
TWO. WE GOT THE ACT OUTSIDE
ORGANIZED APPRECIATE JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
LINE IS ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
UNACCEPTABLE LINE IS ONE OF
SIXTY ONE THE FINAL ONE SIXTY
ONE. KENDRYS DOLLAR ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE NEEDS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
LINE OF THE ONE THIRTY TWO LINE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RAVENNA CARBOXYL LEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE REPLY
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS INJURED WHICH
I SHARE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ONE OF THE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
THE FINAL ONE SIXTY SEVEN. YES
THIS IS NINETY HIGHER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THREE TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB YES THREE
TWENTY NINE A PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THEN WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE LAST LINE HERE WE
HAVEN'T HE WAS. ONE FORTY
SEVEN. MY NUMBER ONE POINT
MEMORANDA CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY NINE. K. ONE MOMENT HERE.
I'M NOT IN SUPPORT OF AB IS
THREE TWENTY NINE OF ONE AND
THEN ZERO. HERE WE ARE NOT
SHOWING ANY IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THE STRUCTURE. THANK YOU
ARE THERE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION NINA SOLANO BEST
WOMAN CRIME VICTIMS UNITED. AND
LARRY MORSE THE SECOND.
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. CEMENT YOU CAN GO
FIRST AS YOU. SUPPLEMENT AT.
KEEPING UP WITH COPIC I WOULD
GIVE IT FOR LARRY TECHNOPARK
THE FACT OKAY WHATEVER ORDER
YOU WANT BUT YOU STILL ON A LOT
OF PROGRESS I WOULD CALL FIX
THIS A SACRIFICE OKAY. NO
PROBLEM. SO MISTER MARSH.
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO HEAR FROM
YOU YOU BEGIN FIRST. MORSE DO
WE. HE MAY BE HAVING TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS EIGHTEEN T. O YOU
KNOW IF HE'S HAVING. TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS. WITH. THIS LET'S
DOUBLE CHECK WE DON'T TO LEAVE
HIM OUT EIGHT. IS A WAY WE CAN
DOUBLE CHECK TO SEE WHERE IT.
KIDDING I'M TAKING A LOOK HERE
HOLD ON ONE MOMENT. OKAY SO I
DON'T. SEE HIM IN THE MEDIA I
DON'T SEE HIM IN THE ROOM
ONLINE I DON'T FEEL BLIND.
HELLO I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
DROPPED- MISTER. BESSEMER I
GUESS YOU'RE HAVE TO GO FIRST
AND HOPEFULLY MISTER MORE
PSYCHED UP FOR GOING. HOPEFULLY
FEINSTEIN NINE- COUPLE MINUTES.
OKAY BONNEVAL CHAIR AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY NINE- PRIVATE FOOD
UNITED ALTHOUGH OF FACTORY THE
MEMBERS ABOUT THE SPORT DOES
RESPECTIVELY OPPOSED DE UM. THE
BILL FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
PRIVATE DID UNITED IS AN ARDENT
SUPPORTER OF THOUGHTFUL OF
WEALTH THAT A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM HOWEVER EIGHTY SIX TWO
SIX TWO I'M SORRY BETWEEN
TWENTY NINE IS NOT THAT. IT IS
NOT WELL THOUGHT OUT IN IT IN
THE BACK FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN MANY
WAYS AND A PARTICULAR IMPACTS
THE VICTIMS OF CRIME. HE THERE
IS NO PROVISION IN THIS BILL
PROVIDES FOR THE VOICE THAT
PICKED UP AND SPECIFICALLY AND
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
ARTICLE TWENTY EIGHT DATA
PROVIDES TO THE VICTIM CAN BE
HEARD AT A BAIL SENTENCING SO
THAT THEIR SAFETY IN PARTICULAR
CAN BE CONSIDERED ONE COMPANIES
RELEASED THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT PROVIDES THAT.
SECONDLY WHAT GIVES ME CONCERN-
AND GIVE THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
CONCERNS ON AB THREE TWENTY
NINE IS THE FACT THAT THIS IS
TARGETING BUT- BOTH LOCAL
OFFENDERS WILL INCLUDED IN THAT
OUR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFFENDERS
HATE CRIME OFFENDERS CHILD
ABUSE OFFENDERS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AND THESE VICTIMS
ARE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
POPULATION THAT WILL BE
AFFECTED BY PEOPLE BEING
RELEASED WITHOUT ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE MATHIS
FUTURES I THINK THAT MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMISSION- KNOW VERY WELL
THAT THAT IS THE MOST DANGEROUS
TIME FOR A VICTIM IS WHEN. HE
OR SHE ARE TRYING TO ESCAPE
THEIR ABUSERS AND TO HAVE
SOMEBODY RELEASED WITHOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY TO PLACE THEM
IN- GREAT VIOLENCE AND AGAIN
NOT. BEING ABLE TO BE HEARD
BEFORE THEY RELEASE IT IS
CRITICAL TO THE SAFETY AND THE
PUBLIC. SAFETY- I UNDERSTAND
THAT. ABOUT INCARCERATING
PEOPLE PAYING TO GET A I HAVE
RESPECT FOR THE- SITE WE ARE WE
TO WORK TOWARDS THAT IN FACT WE
ARE WORKING WITH A SUPPLEMENT
COOPER WHO HAS A BILL THAT
ADDRESSES THOSE ISSUES THAT I
BELIEVE IS MUCH MORE THAT IS A
WELL THOUGHT. OUT IN THE REALM
OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND I WOULD
URGE THE MEMBERS TO CONSIDER
THAT AND CONSIDER THAT WE NEED
TO FIND. A REMEDY THAT NOT ONLY
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE THAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO TRUST BUT
ALSO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF THE
VICTIMS. AND LASTLY I WOULD
URGE YOU TO ALSO LISTEN TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND VOTERS- JUST
TO NOTE THAT FOR WE HAD. AN
ISSUE DID. THAT TRY TO- AS
EFFECTIVELY AWAY. CAL AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S ISSUES THAT
THE WITH ARGUMENTS WILL THAT
WAS BASED ON THE SYSTEM SMALL
FROM THE VICTIM PERSPECTIVE.
WHO WAS A STRONG- UP AGAINST
THAT INITIATIVE CAME OUT STRONG
AND FINISH IT UP MANY CRAP. DAY
AGAIN FOR THE SAME REASONS THAT
ARE BRINGING. FORTH THAT THERE
WAS NO PROTECTIONS FOR OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS NO
BALANCE IN THE SYSTEM. I AGREED
THAT THE BILL SCHEDULE NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY CRIME VICTIM THAT
DOESN'T AGREE THAT THE BAIL
SCHEDULE NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
AND THAT PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE
INCARCERATED. JUST SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
MONETARY NEEDS. BUT THAT DOES
NOT MEAN THAT WE CAN JUST LET
THEM OUT WITHOUT CONSIDERATION
OF THE VICTIM'S SAFETY. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS AGAIN I WOULD STRONGLY
SUGGEST THAT MEMBERS TO LOOK AT
ASSEMBLY COOPER'S BILL AB
THIRTY EIGHT- AS AN
ALTERNATIVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND IT'S MISS SO. SOLANO
GOVERNMENT ALARM. NOW SULUR YES.
THANK YOU FOR TIME AND I THINK
I I'M SORRY VOICE IS KIND OF
SCRATCH. THE SURFACE IT'S MINE
JOB SO. MISTER MORRIS IF YOU
SEE ARE THERE. THE NUMBER IF
YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS GETTING
IN IS NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE
NINE. THREE SEVEN FOUR FOUR
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE A
THREE SEVEN FOUR FOUR THEY'RE
SHOWING YOU THERE BUT WE'RE NOT
GETTING. YOU TALK TO STAFF
RIGHT NOW SO HOPEFULLY AS WE GO
THROUGH SOME OF THE ME TOOS
THAT OPPOSE THE BILL MAYBE YOU
CAN COME IN. RIGHT AFTER THAT
SO THE ME TOOS. THERE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF A AB. THREE TWO
NINE. AT&T OPERATOR. LARRY
MOORE IS IN THAT THE RUMOR
ONLINE HE CAN DO STARZ ZERO AND
WE CAN GET HIS NAME AND FIND
HIS LINE IF HE'S IN THERE SO
THAT WOULD BE START THERE ALL.
HE'S ALREADY IN THERE. ARE WE
ARE LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION OF
AB AND THREE TWENTY NINE PLUS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE SOME QUEUING UP HERE. MAY
I BEGIN AT EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
NINE OPPOSITIONIST REPAIRMAN
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS
LARRY MORRIS. NUMBER EIGHT YES
LEARN MORE YEAH I CAN HEAR YOU
CAN. WHAT HE- I. WHAT ARE YOU
ARE YOU IN ON YOUR PHONE AND
YOU CAN OR YOU TO TURN DOWN
WE'RE GETTING SOME FEEDBACK.
NOW WE HAVE NOTHING IN. HOW
ABOUT NOW MISS ALL RIGHT THE
AGO. YOU MAY BE GALA ABOUT. YES
BEGIN I'M SORRY TO BE SUCH A
PAIN TECHNOLOGY IS A WONDERFUL-
THIS IS LAURIE MORE SOME BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY TWO WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THAT BAIL IN MOST
CRIMINAL OFFENSES TO. BE SET AT
ZERO AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA NO
DOUBT RECALLS FROM HIS
APPEARANCE AT THE CDA
CONFERENCE A FEW YEARS AGO ON
THE BAIL REFORM BILLS THAT HE
AND SENATOR HERTZBERG WERE
PURSUING CALIFORNIA'S ELECTED
DA'S RECOGNIZE AND EMBRACE THE
NEED FOR A BOTTLE BAIL REPORT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA KNOWS CDA
DID NOT OPPOSE THOSE BILLS NOR
DID IT OPPOSE PROPOSITION
TWENTY FIVE LAST NOVEMBER THIS
YEAR CDAC- IS SUPPORTING
CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER IS BILL
AB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN THAT
WOULD PUT AN END. TO THE UNFAIR
PRACTICE OF CHARGING YEARLY
BAIL RENEWAL PREMIUMS WE MUST
HOWEVER OPPOSE AB THREE TWENTY
NINE BECAUSE IN OUR VIEW IT
DOES NOT ADEQUATELY ACCOUNT FOR
THREATS TO PUBLIC SFETY THAT
WOULD LARGELY REMOVE THE
DISCRETION OF THE COURT TO SET
BAIL AS APPROPRIATE TO THE
FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCES OF A
GIVEN CRIME. AND HIS SHE
CHARGED CDA BELIEVES THAT AS WE
CONTINUE TO PURSUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ON BECAUSE GOAL TO
CREATE A FAIRER AND MORE
EQUITABLE BAIL SYSTEM WE MUST
BE CAREFUL TO BALANCE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF THE
ACCUSED WITH PROTECTING PUBLIC
SAFETY. UNFORTUNATELY SB TWO
SIXTY TWO REQUIRES THE COURT
SET BAIL AT ZERO FOR A WIDE
RANGE OF CRIMINAL CHARGES AND
CIRCUMSTANCES THE PRESENT AN
UNACCEPTABLE RISK TO THE
COMMUNITY FOR EXAMPLE THE COURT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO IMPOSE
ZERO BAIL ON MOST HATE CRIMES
AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE PAINFULLY
AWARE OF THEIR INCREASING
FREQUENCY AND MATHIS. ZERO BAIL
ALSO WOULD BE REQUIRED FOR SUCH
CRIMES IS WHAT THIS
INTIMIDATION AND FELONY
POSSESSION OF A WEAPON. THE
BILL ALSO DRAWS ARBITRARY USING
DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN ALLEGED
CRIMINAL CONDUCT FOR EXAMPLE A
PERSON CHARGED WITH MISDEMEANOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO BAIL THAT SAME
PERSON HOWEVER IF CHARGED WITH
SOME TYPES OF FELONY ELDER
ABUSE OR CHILD ABUSE. WITH A
COLD BREW AVAIL. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A ZERO HERE
LAST YEAR TO ME THE- OF NINE.
X. OF JAIL. WAS SPECIFICALLY TO
ON ABILITY OF THE COURT TO SET
BAIL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
INEXPLICABLY THAT LANGUAGE
BESTING DISCRETION WITH JUDGES
OUT OF THIS BILL. THERE IS
NOTHING UNDER CURRENT LAW THAT
PREVENTS THE COURT FROM
RELEASING AN ACCUSED ON HIS OR
HER OWN REQUIREMENTS FOR
SETTING BAIL. AND AS A
PROSECUTOR FOR TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS I SAW IT HAPPEN
REGULARLY. JUDGES FREQUENTLY
EXERCISED THIS PREROGATIVE TO
MAINTAIN FOR THE PARK FROM
SCHEDULED BAIL AFTER PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS AND THE DEFENSE.
CDA IS SUPPORTING ASSEMBLYMAN
COOPER'S AB THIRTY EIGHT BAIL
REFORM BILL THAT WOULD CREATE A
STATEWIDE BAIL SCHEDULE. TO BE
DETERMINED BY A GROUP OF JUDGES
SELECTED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WITH REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION CDA AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. STATEWIDE BAIL
SCHEDULE WOULD BE REVISED
ANNUALLY AND WOULD INCLUDE
PUBLIC INPUT. THIS APPROACHING
BETTER TAILORED TO ACHIEVING
UNIFORMITY AND FAIRNESS ONE
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC. A PERSON
CHARGED WITH A CRIME SHOULD
NEVER REMAIN IN CUSTODY SOLELY
BECAUSE HE OR SHE IS POOR. CDA
SUPPORTS THE CONTINUED EFFORTS
TO REFORM OUR BAIL SYSTEM
HOWEVER WE DO NOT BELIEVE AB
THREE TWO NINE IS THE BEST BE A
CALL FOR ACHIEVING. THAT GOAL
AND RESPECT WAS. THANK YOU
MISTER MOORE. NOW EIGHTEEN T.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION. AB THREE TWO
NINE WILL. YEP APR OPPOSITION
OF AB THREE TWO NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AND WE DO
HAVE ONE ONE THIRTY SIX PEOPLE
HAD. YES THANK YOU HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS PAUL BAUER ON BEHALF OF
ALL PRO BAIL BONDS. IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE TWENTY.
THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT LINE IS
ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SYDNEY HOFF WITH RESOLUTE ON
BEHALF OF THAT CALIFORNIA BAIL
AGENTS ASSOCIATION WHERE
OPPOSED OVER THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE CELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
LINE IS EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WAS THE COMMITTEE THIS IS JEFF
CLAYTON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE AMERICAN BAIL COALITION
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
OF THE ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY SAYS L.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
MAYBE THREE TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. IN OUR NEXT
LINE OF THE ONE OF SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
CAPPY WENCH REPRESENTING THE
GOLDEN STATE BAIL AGENTS
ASSOCIATION JAPAN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND OUR
FINAL OPPOSITION IN THE QUEUE
IS ONE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE
GROUND PRINT. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY CAN WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY MORE OPPOSITION HM. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR
LACKEY FIRST IN AND- YES WORK
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
WHY WOULD IS THERE NO RISK
ASSESSMENT ELEMENT IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION. MISTER LUCKY
THIS IS A DIFFERENT APPROACH
THAN SB TEN- ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
FIVE SB TEN AND PROP TWENTY
FIVE PROPOSED TO COMPLETELY
ELIMINATE MONEY BAIL AND
REPLACE IT WITH WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO A RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOL AS WELL AS THE BEAUTIFUL
DISCRETION AND- SETTING BAIL-
THIS IS BUILDING OFF SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE HAD IN PLACE DURING
THE PANDEMIC- AS WELL AS
APPROACH IS THAT HAVE OCCURRED
SUCCESSFULLY IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS LIKE NEW YORK NEW
JERSEY- KENTUCKY WHERE THERE
WAS- ZERO BAIL OR SITE RELEASE
THAT DIDN'T RELY ON BAIL. FIVE
WHICH LED TO MANY MORE PEOPLE
BE SAFELY RELEASED CRIME RATE
TO THE WENT DOWN OR HELD
STEADY- APPEARANCE RATES HELD
STRONG- RE OFFENSE- RATES I
DIDN'T DIDN'T MOVE SO WE THINK
IT'S AN APPROACH THAT CAN LEAD
TO MANY MORE PEOPLE BEING
SAFELY AND FAIRLY RELEASED
WITHOUT- THREATENING PUBLIC
SAFETY SO IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT
APPROACH I GUESS IS THE SHORT
ANSWER- TO YOUR QUESTION AND-
IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN SB TEN-
MONEY BAIL CONTINUES TO EXIST.
WITH THIS UP PROPOSAL TODAY-
WITH AB THREE TO THREE TWENTY
NINE BUT IT DOES HAVE
COMPONENTS OF ZERO BALANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY- CONSIDERATION
OF THE ABILITY. TO PASS AS SET
FORTH IN THE BILL. OKAY WILL
REGRETTABLY I WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. AS IT STANDS
CURRENTLY I ALSO BELIEVE IT'S
IN DIRECT CONTRAST TO THE-
EXPRESSED WILL OF THE PEOPLE-
BY PROPOSITION TWENTY FIVE IN
THE LAST ELECTION SO- THAT'S
TOTAL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS.
THANK YOU MR QUIRK. YES
ARAMBULA BY WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT I DO THINK
IT NEEDS SOME WORK- AND IN
LISTENING TO THE OPPOSITION
FROM THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S.
THE FACT THAT IT I DO THINK
THAT IT WOULD BE GOOD TO ALLOW
JUDGES SOME DISCRETION- IN-
THERE MAY BE PEOPLE OF
COMMITTED SOME OF THESE LESS
VIOLENT CRIMES. WHO THEY FEEL
NEED TO PAY BAIL OR PERHAPS
THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF NOT
SHOWING UP. WHATEVER IT IS I DO
THINK WE NEED THAT DISCRETION
IF IT'S NOT IN THE BILL- SECOND
I AM CONCERNED THAT. THE PEOPLE
WHO DO HAVE TO PAY BAIL MAY NOT
HAVE RECOURSE TO BAILS BONDSMEN.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
SINCE YOU REQUIRE THAT THE
MONEY ESSENTIALLY BE GIVEN 95%
OF IT BE GIVEN BACK I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY WILL BE IN THE
BAIL BOND BUSINESS. AND LAST
WEEK WE- SET BAIL AT A MUCH
LOWER AMOUNT WHICH WOULD BE A
GOOD SOLUTION MAYBE 10% OF WHAT
THEY TYPICALLY IS TODAY FIVE
THOUSAND INSTEAD OF FIFTY.
THAT'S PROBABLY ENOUGH TO GET
PEOPLE TO SHOW UP. SO IF WE
WERE TO REACH RESET THE SYSTEM.
I'D BE IN FAVOR OF JUST
BRINGING EVERYTHING DOWN 90% I
THINK THAT WOULD BE A BETTER
APPROACH- FOR THE POPLE THAT
YOU'RE YOU DO NEED TO KEEP IN
JAIL AND AGAIN A JUDGE CAN
ALWAYS SAY. WE WILL NOT ALLOW
BAILIN THIS CASE SO THINK
ABOUT THOSE THINGS AS A AND NO
NO GOOD BILL GOES UNCHANGED
ISSUE. SO JUST THINK ABOUT
THOSE THINGS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR BONTA. I THANK THANK
YOU SOMEBODY CALLED MEMBER
QUICKER OF. REBEKAH BACK K. AND
HAS A QUESTION DID YOU WANT TO
ASK I DID YEAH THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL FOR OTHERS WHO ARE
ASKING QUESTIONS ALONG SIMILAR
LINES BUT JUST WANT TO THANK
SOMEONE FOR CORPORATES ALWAYS
THOUGHTFUL INPUT. I DO WANT TO
REITERATE THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT A POPULATION THAT IS
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED OF
ANYTHING. AT THIS STAGE IN THE
CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT NOTHING IN THIS
BILL CONFLICTS WITH. ARTICLE
ONE SECTION TWENTY EIGHT OF THE
CONSTITUTION WHICH DOES GIVE
JUDGES TIME MR COURTS POINT
DISCRETION TO DETAIN PRE TRIAL-
WHEN ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY SO IF
THAT IS NOT CLEAR TO THE
OPPOSITION- WE WILL SEEK TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR- AND WE DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF THE BILL WHICH
SEEKS TO HAVE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. SET A UNIFORMED BELL
SCHEDULE PERHAPS IT WILL BE 90%
LESS THAN THE CURRENT BILL
NUMBERS- I THINK THEY WILL
CERTAINLY AKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT THE FACT
THAT WE ARE THE HIGHEST IT HAS
BILLS SCHEDULED IN THE NATION-
WENT WHEN SETTING THAT AND WE
DO HAVE A COMPUTER IN THE BILL.
WHICH WILL AWAIT THAT THE-
GUIDANCE OF THE HUMPHRIES CASE
WHICH SHOULD BE COMING DOWN THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS. WHICH
PROPOSES TO ALLOW FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE ABILITY TO
PAY BAIL- BY INDIVIDUALS NOT
FIXING THEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THIS K. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I THIS IS AND IMPORTANT
AND EFFORT AND CONVERSATION AND
I WAS PLEASED TO HEAR THAT
EVERYONE THE OPPOSITION
INCLUDED AGREES THAT OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM WHERE ONE
REMAINS INCARCERATED MERELY
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PAY AND
THEIR POOR IS A BROKEN SYSTEM.
AND ONE THAT DESPERATELY NEEDS
TO BE FIXED BECAUSE THE
QUESTION BEFORE ANY COURT WHEN
DECIDING WHO SHOULD BE HELD
WHEN INNOCENT BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING FREE TRIAL SHOULD BE
WHO IS A REST OUR COMMUNITY NOT
WHO CAN PAY AND THE FACT THAT.
IN MY COMMUNITY WE HAVE SOMEONE
WHO IS LED OUT WHO WASN'T RISK
BECAUSE HE HAD THE MEANS TO PAY
FOR IT AND THAT THAT TOO IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE NEED TO BE A
HOLDING THOSE WHO POSE A RISK
AND ALLOWING THOSE WHO DO NOT
POSE A RISK TO OUR COMMUNITY.
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND TO
KEEP THEIR JOB AND KEEP A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPLICATIONS OF
BEING INCARCERATED BEFORE YOUR
TRIAL IN BEFORE YOU'VE BEEN
FOUND GUILTY AND THEN UNTIL
THAT HAPPENS ONE SHOULD BE ABLE
IF THEY'RE NOT A RISK TO
SOCIETY TO MAINTAIN THAT- THOSE
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF THEIR
LIFE. THAT BEING SAID I SHARE A
LOT OF THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION- AND OF MY COLLEAGUE.
THAT THIS BILL'S FAILURE TO
PROVIDE ANY. RISK ASSESSMENT OR
JUDICIAL DISCRETION LEAVES US
OPEN TO INDIVIDUALS WHO DO POSE
A RISK TO OUR COMMUNITIES BEING
LED OUT AND I GUESS I DO READ
IT DIFFERENTLY THAN YOU DO I
DON'T BELIEVE IT- MAINTAINS THE
DISCUSSION HELD UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION I READ THE BILL TO
REQUIRE COURTS FOR THOSE
CHARGED WITH THESE OFFENSES TO
LET THEM OUT OF ZERO BALANCE
NOT THE CONCERN OF MINE SO IF
YOU DO CLARIFY THAT THAT'S- I
THINK. A GOOD AMENDMENT THAT
WILL HOPEFULLY BE TAKEN IN THE
FUTURE BUT I'M GLAD THAT THERE
ARE SEVERAL BILLS MOVING IN
THIS SPACE I'M GLAD WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION I LOOK
FORWARD TO A BILL THAT I THINK
STRIKS THAT BALANCE OF
ENSURING THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
OUR COMMUNITY AND NOT
INCARCERATING PEOPLE FOR BEING
INDIGENT- BUT I CAN'T AT THIS
POINT- SUPPORT IT BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK IT YET STRIKES THE
RIGHT BALANCE IN PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU.
COMMENTED INPUT. SENILE YOU MAY
CLOSE RESTAURANT WELL I JUST
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE ACTIVE
LISTENING AND THE VERY HELPFUL
COMMENTS SO THE FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE THE FIRST HOUSE I
WILL DEFINITELY TAKE A
CONSIDERATION YOUR YOUR ADVICE
COUNSEL AND INSIGHT AS WE SEEK
TO IMPROVE THE BILL- I
APPRECIATE IT FROM FROM ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES AS WE TRY TO
IMPROVE IT I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S A PERFECT SYSTEM- MY
BELIEF IS THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE- WE DO HAVE
WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO COULD OR
WOULD DO HARM. TO OTHERS WHO
ARE PAYING THE WAY OUT AND-
AND- POSING A RISK TO THE
COMMUNITY WE HAVE FOLKS WERE
ABSOLUTELY NO RISK WILL COME TO
OTHER HEARING TOOK SIMPLY CAN'T
BE RELEASED BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY BECAUSE
THEY'RE POOR BUT THAT IS WRONG
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO CHANGE IT
HOW WE CHANGE IT IS UP FOR-
IMPORTANT DEBATE SB TEN WAS A
PROPOSAL- HAD SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS TO IT HAD
SOME DOCTOR PRETTY CONTROVERSY
THIS IS ON ANOTHER RUN AT
STRENGTHENING AND MAKE IT MORE
FAIR- THE SYSTEM WE THINK THAT.
WHILE IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT IT
GOES A LONG WAY TOWARDS BEING
BOTH SAFE AND FAIR YOU CAN AND-
WE MUST DO BOTH THEY ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE- SO. WE
THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT STARTING POINT. YOUR
INPUT TODAY. AND ASK YOUR- I
THANK YOU MR BY NOTED THE IS A
VERY NOT ONLY TO YOU BUT SET
SEVERAL MEMBERS INDIA IN THE
ASSEMBLY- THE DATE THE COMMENTS
FROM SOLANO BEST WOMEN IN IN
MISTER MORSE ARE WELL TAKEN-
RIGHT NOW. IT LOOKS LIKE THIS
COMMITTEE DIDN'T HAVE ALL THE
ALL THE INFORMATION ON HEARING
OF A COOPER BUILT THAT I
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT I'M JUST NOT HEARING
ABOUT IT- I. WOULD THE
TROUBLING PART IS SETTING UP A
COMMISSION OF ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS PROBABLY A
NONSTARTER SO IT LET'S MAKE
SURE AND I KNOW HAVING RISK
ASSESSMENT AS YOU AND I KNOW.
THIS IS PROBABLY A NONSTARTER
FOR THE FOR THE- THE PRO SIDE-
THERE. AND I WANT THIS
COMMITTEE. TWO ULTIMATELY THESE
MEMBERS HERE THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT NOW TO WEIGH IN
HEAVILY ON HOW THIS ULTIMATELY
IS AND AS MISTER MISTER QUIRKS
OF HIS SAGE WISDOM SAID NO BILL
GETS OUT HERE UNTOUCHED OR
UNCHANGED AND SO- I WOULD ASK
THAT WE MOVE THIS BILL OUT
KNOWING THAT IT GOES TO
APPROPRIATIONS. KNOWING THAT MR
WHATEVER OTHER BILLS IF THERE'S
MORE THAN ONE DOT COM WILL HAVE
TO COME OUR WAY. AND WE CAN WE
CAN AND WHICH IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS A PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WE CAN
ACTUALLY PROBABLY. TRY TO CRAFT
POLICY COMPROMISED A CRAFT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL MOVE
FORWARD WITH BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE DAY- SPECIALLY MY
COMMUNITY- ENDING CASH BAIL ON
POOR PEOPLE IS EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AND- WHAT
I'M HEARING AND I MAY BE WRONG
WHAT I'M HEARING IS EVERYONE.
AS THE BRIDGE IS SPECIALLY HERE
AGREES WE SHOULD HAVE SOME KIND
OF- JUST BAIL SYSTEM. WHATEVER
YOU WANNA CALL IT FOUR ZERO
BAIL. OR RISK ASSESSMENT BAIL
OR WHATEVER OR JUDGE JUDICIAL
BURIAL- I THINK IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY HERE- TO WORK
WITH YOU. AND ANY OTHERS TO
KIND OF. TRYING TO CRAFT DATA
INTO IT'S ONE THING SO I'M
ASKING- ALL. MEMBERS IF YOU
CAN'T THE MOVE THIS OUT KNOWING
THAT WE HAVE OTHERS COMING IN.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY TO HOPEFULLY
CRAFT SOMETHING. THAT WE'RE NOT
WE GET OUT OF OUR HOUSE BUT
WE'LL GET OUT OF THE OTHER
HOUSE AND THAT- SAYS IT IS AN
ASSEMBLY BILL. REGION WE CAN
LOOK AT IT AND BE VERY PROUD OF
IT BECAUSE WE CRAFTED THE FINAL
DISSOLUTION. THAT'S WHEN ASKING
FOR A LITTLE. CALL THE ROLL. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. MISS WHICH
MOVED IT MISTER CREEK SECOND.
ON AB THREE TWENTY NINE BY
SEVEN MEMBER BONTA THE MISSION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES YOU'RE A LACKEY
LACKEY NO BARRICADE CAN. WORK
HIGH COURT I SAN DIEGO. SAY OUR
TO. SEE OUR TURNOUT WICKS HI
WICKS I LI. LI I THAT MEASURE.
MEASURES ON CALL WE NEED MORE
MORE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THINK RAP
THANK YOU. MR CHAN. I ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB. FOUR ZERO.
THREE ZERO EIGHT CHEN AUTO
BURGLARY TASK FORCE SAYS CLARO.
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU MEMBERS
ARE FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT
TO START OFTEN BY PRAISING HER
EXCELLENT STAFF THE PROVIDING
OF THE PROFESSIONALISM THAT AND
THEIR EXPERTISE IN OUR BILL I'M
HERE PERCENT AB THREE ZERO
EIGHT A BILL THAT WOULD CREATE
A VEHICLE BURGLARY AND AUTO
THEFT TASK FORCE AND THREE
MULTI COUNTY REGIONS SAN DIEGO
LOS ANGELES AND THE BAY AREA.
THAT COVERAGE A LARGE PORTION
OF OUR STATE THE TASK FORCE
WILL IDENTIFY AND APPREHEND
CRIMINALS WHO STEAL VEHICLES
VEHICLE PARTS AS WELL THOSE WHO
BREAK INTO VEHICLES TO STEAL
THE BELONGINGS INSIDE. THIS
BILL WOULD ASSIST LOCAL
AGENCIES BY SHARING INFORMATION
OBTAIN PROPER EQUIPMENT AND
DEVELOPING BEST PRACTICES TO
TACKLE THIS NEW FORM OF
ORGANIZED CRIME IN RECENT YEARS
VEHICLE BURGLARIES HAVE BEEN A
GROWING ISSUE IN THE BAY AREA
THERE'S NOW A RISING CONCERN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC MULTIPLE NEWS
ARTICLES HAVE REPORTED GAINS
FROM THE BAY AREA WE'RE COMING
TO PARTS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND OTHER COURSES
NATION'S SPECIFICALLY TARGETING
VEHICLES THAT WERE LIKELY
RENTED BY TOURISTS. THESE
TARGETS WERE DESIRABLE SINCE
THE VICTIM WAS LIKELY UNABLE TO
RETURN TO TESTIFY IN COURT. AND
PROVE THAT THEIR VEHICLE DOORS
WERE LOCKED AT THE TIME OF THE
INCIDENT. THE VICTIM'S ABSENCE
HAS LED TO A VEHICLE BREAK INS
AND THEFTS GOING UNPUNISHED FOR
MANY YEARS. SINCE COVER
NINETEEN SHUT DOWNS YEARS AGO.
VEHICLE THEFTS AND BURGLARIES
HAVE SKYROCKETED WHILE MANY
OTHER CRIMES HAVE DECREASED.
CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS REQUIRE
VEHICLES TO THROW AND TO KNOW
HOW CALIFORNIA VOTERS ARE BEING
EQUITY IN THEIR VEHICLES
CURRENTLY. JUST LAST WEEK I HAD
A CONSTITUENT CALL- BEGGING THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE INCREASING THEFT OF
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS. THESE
PARTS HAVE BECOME A POPULAR
TARGET BY THIEVES DUE TO
DIFFICULTY IN TRACKING CADILLAC
INVERTERS. COURTS SINCE THERE'S
NO SERIAL NUMBER ATTACHED TO
THE CAR. VEHICLE CRIMES HAVE
RISEN TO INTOLERABLE LEVELS
ACROSS STATE AS A WHOLE. I HAVE
SHARED WITH THE COMMITTEE
PROPOSE ALTERNATIVES THAT WILL
GO INTO THE PRINT IF THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. YOU MEMBERS OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU- WITH THAT-
WILL PASS THIS INFORMATION TO
ONE OF THE- I WILL MISS
TESTIMONY WITH MR RAIMES FROM
AND FROM THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RANGE FROM
A WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND PALACE VERDES
IN SANTA ANA POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION FOR ALL IN STRNG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE AWAY- ONE
FORSMAN EXISTENCE WHICH IS
LOCAL DEPARTMENTS M. SIXTY HAVE
ALL COMMENTED ON DRAMATIC
INCREASE. OF AUTO RELATED
CRIMES IN THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS IT'S OBVIOUSLY- BROWN
EXPONENTIALLY. DURING THIS TIME
OF COPAYS. AB THREE OH EIGHT
SIX TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION BY
ESTABLISHING THE VEHICLE
BURGLARY AND THEFT TASK FORCE
BUT STATEWIDE COORDINATED
EFFORT TO PROVIDE STATE FUNDING
TO IDENTIFY APPREHEND. AND
PREVENT CRIMINALS UP BREAKING
THE VEHICLE TO STEAL PERSONAL
BELONGINGS ANALYTICAL ITSELF.
THIS BILL WILL ASSIST LOCAL
AGENCIES BY ALLOWING THEM TO
SHARE INFORMATION ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS ABOUT CARD PASSED
THE BURGLARY. AND TO DEVELOP
BEST PRACTICES. THE SHARING OF
INTELLIGENCE BETWEEN THE TASK
FORCE AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THE SPECIFIC VEHICLE
BURGLARY AND THEFT ACTIVITIES.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
SCOPE OF INTELLIGENCE THAT IS
CURRENTLY SHARED. THE ALLOCATED
MONEY IS DEPENDENT ON THE
REGION'S NEEDS AND COULD BE
TOWARD PUT TOWARDS SALARIES
EQUIPMENT AND TRAVEL REPRESENTS
THE NATURE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT ARE HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY VEHICLE RELATED
CRIMES. THIS UPDATED EQUIPMENT
WILL PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH THE ADEQUATE TOOLS NEEDED.
TO STOP CAR BURGLARIES. THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
ESTABLISH AN APPOINTMENT A
JOINT INVESTIGATIVE TEAMS THAT
WILL BE DESIGNED TO CONSTRUCT
EFFORTS IN AREAS IN THE STATE
EXPERIENCING A HIGH RATE OF
THESE CRIMES. THEY CONTINUE
OFFICES BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRANSLATIONALLY TRAINING AND A
COOPERATIVE EFFORTS BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES STATEWIDE
WILL REDUCE THIS TREND AS WELL
AS INCREASE THE PERCENTAGE OF
STATEWIDE VEHICLE. RECOVERED IN
THE FUTURE FOR THESE REASONS.
THREE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN A ROOM
AND SUPPORT SEEN NONE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM. HEARING
NONE- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE LINE. YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BY ONE
THEN ZERO NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY IN Q. MISTER. WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- UP SORRY I DON'T SEE
ANY OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. NO
RIGHT IT ENTITLED ORVILLE
THOMAS IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER.
SUPPOSED TO BE ON THE PHONE. I
DO NOT SHOW HIM ENOUGH. AT ALL.
AGAIN MISTER THOMAS IF YOU'RE
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING IN IS
916-319-3744. ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION ONLINE WHILE WAITING
FOR MISTER THOMAS TO GET IN.
AT&T OPERATOR YOU SEE ANYONE.
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION. APR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
SENATE. ZERO AND I DO NOT SEE
ANYBODY IN QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
STRIKER. AND AGAIN MISTER
THOMAS. 916-319-3744 IF YOU'RE
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING IN. AND
IF HE IS ON THE LINE HE CAN DO
STAR THAN ZERO AND WE CAN CATCH
IS LINE. STARRED IN ZERO MISTER
THOMAS. I DO NOT SEE HIM
SHOWING UP AT ALL. K. THEY WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE AND
IF MISTER THOMAS COMES IN WE
CAN ALWAYS LET HIM AND LATER.
AS A RECALL. IN ELECTED.
CERTAINLY I'D- I RECOGNIZE THIS
IS A VERY BIG PROBLEM AND I'LL
BE ADDRESSING A BILL. LATER ON
TO THIS COMMITTEE THAT
ADDRESSES ANOTHER ASPECT OF
THIS VERY. DEEPLY TROUBLING
CIRCUMSTANCE. I PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED THIS NOT THAT LONG
AGO PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC AND-
IT'S A- IT'S A BIG FRUSTRATION.
AND IT'S A SITUATION WHERE. A
LOT OF THESE AUTO BURGLARY
FOLKS ARE COMMITTING THIS
OFFENCE MULTIPLE MULTIPLE TIMES
DURING THE- ONE DAY AND IT'S A
IT'S A WIDESPREAD PROBLEM IN A
LOT OF IT. HAS TO DO WITH THE-
TOURISM- RENTAL CARS IT'S A
VERY COMMON OCCURRENCE BECAUSE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF THE VICTIM
SHOWING UP. AS A VERY REMOTE
AND OTHERS NUMBER ASKS ASPECTS
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS- THIS
PARTICULAR PROBLEM AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR FOR BRING THIS
FOR. THANK YOU MR CLARK. YES
IT'S A PROBLEM AND ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS AND I AGAIN
APPRECIATE IT AND I WANT TO SAY
THAT- WE HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS
BROUGHT FORWARD BY A REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS TODAY WHICH I THINK ARE
EXCELLENT. AND I'M ATTENDING TO
SUPPORT ALL OF THEM AND- WELL
DONE. THANK YOU TO WORK CYPRESS
COMING FROM YOU SIR. MR LEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS REGARDING THIS BILL
IS THERE ANY CURRENT LAW THAT
PREVENTS RIGHT NOW REGIONAL
TASK FORCE FROM OPERATING THE
WAY YOU'D WANT THEM TO OPERATE
FROM COORDINATING TOGETHER.
FEDERAL HIGHWAY PATROL HAS
SOMETHING- CURRENTLY IN LINE
HOWEVER THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE FINANCIAL REVENUE CURRENTLY
TO HAVE A SUSTAINABLE MODELS
UNDERSTAND IT. ADDITIONALLY
THERE IS NO FORMAL STANDARDS
HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
WORK TOGETHER. ON THIS RIGHT
NOW HAS A OFTEN PROCESS SO EVEN
THOUGH IN THIS CURRENT BILL
THAT'S L. A. COUNTY SANTA
COUNTY AND- AREAS AND- THE BAY
AREA- OTHER COUNTIES. HAVE THE
OPTION TO COME IN AT TO THIS
CONTEST WORSE. I ALSO SAW THAT
WELL THERE'S A LOT OF THOUGHT
INTO WHAT THIS COULD BE FUNDED
FOR THE STRUCTURE FOR
APPLICATION THE GRANTS I DON'T
SEE A FUNDING MECHANISM FOR IT
I KNOW THIS POLICIES OFFICE OR
I'M SORRY. IS COMMITTEES
OBVIOUSLY- GOVERNING THE POLICY
OF IT HOW MUCH DO YOU I'D
IDEALLY. ENVISIONED THE GRASS
TO BE HOW MUCH IT WOULD COST
THE STATE AND I'M JUST
WONDERING HOW HOW YEAH WONDER
HOW MUCH YOU TO ENVISION THE
TOTAL PRESS THREE. SUMMER
WITHOUT SAFE AND HAS A QUESTION
A CURRENT ESTIMATES OF STATE
THAT IT COULD COST AS MUCH AS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
CERTAINLY AS WE MOVE FOR- WE'RE
TRULY OPEN TO. OPEN THE LINES
OF COMMUNICATION TO DISCUSSION
OF HOW WE CAN MITIGATE SOME OF
THE- COSTS OF THE PROPOSAL.
THAT'S GOOD WELL THAT'S GOOD TO
HEAR THAT IT'S TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT. COULD BE PROPOSED
TO BE FUNDED WHEN OF COURSE
WE'RE ALSO STRUGGLING TO
AFFORD. MANY OF OUR SOCIAL
SERVICES AND OUR SCHOOLS SO
IT'S GOOD TO KNOW THE FIGURE
THAT IS ENVISIONED BY THIS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SUMMER. THANK YOU. WITH WITH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- IN THE
LETTER THAT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRATION POLICY CENTER
SUBMITTED IN TERMS OF THEIR
OPPOSITION- THEY TALKED ABOUT
CONCERNS AROUND PRIVACY RUN
DATA SHARING- THEY ALSO TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW TASK FORCE
HAVING A LONG HISTORY OF
HARMING LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
RACIAL PROFILING- AND CREATING
KIND OF. A CLIMATE OF FEAR-
PARTICULARLY IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR- AND SPECIFICALLY FOR
NONCITIZENS THERE AT THE RISK
OF DATA GOING TO ICE AND OTHER
FEDERAL AGENCIES. WHICH I DO
SHARE THAT CONCERN CAN YOU
ADDRESS SOME OF THAT AND YOU
KNOW HOW YOU PLANNING HANDLING
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SOMEONE WAKES. UP THE
INFORMATION THE STATE IS
ALREADY BEING SHARED BETWEEN
AGENCIES. IT DOESN'T EXPAND THE
CONTENT OF INFORMATION THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING SHARED- NOR
WILL THERE BE ANY QUESTIONS IN
THE AREAS. OF THEIR CITIZENSHIP
THAT IS COMPLETELY PRIVATE. AND
WHAT'S THE SORT OF OVERSIGHT OF
THIS TASK FORCE. WILL BE
BETWEEN THE AGENCIES THEMSELVES.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU SOME
NUMBER. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU
MAY CLOSE- I APPRECIATE ALL THE
QUESTIONS- AND CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD AS THIS IS THE FIRST
PROCESS IN THIS HOUSE AND AS
THIS IS WILL BE DOUBLE REFERRED
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND FUTURE COMMITTEES
ON SOME THE QUESTION THAT YOU
HAVE TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THOUGHTS AND CONCERNS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHEN I DO BELIEVE
DOING A TASK FORCES IS THE WAY
TO GO SO WE CAN IRON OUT A LOT
OF THESE THESE PROBLEMS AND IN
THE MOST IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WORKING ON A
LOT OF TIMES WE DO LOS AND THEN
WE DON'T KNOW HOW IT'S
IMPLEMENTED SO GETTING TOGETHER
AND FIGURING OUT. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU MISTER. MAY CALL THE ROLL
OUT OF SECTOR. AB THREE OH
EIGHT BY SEVEN MEMBER CHEN THE
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER ADDED
LACKEY LACKEY I BARRICADE HAN.
CORK BY CORK I SANTIAGO CA ARE
TOO HIGH THE ARE TOO HIGH WICKS.
WICKS NOT VOTING. LEE PLEASE I.
THE TECHNICIAN THAT MEASURE
PASSES GRADUATION MECHANISM
THANK YOU MEMBERS. HI MISS
DAVIES A. B. FOUR ONE NINE ITEM
NUMBER SIX CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
VICTIM AND WITNESS PRIVACY.
WE'RE NOT YOUR FIRST COMMITTEE
ACT PARK YOUR MY SECOND SET. NO
YOU'RE LIKE MY SECOND BILL I
SHOULD SAY THAT OKAY. ALREADY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB FOUR ONE NINE I FIRST
LIKE TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY STAFF TO AMEND
THE BILL IN A WAY THAT CLEARED
UP ANY CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. UNDER CURRENT LAW
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION ABOUT A VICTIM OR
WITNESS SUCH AS SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER BIRTHDATE EMPLOYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER AND
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION AMONGST A
HOST OF OTHER THINGS ARE NOT
PROTECTED DEFENDED OR THEIR
FAMILY COULD REQUEST AND
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION
WITHOUT A COURT ORDER. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE IN CASES
INVOLVING FRAUD OR THEFT. WHERE
THE CRIMINAL DISCOVERY MAY
INCLUDE A TREASURE TROVE OF
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION SUCH AS EMAIL
ACCOUNTS DATE OF BIRTH SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS BANK RECORDS
CREDIT CARDS AND DRIVER'S
LICENSE. AB FOUR ONE NINE IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO PROTECT
CERTAIN TYPES OF PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION THAT
CAN BE DISCLOSED TO A DEFENDANT.
IF SUCH INFORMATION IS NEEDED
BY THE DEFENSE TO BUILD THE
CASE THIS BILL KEEPS CURRENT
LAW IN TAPPED. BY ALLOWING THE
COURT TO REQUIRE THAT
INFORMATION TOGETHER. AB FOUR
ONE NINE HAS POTENTIAL TO HELP
THE VICTIMS AND WITNESSES OF
CRIME THE PEACE OF MIND THAT IF
THEY COME FORWARD WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CASE. THE
STATE CAN PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE INFORMATION ABOUT
THEM. THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCEOF
BAR ASSOCIATIONS AND I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. WITH ME TODAY VIA
PHONE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
IS MICHAEL FOR ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR THANK YOU MOVE THE
BILL. SECOND I DO. YOU HAVE A
WITNESS IF YOU HAVE A WITNESS.
BOB MICHAEL FERN THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF BAR ASSOCIATIONS
YES SIR. IS HE ON THE PHONE. AT.
EIGHT EIGHT AT&T CAN YOU FIND
MR FERN. HIS MIND IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- I AM OF THE
FIRM. IF WE CAN HEAR YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU MISTER
BURN. YOU MAY BEGIN YEAH FIVE
MINUTES. CERTAINLY UP MY NAME
IS MICHAEL BYRNE- MY VIEWS
DON'T NECESSARILY REFLECT THOSE
OF MY EMPLOYER WHICH THE L. A.
COUNTY DA'S OFFICE I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONFERENCE
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATION-
WHICH COMPRISED MURATSUCHI
ACROSS CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
THIRTY DELEGATES FROM EVERY
AREA PEOPLE PRACTICE IN
CRIMINAL LAW- FIFTY BE A
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING
ADMINISTRATION JOB THIS IN
CALIFORNIA PRACTICAL PROBLEM
SOLVING LEGISLATION. THIS
MEASURE- BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
AB FOUR ONE NINE SIX IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY BY UPDATING
THIRTY YEAR OLD LANGUAGE IN
CALIFORNIA'S PROBLEMS THAT
REACT. NPR PROTECTION TEN FOUR
POINT TWO. WHICH PROTECTS THE
INFORMATION THAT BY PROTECTING
THE PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION OF VICTIMS
WITNESSES. CURRENTLY THE LAW
ALLOWED HELPFUL NUMBERS AND
ADDRESSES TO BE DISCLOSED TO
THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY AND
DEFENSE INVESTIGATORS BUT
RESTRICTS FURTHER
DISSEMINATION. OF THAT
INFORMATION- AFTER THE COURT
APPROVED SHOWING OF NEED. AB
FOUR ONE NINE WOULD EXTEND THE
PROTECTIONS INCLUDE A VICTIM OR
WITNESS IS PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION GENERALLY PUBLIC
SPECIFIED EXCEPTIONS- AND THAT
IS WHY PPBM SUPPORTERS UP IN
THE SPONSOR OF EIGHTY FOUR ONE
NINE- BELIEVING THAT ADVANCE
THE GOAL OF PUBLIC SAFETY-
ADVANCING THE GOAL OF
MODERNIZING LAW AND URGES
COMMITTEE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
AUDIENCE. ANY OTHER WHICH IS IN
SUPPORT OF VIDEO CONFERENCING.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES AT&T
AND SUPPORT ON THE LINE. AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. SEEN NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE- ED
IN THE- CONFERENCE ROOM
TELECONFERENCE ROOM. AND NOW
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. AT&T AS
CHAIR MEMBERS SECURE MEMBERS
RANGE FROM AGAIN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALSO TODAY- IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THE BILL
CALIFORNIA COALITION SCHOOL
SAFETY PROFESSIONALS LOS
ANGELES SCHOOL POLICE
ASSOCIATION SANTA ANA POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AMPLE
STORIES POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. ALL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AS A REMINDER PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. THANK YOU ARE NAY
QUESTIONS FROM FROM MEMBERS.
MISS REBECCA BAUER CAN'T. THINK
HERE- FIRST ONE IS AB THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY THE PROTECTION OF
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES IS
CRITICAL IN GETTING JUSTICE IN
OUR SYSTEM I HAD A QUESTION
OBVIOUSLY THE BILL ALLOWS FOR
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS TO RECEIVE
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
REPAIRED OFFENSE HAS IS. MAKES
SENSE- OBVIOUSLY IN HEARING A
DEFENSE AND WORKING WITH A
CLIENT AND DEFENSE ATTORNEY
ENGAGES IN AN ANALYSIS OF WHAT
THE CHANCES ARE OF WINNING YOUR
CASE TO COURT IN PLAYING OUT
XCERRA AND SO DOING IS IN
CONVERSATION WITH THEIR CLIENTS
ABOUT THE CASE- OBVIOUSLY IN
THAT THERE'S NO NEED TO SHARE
TELEPHONE NUMBERS ADDRESSES
ETCETERA I GUESS MY CONCERN IS
THAT IN THAT CONVERSATION
SHOULD. THE EMPLOYER FOR
EXAMPLE OR THE NATURE OF THE
WORK AND THE INDIVIDUAL AND
VICTIM COME UP IN THE
ASSESSMENT OF THE CASE THAT
WOULD SEEM LIKE A VIOLATION OF
THIS LAW SO I JUST WANTED TO
TOUCH ON THAT BRIEFLY BECAUSE I
THINK THAT RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE ATTORNEY AND THE CLIENT IS
REALLY CRITICAL. WELL I CAN
TELL YOU AT LEAST AT THIS POINT
RIGHT NOW AND WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW ANY TYPE OF
PENALTY THAT COMES FOUR EIGHT.
AND A CURRENT LAW RIGHT NOW HAS
IT THAT IF THE DEFENSE CONSERVE
VIOLATES THIS PROVISION NOT
ONLY WAS IT A DISHONEST METER
BUT- THEY'RE ALSO SUBJECT TO
PENALTY AND POTENTIAL DISPARITY
FROM THE STATE BAR. AND I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A SUFFICIENT
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH PENALTY.
RAISE MY QUESTION IS IN THE
PENALTY ON THE ATTORNEY THE
QUESTION IS. I GUESS MY CONCERN
IS COULD- TO ATTORNEY BE BARRED
FROM HAVING AN HONEST
CONVERSATION WITH THEIR CLIENT
ABOUT THE CASE BECAUSE THE
BREADTH OF THE INFORMATION THAT
IS NOT PROTECTED. IS SO WIDE.
RIGHT NOW YOU CAN'T GIVE I MEAN
IT WAS BEFORE I BELIEVE
TELEPHONE NUMBER ADDRESS IS
JUST AS TO ADDRESS THOSE TWO
THINGS WHICH IS EASY AS A
DEFENSE ATTORNEY TO HAVE A-
FULL CONVERSATION WITH A QUITE
WITHOUT GIVING UP THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT NECESSARY.
HOWEVER I CAN IMAGINE AS THE
OPPOSITION POINTS OUT
SITUATIONS WHERE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO SPEAK TO YOUR
CLIENT ABOUT. THE NATURE OF THE
EMPLOYMENT OF THE VICTIM RIGHT
IN DISCUSSING THE MERITS OF THE
CASE AND WHETHER THEY SHOULD
PLEAD OR GO TO TRIAL OR-
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE AND
THAT WOULD BE A VIOLATION OF
THIS LAW. LEADING TO DISBARMENT
AND A MISDEMEANOR AND I GUESS
THAT CONCERNS ME THAT THAT
CLIENT ATTORNEY RELATIONSHIP
WOULD BE HAMPERED BECAUSE OF
THE REST OF THE INFORMATION
THAT'S NOT PROTECTED. WHAT I
BELIEVE ON THIS AND- IN THIS IS
SOMETHING I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
LOOK UP IS THAT THAT WAS IT
THAT IF THEY NEEDED TO HAVE
THIS INFORMATION AND THEY COULD
PROVE THAT IT WOULD HELP YOU
KNOW BE PART OF THE CASE THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO ASK FOR
IT. OKAY THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY. IDEA AT. BEST IS THIS MR
FERN. YES GO AHEAD- YES IT TO
ADD TO THAT- MY UNDERSTANDING
IMPROPER NOT. I THINK I'M NOT
MISTAKEN I BELIEVE ONE OF THE
MEN MEANT THAT- WERE BEING
CONSIDERED AND WAS BEING
ACCEPTED IT WOULD BE TO ALSO
ADDED THAT THAT THE FIVE
EXCEPTION- THE LOCATION OF
EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS SPECIFIED.
AS A FORM OF PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION AND TO
MY KNOWLEDGE- PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE NATURE OF
EMPLOYMENT SO- EIGHT
POTENTIALLY COULD CERTAINLY
SPEAK TO THE CLIENT ABOUT WHAT
TYPE OF JOB IT WITNESS DIED-
AND WITH B. I BELIEVE THE
ACCEPTED AMENDMENT AGAIN- FIVE
LONG. WOULD BE KEPT AMENDMENT
IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW THEM TO
STOP THE LOCATION OF THE- THE-
WITNESSES EMPLOYMENT AS. WELL
AS HELPFUL THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
MISTER. AND JUST BUILDING A OF
THAT JUST TO CLEAR SO. IF THE
IT'S BELIEVES COULD HELP THE
DEFENDANT'S CASE THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO DISCLOSE THAT
INFORMATION OR- THEY ARE THE MR
FOR AND IF YOU WANT TO JUST
FOLLOW UP ON THAT PLEASE-
TWENTY FOUR POINT TWO OUTLINES
THE PROCESS BY WHICH IT P. I.
YOU CAN POINT TO BE SHARED WITH
A THIRD PARTY SUCH AS THE
DEPENDENT AND OR THE FAMILY-
THE THEY JUST NEED TO BE A
SHOWING BY THE BAND THAT TO HOW
IT'S RELEVANT TO THEIR DEFENSE
HOW IMPORTANT TO BE DISCUSSED
AND SHARED WITH THEM- BUT JUST
AS A GENERAL RULE- I THINK THIS.
CARRY NUMBERS PAPER BURKE. AND
OTHER BY BYE METRICS BE SHARED.
WITH THE PARTIES GOT IT OKAY
THANK YOU THAT'S HELPFUL AND-
WHEN YOU TOOK THE MOST YOU KNOW
IF THE OPPOSITION IS COMING OFF
OF THE BILL BECAUSE OF THAT OR-
WE HAVE NOT HEARD. DID MISTER
LUCKY AND NOW. WITH THAT YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO HEAR MY BILL AND I
ASKED FOR. NINE THE PROVIDENCE
SECONDED OF I THINK WE'VE
DISCUSSED THIS. ANOTHER FRIEND
HOPE WE CAN MOVE DECIDED
COMMITTEE CHAIRED RECOMMENDED
AYE VOTE. ON EIGHTY FOUR
NINETEEN BY SOME MEMBER DAVIS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY I'VE
EVER CAN JACKIE HAND AYE CORK
AYE CORK AYE SANTIAGO CA ARE
TOO HIGH C. R. TWO I WICKS.
WICKS I LEE. WE I. THANK YOU
VERY BILL PASSES
CONGRATULATIONS THANKS FOR. I
AM NUMBER EIGHT AB FORTY EIGHT.
RENDON GONZALEZ. LAW
ENFORCEMENT KINETIC ENERGY
PROJECTILES CHEMICAL AGENTS.
YEAH. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN. IT'S
ON IT'S ON BE CAREFUL NO LIGHT.
M. SO THANK YOU I GUESS IT'S A
MORE SIMPLE WAY TO SAY THIS IS
WE'RE TRYING TO GET SOME
REGULATIONS FOR RUBBER BULLETS
AND TEAR GAS. ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY EIGHT WILL SET CLEAR
MINIMUM STANDARDS ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S USE OF SO CALLED
LESS THAN LETHAL WEAPONS LIKE
RUBBER BULLETS PEPPER SPRAY
TEAR GAS FOR CROWD CONTROL
REQUIRE REPORTING OTHER USE TO
THE DOJ. LAST SUMMER AT LEAST A
HUNDRED PROTESTERS BYSTANDERS
AND JOURNALISTS THAT WE KNOW OF
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SIXTEEN
SERIOUS INJURIES FROM RUBBER
BULLETS AND BEAN BAG ROUNDS AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDING SEVEN PEOPLE WHO LOST
AN EYE. WE'VE ALL SEEN JUST HOW
DANGEROUS LESS THAN LETHAL
WEAPONS CAN BE IN THE EVIDENCE
SUPPORTS THAT A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN STUDY FOUND THAT 3%
OF PEOPLE HIT WITH RUBBER
BULLETS ACTUALLY DIE IN 15% ARE
LEFT PERMANENTLY DISABLED IT IS
CLEAR THAT THESE WEAPONS ARE
INAPPROPRIATE FOR SIMPLE CROWD
CONTROL. NO ONE WHO SIMPLY
EXERCISING THE RIGHT TO PROTEST
SHOULD BE SCARED TO FACE
SERIOUS INJURY OR DEATH BECAUSE
OFFICERS ARE INDISCRIMINATELY
FIRING RUBBER BULLETS INTO A
CROWD FOR USING HARMFUL
CHEMICAL AGENTS. AB FORTY EIGHT
WOULD CREATE STANDARDS THAT
ONLY ALLOW TRAINED OFFICERS TO
USE THESE TOOLS AND WEAPONS IF
THERE'S A THREAT TO LIFE OR
SERIOUS INJURY TO AN INDIVIDUAL
OFFICERS MAY NOT USE THEM
SOLELY FOR VIOLATIONS OF
IMPOSED CURFEW BECAUSE OF
VERBAL THREATS OR NON
COMPLIANCE FROM A LAW
ENFORCEMENT DIRECTIVE. OFFICERS
WILL BE REQUIRED TO USE DE
ESCALATION TECHNIQUES FIRST
INCLUDING WARNING THE CROWD AND
GIVING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO LEAVE THE SCENE
BEFORE THEY DEPLOY THESE
WEAPONS THEY COULD ONLY USE
THESE WEAPONS IN A MATTER
PROPORTIONAL TO THE THREAT NOT
INDISCRIMINATELY AGAINST A
CROWD OR TARGETED AT THE HEAD
OR NECK. AB FORTY EIGHT WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
REPORT THE USE OF KINETIC
PROJECTILES AND CHEMICAL AGENTS
TO THE DOJ MONTHLY WHICH WILL
FURTHER PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY
ON THESE PROJECTILES AND
CHEMICAL AGENTS THIS BILL IS
LONG OVERDUE AND IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA BE A LEADER IN
PROTECTING PROTESTERS. AGAINST
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE BY THE
POLICE. I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
TODAY WHO CAN SPEAK ABOUT THE
LONG LASTING IMPACTS OF THESE
DANGEROUS WEAPONS WHEN USED
IMPROPERLY THEY'RE ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU. THAT'S YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES AND DR ROHINI HAAR. N.
FORSCHER KOHNER TO SHEA COOK
FOR SHEA. AND YOU CAN BEGIN.
ANYTIME YOU WANT. YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES IN MY NAME. BUT. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. RIGHT
MY NAME IS RANI HAAR I'M A
RESEARCHER AND AN EMERGENCY
ROOM PHYSICIAN IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I THIRTY PROTESTS
AND THE USE OF CROWD CONTROL
WEAPONS PRIMARILY WITH
PHYSICIANS FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
FIRST I WANTED TO SHARE A FEW
BROADER POINT. ONE IS THAT
PROTESTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS ARE
ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL PILLARS
OF THE DEMCRATIC PROCESS IN
THIS COUNTRY IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
ADVOCATE NOTABLE. CHIU INCITING
PROTESTS THE VAST MAJORITY ARE
PEACEFUL AND EVEN WHEN PROTESTS
TURNED VIOLENT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PROTESTERS IN THOSE
CROWDS ARE STILL PEACEFUL. THE
MERE FACT THAT A DEMONSTRATION
IS BEING ILLEGAL OR THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE VIOLENT
DOES NOT JUSTIFY DISBURSING THE
ENTIRE ASSEMBLY. OR USING CROWD
CONTROL WEAPONS. THIRD THE MOST
EFFECTIVE METHOD TO PREVENT
VIOLENCE IN PROTEST TO ENGAGE
IN NEGOTIATIONS AND OPEN
DIALOGUE BETWEEN PROTESTERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE USE OF
THESE CAR CONTROL WEAPONS
ABSOLUTE LAST RESORT WHEN
DEALING WITH GENUINE AN
IMMINENT THREAT TO SAFETY OF
PEOPLE PRESENT. AND THE ONLY
OTHER OUT OTHER OPTIONS HAVE
BEEN ATTEMPTED. ON CROWD
CONTROL WEAPONS ARE DEPLOYED
THERE ARE IMPORTANT GUIDELINE.
THEY MUST BE NECESSARY THERE
YOU THIRTY PROPORTIONATE AND
TARGETED AND IT MUST NOT BE
MISUSED. UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS
NOT WHAT WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
PAST YEAR. I DO NOT KNOW OF ANY
PROTEST BUT I STUDIED WITH THE
USE OF CROWD CONTROL WEAPONS
HAS DE ESCALATED TENSIONS. OR
MADE THE SITUATION FAVOR. IT
OFTEN DOES QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
I'VE WORKED WITH MANY MANY
COLLEAGUES ACTED ON BEHALF OF
PHYSICIANS FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
HELP AFFECT THE OF CONTROL
WEAPONS. MOST RECENTLY
PUBLISHED A REPORT ON THE USE
OF GENETIC IMPACT PROJECTILES
COME SOMETIMES CALLED RUBBER
BULLETS. SO THERE ARE MUCH MORE
THAN THAT. THE REPORT IS CALLED
SHOT IN THE HEAD AND FIND A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN PEOPLE WITH
SIGNIFICANT HEAD INJURIES.
JUMPED AFTER THE KILLING OF
GEORGE FOUR EIGHT IN TWENTY
TWENTY. MANY OF THEM WERE IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU'RE WELCOME TO
SEE THE VISUAL INVESTIGATION
FOR YOURSELF YOU CAN GOOGLE
SHOT IN THE HEAD AND PHR. THERE
ARE ALSO A NUMBER OF OTHER
RESEARCH OUTPUTS AND HAPPY TO
SHARE WITH YOU. OUR RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT WHEN CRAPPIE BUT
WEAPONS ARE USED UNNECESSARILY
DISPROPORTIONATELY AND WHEN
THEIR VIEWS. WE SEE MORE
INJURIES DISABILITIES AND EVEN
DEATH AND THIS IS A MONTH ON
ARMED CIVILIANS. PERFECTLY
RUBBER BULLETS AND ALL OTHER
CONNECTICUT IMPACT PROJECTILES
ARE DANGEROUS WHEN USED IN
CROWDS. AT SHORT RANGES AND AT
LONG RANGES AT ANY RANGE. AND
TEAR GAS IF YOU SO PERVASIVELY
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND AROUND
THE WORLD BUT MANY PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY CHILDREN THE ELDERLY
AND THOSE WITH CHRONIC FROM
LUNG PROBLEMS ARE SPECIALLY
VULNERABLE. I'M HEARTENED TO
KNOW THAT WE'RE TO PLEASED TO
TAKE SPECIFIC STEPS TO ENSURE
THE CROWD CONTROL WEAPONS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE BETTER
REGULATED. TO GUARD AGAINST THE
DANGERS OF DANGEROUS OVER YOU.
IT IS MY SINCERE HOPE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION AND OTHERS LIKE IT
CAN HELP PROTECT THE RIGHT TO
PROTEST AND SAFEGUARD THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIANS DEMONSTRATING TO
MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THIS POCHE.
GHOSTERY CONNOR HELLO- HELLO TO
THE ASSEMBLY GOOD AFTERNOON HI
MY NAME IS BRIDGET CONNOR- I AM
A TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD BLACKMAIL
OF ONCE WANTED TO PURSUE A
CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT BEING
A VICTIM OF POLICE BRUTALITY-
THAT DESTROYED MY DRINK- IN
LATE MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY I
WATCHED THE VIDEO OF THE WORDS
WILL IS MURDER I WAS SHOCKED
DISTURBED AND OUTRAGED I WHAT I
SAW- I THOUGHT ABOUT MY SAFETY
MODOC RELATIVES AND FRIENDS AND
THE LONG LIST OF BLACK MEN THE
WOMEN. WHO WERE MURDERED- DUE
TO POLICE MISCONDUCT. OCTOECHOS
TO THE BACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT- BY PROTECT. I MADE
THIRTY. TWENTY OUNCE PROTEST AT
THE CAPITOL SACRAMENTO THE
PROTESTS PEOPLE UPSET SEVERAL
FEET AWAY FROM OFFICERS.
EMPLOYEES SHOUTING A CHANCE FOR
JUSTICE ALL WHILE HOLDING A AN
AMERICAN FLAG- I NEVER BEHAVED
IN A VIOLENT OR AGGRESSIVE
MANNER- DESPITE THIS CALL
OBSTACLES. REPORTER GAS BOMBS
GRENADES. IN MY DIRECT NOT THE
CROWD OF PROTESTERS. I TRIED TO
RUN TO SAFETY- ALSO STRUCK THE
LESLIE BUT LET ME LET ME- HOUSE
SHOT WITH SOMETHING WHICH I
BELIEVE WAS A RIVERBOAT. I WAS
VERY CLOSE TO MY RIGHT ARM AND
ON MY LEFT LEG. AT LEDGER DOWN
MY FACE AND THE IMPACT.
REQUIRED YOU TO SPEAK-
IMMEDIATE MEDICAL ATTENTION-
NOW EACH TIME I LOOK IN THE
MIRROR I TO USED CAR THERE
MIGHT BE TO PROTEST AND- BY
THAT TIME. MY DIDN'T. I'LL BE
NEARLY EIGHTY. HI PROSPECTING
SHOT ASKING DURING GUIDING THE
PRESIDENT APPROACHED LAST YEAR
FOR EIGHTY FIFTY SIX I SAID I
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO THANK MY
LUCKY STARS NOTHING WORKS AT. I
WOULD HAVE NOT BEEN SO LUCKY.
READING MORE TENDERS ON THE USE
OF KINETIC PROJECTILES LIKE
RUBBER BULLETS BIG BY BEING
BACKGROUNDS AND TEAR GAS WILL
PREVENT LIFELONG DAMAGES FOR
OTHERS. THE ADDAMS ECONOMY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN A
ROW. ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM.
EIGHTEEN T. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ONLINE. AS A REMINDER
IT'S ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. WE
DO HAVE A FEW IN Q. OUR FIRST
WILL COME FROM LINE ONE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR SOUTH
BRAMBLE SPEAKING CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE
NINETY NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIFTY WHITE WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRED MEMBERS CHRIS
LANG OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
THANKS REPRESENTING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COURT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE ONE AT NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BONTA LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BURGER
GEORGIA HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BOND RAP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WHERE THE PROP SPONSOR OF AB
FORTY EIGHT AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT PHOTO LINE ONE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT ARE STARTING WITH
A CALIFORNIA PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN POSSIBLY
YOUR NEW BUTTONS ON. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES BEST GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M MEMBER AND ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND AS A REMINDER IT IS ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT OUR NEXT IS
LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
DON'T THINK MONSTER HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TERMS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT OVER THE LINE SIXTY NINE
LET'S GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CANACCORD ARE NOT ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO NEXUS
NINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
MATT HEINZ FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I
ABOUT SHAUN RUNDLE CPO A-
HOPEFULLY ON THE PHONE. AT&T.
CHECK IT NOW ONE MOMENT. I'M
NOT SHOW IN- ONE MOMENT. FOR I
DO SHOW THAT WE DO HAVE SHAUN
RANDLES LINE ON AND IT'S OPENS
BUT I I'M NOT HEARING ANYTHING
FROM IT. I'M SORRY I'M HERE
RESEARCHER CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
I SURE CAN. YOU MAY BEGIN THANK
YOU FIVE MINUTES BEG YOUR
PARDON. YES THANK YOU FORGOT
ABOUT THAT- SHOWN ON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND-
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE- IN IN THE WAKE OF ALL
THE RECENT EVENTS OF THE LAST
YEARS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT A
NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SOME PROPOSALS.
BUT IN THE OTHER HOUSE ABOUT
MEDIA ACCESS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN REGARDS TO BE A LEADER BILL-
THAT THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN HAS AS WELL THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY. A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT COME UP WHEN CIRCUMSTANCES
LIKE THESE HAPPEN AND WHAT WE
WANT TO AVOID BUT WHAT
UNFORTUNATELY WE FEEL THAT THE
BILL WILL BE ABOUT TO HAPPEN IN
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES. ARE HAVING
TO IF YOU TAKE AWAY SOME OF
THESE AGENTS. IT WILL ACTUALLY
LEAD TO POTENTIALLY THE NEED TO
USE- OTHER- SYSTEMS THAT MAY
PLACE- THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
BE MORE HARMFUL THAN- TEAR GAS
OR RUBBER BOATS SUCH AS BATONS
ARE POTENTIALLY. DEADLY COURSE
THESE ARE MEANT TO BE- WHAT
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE IS
MEANT TO BE LESS SLEEP ALL
OPTIONS THAT AGENCIES WANT TO
BE ABLE TO USE UNDER SOME OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES WORKING
QUICKLY TURNED FROM. A PEACEFUL
PROTESTER DEMONSTRATION INTO-
SOME OF THE OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES
ESPECIALLY WHERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT MAY BE VASTLY
OUTNUMBERED BY POTENTIALLY
HUNDREDS OR EVEN THOUSANDS TO
ONE- AND ALSO IN THE LANGUAGE
THAT THE STATE THAT A CHEMICAL
AGENT CAN BE DEPLOYED IF IT'S
TEAR GAS- THAT ONLY A
COMMANDING OFFICER AT THE
SCENE- CAN OPERATE THAT.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF WE
WOULD APPRECIATE SOME CLARITY
ON THAT BECAUSE IT'S A LITTLE
UNCLEAR ABOUT. YOU KNOW IF THE
COMMANDER IS AT ONE END OF THE
A LONG STREET IS THAT
CONSIDERED. APPETITE ASSEMBLY
PROTEST DEMONSTRATION AND
HAPPENS TO BE USED ELSEWHERE
FOR PEOPLE THAT AREN'T
COMPLYING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
DIRECTIVES OF THE BILL STATING
THAT IT ENDS UP BEING USE WHAT
POTENTIALLY IS. THE LIABILITY
THERE- SO THERE'S JUST SOME
OTHER THINGS OF WHAT THE BILL
PROPOSES GOING ALL THOSE GOING
THROUGH ALL OF THOSE STEPS- TO
ENSURE- PROPER USAGE WHICH
OBVIOUSLY WE- APPRECIATION
ADVOCATE AND I KNOW AGENCIES.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN CIRCUMSTANCES
OVER THE LAST YEAR- ARE LOOKING
AT ALL THOSE STEPS IS VIRTUALLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THOUGH WHICH
IS OBVIOUSLY OUR FOCUS WHERE
THESE TYPE OF INCIDENTS.
OVERALL YOU SUPPORT INCIDENTS
HAVE DECREASED BUT AS WE LOOK
AT THE SPECIFIC INCIDENTS WE
WANT TO GET TO THE TO THE RIGHT
PLACE BUT WE FEEL THAT- WHAT
THE BILL PROPOSES IN TERMS OF-
VIOLATIONS IMPOSE CURFEW VERBAL
THREATS. NO COMPLAINTS WITH
FUND PORTION DIRECTIVES NURSE
OKAY IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES WE
DON'T WANT TO TAKE AWAY THESE-
THE ABILITY TO USE SOME OF
THESE AGENTS AND SEVEN THAT
FORMS THE BASIS OF PARK.
OPPOSITION TO APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME THANK. THANK YOU SIR ARE
THERE. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN A
ROOM THERE IN OPPOSITION. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING CALL. EIGHTEEN T.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE LINE. AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
OUR FIRST WILL COME FROM LINE
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHARMERS GOOD AFTERNOON CORY
SOCIAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDED
UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NECAS WINNER OF THE LINE. BRIAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND SANTA
ANA POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DOWNLOADABLE ON THE APP WITH
THE- TELEPHONE METADATA
PROPERTY TO THIRTY EIGHT. TELL
WHAT BALAJI POLICE CHIEF
ASSOCIATION. COOPERATE BY
REFERENCE- YES YES. THANK YOU
NEXT. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
Q. OKAY TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE NOW ANY QUESTIONS MR
CORK AND MS WICKS AND- FIRST
ONLY THEN I'LL MOVE THE VALVE.
AND THE SECOND- THE OPPOSITION-
WAS ASKING FOR SOME. OUR
DEFINITIONS I HOPE THAT THAT
CAN BE WORKED OUT SO IN THE END
WE CAN COME UP WITH SOMETHING
THAT. THAT THEY CAN AT LEAST
NOT OPPOSE. THANK YOU. YEAH IT
KIND OF SURPRISED ME A TO BE
HONEST THE- COMMANDING OFFICER
GIVING THE DIRECTION ACTUALLY
CAME FROM A SERIES OF MEETINGS
I HAD WITH DIFFERENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS SO. I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY JUST HAVE AN ALL
SPOKEN ARE ALL AGREE ON THE
BEST- PERSON TO MAKE THE CALL-
IN SO I WILL AGAIN DO THE
ROUNDS BUT IT IT'S HARD
OBVIOUSLY IF THEY ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS ABOUT WHO. WHO
AND HOW THAT SHOULD BE DONE BUT
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU MISS
WICKS THANK YOU- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL I THINK IT'S
A GREAT BILL THE STORY YOUR
WITNESS. TESTIFIED TO HIS
HORRIFIC AND IT SHOULDN'T
HAPPEN AND WE SAW ALL THESE
SITUATIONS LAST YEAR- I
OBVIOUSLY FOR THE WHAT BUT WILL
BUT I'D LOVE FOR YOU TO ADD
MUSICAL AUTHORS WELL.
ABSOLUTELY. YOU MAY AREAS OF
YES MUST GIVE ME A NEWS MEMBER
MR LEE I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR LEADERSHIP OPPOSING THIS
GENEROUSLY REASONABLE BILL TO
BAN THE USE OF THE LESS THAN
LETHAL WEAPONS IN MY DISTRICT
ALONE THERE'S ONE THERE'S ONE
PERSON WHO WAS SHOT IN THE EYE
AND LOST HIS LEFT EYE AS
ANOTHER PERSON WHO WAS SHOT AND
PERHAPS YOU MAY NEVER HAVE
CHILDREN. THAT IS A TERRIBLE
CONSEQUENCES OF WHEN PEOPLE ARE
PROTESTING HISTORIC AND
HISTORIC NUMBERS IN THE SUMMER
AGAINST POLICE BRUTALITY IT'S
IRONIC THAT A HISTORIC AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCED POLICE
BRUTALITYAND KNOW THE TASTE OF
BEING SHOT AT OR TEAR GAS I
MYSELF KNOW HOW AWFUL IT IS TO
BE CHOKING OUT YOUR GRASS WILL
ALSO BE FLASH BANG WITH A FLASH
GRENADES. SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE
PROUD TO CO AUTHOR THIS BILL
WITH YOU AND ALSO TO SUPPORT
YOU IN THIS EFFORTS AND IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT NOTE THAT
CHEMICAL AGENTS LIKE TEAR GAS
HAVE BEEN BANNED FOR ALMOST A
HUNDRED YEARS SINCE AFTER WORLD
WAR ONE SO THEY HAVE NO PLACE
ON THE BATTLEFIELD THEY
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE A PLACE ON
OUR STREETS AND I'M VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YES
MISBACH YOU LIKE FOR ME TO SAY
REBEKAH POWER K. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK ON THIS
BILL I THINK THAT WE SAW YOU'RE
A WITNESS SPOKE POWERFULLY
ABOUT WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN THIS
THESE TOOLS ARE MISUSED AND
THAT IS THE LAST THING ANY OF
US WANT I THINK WE ALSO SIGNED
JANUARY AT THE INSTRUCTION OF
THE CAPITAL WHAT CAN HAPPEN
WHEN POLICE ARE OVERWHELMED
AND- WHEN THERE IS A GROUP OF
PEOPLE TRYING TO BREAK THE LINE
THREATEN PEOPLE'S LIVES AND SO
THE BALANCE THAT YOU HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD I CAN TELL
FOR. SURE IT'S EASIER TO STRIKE
THAT BALANCE IS WELL DONE AND I
CAN TELL THAT IT'S BEEN DONE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY GROUPS I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND THE PARTS
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU. THE
FOURTEENTH. OF JULY OKAY. YES
WELL CERTAINLY AT I DO BELIEVE
THAT- SOME OF THE ACTIONS THAT
HAVE RESULTED FROM THE- THESE-
PROCESSES ARE OF A CONCERN AND
DESERVE DISCUSSION. BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THAT FIRST OF ALL
THERE'S A CLEAR DISTINCTION
BETWEEN A PROTESTER
DEMONSTRATION AND RIOT. HAVING
BEEN IN THE POSITION OF
WITNESSING BOTH. THERE'S A
CLEAR DIFFERENCE AND WHEN
SOMEONE STARTS TO RESORT TO
OVERT ACTIONS. AGAINST LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE BECOMES A VERY
DANGEROUS VERY BALL SAID
CIRCUMSTANCES. UNDER YOUR
PROVISION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ LET ME ASK YOU WHAT
WOULD ROCK THROWING BE
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH. TO USE IT IS
IT WASN'T DANGER YES BUT IT HAS
TO BE DIRECTED AT THE PERSON
THROWING ROCKS I MEAN THERE'S
IT'S A REASONABLY OBJECTIVE
STANDARD YOU CAN'T SIMPLY SAY-
SOMEBODY THREW A ROCK AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO SPRAY RUBBER
BULLETS ACROSS THIS CROWD I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY THAT WOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE BUT YOU KNOW THAT
THERE CANNOT BE GIVEN HOW WOULD
YOU SUGGEST THAT THAT BE- TAKEN
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE- I'VE
ACTUALLY HAD PROJECT-
PROJECTILES THROWN AT ME. IN A
SITUATION AND I'M TELLING YOU.
IT FEELS EXTREMELY. THREATENING
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THOSE
PROJECTILES EVEN THOUGH LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES HAVE
EQUIPMENT. TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES- BUT THAT. IS STILL
VERY DANGEROUS VERY UGLY SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT HAVE TO BE
QUELLED AND HAVE TO BE TOLD
THAT THAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
BEHAVIOR. AND SO THAT'S REALLY
THE MISSION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN THEY GO UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IT IS A TO STOP
THEM FROM PROTESTING OR SENDING
THEIR- THEIR MESSAGE OF-
DISAGREEMENT WITH WHATEVER.
SITUATION EXISTS IT'S TO KEEP
THINGS PEACEFUL. I WANT PEOPLE.
YOU CAN LAUGH ALL YOU WANT BUT
IT'S FUNNY WHEN SOMEONE STOLE A
BOTTLE AT U. S. NINETY WHEN
YOU. GOING TO ACCESS TO MY-
REQUESTION BUT IT'S ALSO NOT
THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE SHOT AT
PERFECTLY INNOCENT BYSTANDERS
IN LOSING THEIR ICE. ALL RIGHT
SO IT IS A GIVE AND TAKE AND I
HAVE MET WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN ON THIS
BILL AND I WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AND YOU SHOULD BUT TO
SUGGEST THAT BECAUSE AN OFFICER
IS AFRAID BECAUSE SOMEBODY
THREW A ROCK AT HIM THAT HE
SHOULD BE ABLE. OR SHE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO INDISCRIMINATELY.
SPRAY RUBBER BULLETS. AT A
CROWD. IT IS OFFENSIVE TO MY
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
PROTEST. THIS IS A SPECIALIZED
AFRAID. AND I WILL TELL YOU
THAT THEY'RE ACTING OKAY. HALF
OF OTHER PEOPLE AND I DON'T
THINK THAT WAS VERY FAIR EITHER
AND- I JUST WANT TO SEE THE-
LIGHT. I DO AGREE WITH. THE
FACT THAT WE NEED TO WORK
THROUGH THIS ISSUE. BUT I THINK
IT DOES APPROACH AND THIS BILL
BEFORE ME. THIS TO EXTREME A
VERY VERY AMBIGUOUS ON A NUMBER
OF FRONTS. AND I CAN TELL THAT
YOU'RE NOT IN A- MOOD RIGHT NOW
TO DISCUSS OKAY ASSEMBLY SIDE
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY ANYMORE. I
AND I DO APOLOGIZE FOR SAYING
AFRAID AT THAT IS WHAT I HEARD
YOU SAY IT IS A VERY SCARY
SITUATION AND I'M SORRY IF I
USE MY WORDS TO SAY IF AN
OFFICER IS AFRAID I DON'T THINK
THAT'S AN EXCUSE I STILL DON'T
THINK IT'S AN EXCUSE. SO I WILL
BE HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU
ARE IN WHAT ANYONE ELSE IS NOT
AMBIGUOUS IT'S VERY SPECIFIC ON
WHAT OFFICERS NEED TO DO. TO DE
ESCALATE AND TO WARN THAT THIS
TYPE OF USE OF FORCE IS GOING
TO BE USED IF THERE IS A
DIFFERENT WAY TO APPROACH THAT
I'D BE HAPPY I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS BILL FOR TWO YEARS I'D
BE HAPPY TO HEAR IT. BUT YOU
KNOW THIS IS WHAT WE WE'RE AT
RIGHT HERE IN AND- NO BILL LIKE
THIS HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET
THROUGH IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS IS WHY.
BUT WE HAVE TO PROTECT INNOCENT
BYSTANDERS AT PEACEFUL PROTEST
IT IS JUST TO FUNDAMENTAL BEEN
TO ALLOW WHAT HAPPENED THIS
SUMMER TO HAPPEN AGAIN AND
AGAIN. THE QUESTIONS WERE
SELECTED. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. YOU MAKE CLOSENESS
GONZALEZ I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT ACTUALLY WHEN THESE TYPES
OF WEAPONS ARE DEPLOYED IT
ACTUALLY ESCALATES THE VIOLENCE
SO TO SUGGEST THAT THESE ARE
USED TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE WOULD
BE COUNTERINTUITIVE. AND THE
TRUTH IS WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW
MUCH. VIOLENCE ARE HOW HOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE BEING INJURED
BY THE USE OF THESE LEFT LESS
THAN WE LEGAL. LESS THAN LETHAL
WEAPONS BECAUSE WE DON'T EVEN
GET HAVE THAT DATA THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT FEATURE OF THIS BILL
AS WELL. BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
THIS. A LOT OF INNOCENT PEOPLE
THIS SUMMER HAVE BEEN.
PERMANENTLY MAIMED BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT SHOW
UP AT THE PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATION THAT THAT MAYBE
GOT TO BE A LOT OF PEOPLE. AND
INVOICE THEIR THEIR RIGHT TO
TAKE ON THE ESTABLISHMENT IN
THE SYSTEM BUT THEY FELT HURT
BY. THAT AS SOMEBODY WHO FROM
THE DAY MY KIDS WERE BEING HELD
HAVE TAKEN THEM TO PROTESTS
HAVE TAKEN THEM TO ACTIONS. IT
IS EXTREMELY SCARY TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENED THE SUMMER TO INNOCENT
BYSTANDERS NOT PEOPLE WHO WERE
SHOOTING AT THE POLICE BUT
PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE TO EXPRESS
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
WE HAVE TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH ANYONE WHO HAS. A
SUGGESTION I HAVE TAKEN EVERY
MEETING I WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE
EVERY MEETING- WITH ANY SECTORS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT I HAVE AND I
MADE CHANGES THAT. YOU KNOW
THEY ASK FOR SO AT THIS POINT I
JUST THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT- STANDARD THAT WE
NEED TO SET IN AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO WORK. WITH ME ON.
THANK YOU- BUT OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS VERY- SENSITIVE ISSUE. BUT.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- WHEN I WAS A YOUNG
REGGIE JONES SAWYER LIVING IN
LOS ANGELES. WITH A POLICE
CHIEF NAMED DARYL GATES. WHO
SAID THAT USING A CHARCOAL. WAS
AN APPROPRIATE WAY. TO DEFEND
FOR POLICE OUT TO DEFEND
HIMSELF THE NUMBER OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN WHO DIE BECAUSE
YOU HAD A CHIEF OF POLICE WHO
BASICALLY SAID WE HAD AN
ANATOMY. HE WANTED TO AND IF WE
HAD AN ANATOMY. THAT CAUSED US
TO DIE WHEN THEY DID THE
CHUCKLE. AND COULDN'T SEE THE
HUMANITY. N. A. A POLICE ACTION
THAT RESULTED IN SOMEONE'S
DEATH M. I HAD DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THINK ABOUT THAT THAT WAS
LIKE THE LATE EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES. I THINK MISTER GIBSON
JUST HAD UP. WHAT YEARS IS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FROM THE
LATE EIGHTIES TOLD NOW THAT
SOMEHOW WE STRUGGLED WITH IT.
SO I COMMEND YOU FOR BRING IT
HERE NOW BECAUSE- EVEN WITH
THIS DISCUSSION. WE NEED TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM WE DO AND WE
SHOULDN'T TAKE. TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS. TO SOLVE IT WE NEED TO
SOLVE IT NOW- AND I KNOW.
THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE USED TO TRAIN. THAT I
WISH WERE BACK AT THE ACADEMY
TRAINING PEOPLE ON THE USE. OF
THIS BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
D. E. DO YOU SPEND A TRAINEE
AND HOW FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN
READING. HAS NOT BEEN ADEQUATE
ENOUGH. MORE UPDATED. TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE STANDARDS- SO THAT
BOTH SIDES ARE SAFE AND BOTH
SIDES UNDERSTAND WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE- AND THAT BOTH SIDES
UNDERSTAND DE ESCALATION. AND
HOW TO WORK BECAUSE CHANGE
OBVIOUS CHANGED A LOT FROM WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT USED TO SIX
GERMAN SHEPHERDS ON MY PEOPLE.
IT'S CHANGED THAT STORE FIRE
HOSES. ON BLACK PEOPLE IT'S
CHANGED CHANGED DRAMATICALLY
AND THAT WAS AN APPROPRIATE
METHODOLOGY BACKED ON. WHEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE NOW IS THE
TIME FOR ALL SIDES. TO SIT AND
TALK ABOUT WAYS WE CAN KEEP
EVERYBODY SAFE. BUT REALLY
UNDERSTAND BOTH SIDES.
ESPECIALLY KNOWING THAT- YOU
PROBABLY CAN HEAR MY VOICE HOW
EMOTIONAL YOU CAN GET WITH THIS
WHATEVER SIDE YOU'RE ON. AND-
OUR OPTION RECOMMENDING AND I
BOTH I RECOMMEND BECAUSE IT.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN RISKS WE
RESOLVE IT NOW. OR AT LEAST
START THE FIRST STEPS OF
IMPLEMENTING SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN BUILD ON TO MAKE IT BETTER
AND BETTER AND IF WE NEED MORE
MONEY. FOR TRAINING- THE CHAIR
APPROPRIATIONS OFFICE ACROSS
THE HALL FROM ME. AND I'M SURE.
I SHOULD OWN BUDGET FIVE I'M
SURE WE CAN. MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE PROPERLY TRAINED SO
WE DON'T HAVE THESE MISHAPS
AGAIN AND IF PEOPLE DON'T COME
OUT INJURED RIGHT NOW YOU'RE IN
A WHICH- GOD FOR BID WE HAVE
MULTIPLE DEATHS. AFTER THIS IF
WE DON'T DO ANYTHING NOW IT
COULD ESCALATE TO THAT AND SO
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE AGAIN ON BOTH SIDES
SOMEONE GETS HURT THEY GET MAD
THEN ONE SIDE. GOES AFTER THE
OTHER AND NOW WE DO HAVE A FULL
FLEDGE PROBLEMS SO. THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING US HERE. IT IS IF
I CAN'T I JUST AGAIN WHEN I
APOLOGIZE TO MR LACKEY I THINK
HE KNOWS I HAVE A DEEP RESPECT-
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT DESPITE ALL
THE CHALLENGES THAT COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE FACES AND I'VE ALWAYS
HAD EIGHTY EIGHT VERY WORKABLE
RELATIONSHIP WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WE TRIED TO
WORK ON THIS BILL WITH IT SO I
DIDN'T MEAN TO IN ANY WAY.
OFFEND YOU OR YOUR PREVIOUS
CAREER OR ANYWAY I MEAN THIS IS
IT WAS JUST. I THIS SHOWS HOW
IMPORTANT THAT DISCUSSION IS. I
USUALLY DON'T LET PEOPLE TALK
AFTER I'M SORRY BUT- THANK YOU
FOR. FOR YOUR POLICY. I THINK
THAT'S HOPEFULLY IT'S A- IT IT
STILL NEED OF. A MOTION AND A
SECOND. START MISTER MISTER
CLARK MOVED THIS WEEK SECOND.
AB FORTY EIGHT BY SEVEN MEMBER
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY NO BARRICADE
CAN BARRICADE HAD HI CORK CORK
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I SAY OUR
TO SEE OUR TONO WICKS WICKS HI
LI. LEE HIGH THAT MISSION THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU. FULL.
MISTER AB TWENTY SIX POLICE
OFFICERS USE OF FORCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. READ. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I WANTED TO
NOTE UP FRONT IF I COULD THE-
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS THAT
I'VE HAD WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE APPRECIATION I HAVE
FOR- YOUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
IN THE COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEES- CONSULTANT- AND
I'VE DECIDED AS THE ANALYSIS
SHOWS THAT I'M REMOVING
ACCESSORY TO A CRIME HAS A
PROVISION THAT WAS INITIALLY
PART OF THIS BILL AND THAT
COMES WITH HAVING HAD
CONVERSATIONS MUCH IS WHAT WAS
EXPRESSED- AND OPPRESSED THEN
THE PREVIOUS- BILL DISCUSSION I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE THOSE KIND OF
DISCUSSIONS AND- AS A RESULT WE
WILL REMOVE. EXCESS RETURN
CRIME. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX. A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL
MEASURES THAT ESTABLISH TWO
THINGS. ONE WHAT IT MEANS FOR
PEACE OFFICER TO INTERVENE WHEN
WITNESSING AN EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE BY ANOTHER PEACE OFFICER.
AND TO CERTAIN OUTCOMES FOR
FAILURE TO INTERVENE. MEMBERS
WE WERE ALL JUST MADE BY THE
TRAGIC EVENTS THAT LED TO THE
UNTIMELY DEATH. OF GEORGE FLOYD.
AND TO THEIR CREDIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE CONDEMNED THE
ACTIONS OF THE SUPERVISING
OFFICER INVOLVED IN THAT
INCIDENT. THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. I WOULD ARGUE
THAT IN THE DAYS WEEKS AND
MONTHS FOLLOWING THE TRAGIC
EVENT THAT THE PROTESTS AND
DEMONSTRATIONS THAT WE
WITNESSED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY WE'RE NOT SINGULARLY
FOCUS ON JUST THE ACTIONS OF
THE SUPERVISING OFFICER. NO THE
DEMONSTRATORS WERE ALSO
PROTESTING THE FACT THAT THREE
ADDITIONAL OFFICERS SIMPLY
STOOD BY AND WATCHED HIM DIE.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
CURRENT LAW IS WRITTEN SIMPLY
REQUIRES THAT IT OFFICER HAS A
DUTY TO INTERVENE. HOWEVER THE
PROBLEM IS THAT NOTHING IN
CURRENT LAW EXPLAINS OR
ESTABLISHES NGUYEN IN FACT THE
PEACE OFFICER HAS INTERVENE.
ABSENT OF THIS UNDERSTAND IT IT
LEAVES THE PUBLIC UNINFORMED
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT THE ABILITY
TO DEFINE. INTERVENTION AS
WHATEVER EACH INDIVIDUAL PIECE
OFFICER DEEMS AS APPROPRIATE.
FOR THESE REASONS I PUT FORWARD
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX. AB
TWENTY SIX CLARIFIES AND
ESTABLISHES INTERVENTION OR
INTERCEDE TO INCLUDE BUT NOT
LIMITED TO THE USE OF DE
ESCALATION TECHNIQUES
CONFRONTING THE OFFICER
APPLYING EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE
PHYSICALLY STOPPING THE
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE WHEN IN
A POSITION TO DO SO. RECORDING
AND DOCUMENTING THE INCIDENT IN
REAL TIME WITH THE BODY KAMMLER
KAMMER AND REPORTING THE
INCIDENT TO DISPATCH OR WATCH
COMMANDER IN REAL TIME STATING
THE OFFENDING OFFICER'S NAME.
UNIT LOCATION TIME AND
SITUATION IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH
IN AN ATTEMPT TO INTERVENE HAS
BEEN MAY. ADDITIONALLY IT
REQUIRES A PEACE OFFICER TO
REPORT THE INCIDENT IMMEDIATELY
TO HIS OR HER SUPERVISOR. AB
TWENTY SIX PROHIBITS
RETALIATION ON A PEACE OFFICER
FOR REPORTING THE INCIDENT. IT
WAS AN OFFICER FROM TRAINING
FOR OTHER OFFICERS FOR A PERIOD
OF AT LEAST THREE YEARS FROM
THE DATE THAT AN EXCESSIVE USE
OF FORCE COMPLAINT IS
SUBSTANTIATED. AND IF THE
INVESTIGATION BY THE PEACE
OFFICERS LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
FINDS. THAT THE PEACE OFFICER
EITHER USE EXCESSIVE FORCE THAT
RESULTED IN GREAT BODILY INJURY
OR DEATH OF A MEMBER OFTHE
PUBLIC. OR FAIL TO INTERVENE IN
THAT INCIDENT CAN BE
DISQUALIFIED FROM BEING A PEACE
OFFICER. ALL DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
AND POKE BAR OR POLICE OFFICER
BILL OF RIGHTS. ARE PRESERVED
IN THIS BILL. IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TECHNIQUES AND
PROCEDURES THAT ARE PUT FORWARD
IN THIS BILL FOR ESTABLISHING
THAT AN OFFICER HAS INTERVENE
CAN ACTUALLY BE APPLIED IN REAL
WORLD SCENARIOS MY OFFICE
REACHED OUT TO POST. WHO WAS
CHARGED TO DEVELOP DUTY TO
INTERVENE TRAINING. AND OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE LIAISONS PROPOSED
WE HAVE CONFIRMED THAT DUTY TO
INTERVENE TRAINING AND ALL OF
THE FEDERAL STATE AND STATE
LAWS ASSOCIATED WITH FAILURE TO
INTERVENE. IS AN ALL OF THE USE
OF FORCE TRAININGS. IT IS IN
THE ACADEMY AS WELL AS IN
SERVICE TRAINING AND RECENTLY
THE COMMISSION MANDATED USE OF
FORCE TRAINING AS A PERISHABLE
SKILL WHICH MAKES IT REQUIRED
TRAINING FOR EVERY IN SERVICE
OFFICER EVERY TWO YEARS. IN
FACT POST HAS PURCHASED FIVE
MILLION IN NEW TECHNOLOGY FOUR
HUNDRED VIRTUAL REALITY
SIMULATORS THAT WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THEY OFFER A SIMULATOR
USE OF FORCE DE ESCALATION
COURSE THAT LITERALLY PRACTICES
INTERVENTION. AND INTERVENTION
TECHNIQUES AND SCENARIOS
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND REESTABLISHING
PUBLIC TRUST BY EDUCATING THE
COMMUNITY ON THE LAWFUL
PROCEDURES AND PRACTICES OF
PEACE OFFICERS WHO HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY HAVE IN
FACT ATTEMPTED TO INTERVENE TO
STOP EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE. AB
TWENTY SIX SIMPLY CODIFIES WHAT
IS LITERALLY BEING STALKED AS
WE SPEAK. IN THAT SPIRIT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. WITH ME- TO TESTIFY TODAY
IS BRIAN **** WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE. AND BETTY WILLIAMS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII STATE
CONFERENCE AND UNLESS IT. THANK
YOU. BOTH OF YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES. OR WHATEVER WAY YOU
pTO GO FIRST EIGHTEEN P. MR ****
FLORIDA. WHAT. I REQUEST THANK
YOU OKAY- THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOME HOME FOR PROVIDING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
I'M DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
BRIAN **** WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWENTY SIX ACROSS CALIFORNIA
IN THE COUNTRY POLICE HAVE USED
EXCESSIVE FORCE LITTLE FIGURE
CONSEQUENCES PORTUGAL ONE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN STUDY FOUND
THAT ABOUT ONE IN EVERY ONE
THOUSAND BLACK MEN WILL BE
KILLED BY POLICE. CLOSE BY ONE
OF THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
AMONG MEN OF COLOR SAN
FRANCISCO THE BLACK AND BROWN
COMMITTEE HAS LARGELY BORNE THE
BRUNT OF THAT VIOLENCE SO MUCH
SO THAT SAN FRANCISCO INTERNET
WITH ONE OF THE OTHER PART OF
JUSTICE AND THE HOST GEORGE
FORD ERA RESPONSE NEED NOT BE
THAT DEADLY THE WHOLE THE
DESTRUCTIBLE MORALLY REPULSIVE
AND ROCHESTER NEW YORK POLICE
PEPPER SPRAYED AND NINE YEAR
OLD BLACK CHILD AS SHE SAT IN
THE POLICE CAR. HANCOCK COVERED
IN SNOW. THE BODY ONE CHEMICAL
TO A BILL. IT IS BECOME A OFTEN
REFRAIN. THE PERSON OFTEN A
PERSON OF COLOR TO NOT COMPLY
QUICKLY ENOUGH. BOXES TO OFTEN
RESORTS EXCESSIVE. COULD ALSO A
BILL ANOTHER STAR TRUTH EIGHTY
TWO SIX ADDRESSES. APPLE
DOESN'T ALL. WATCHING MIND DID
NOT. THE ROCHESTER POLICE YOU
BLAMED THE INCIDENT ON THE
CHILD'S MOTHER. THE OFFICER DID
NOTHING WRONG. WE CANNOT WAIT
ON POLICE UNIONS ARE PLEASED TO
LIMIT THE USE OF EXCESSIVE
FORCE AND CAUGHT UP WITH
HAPPENS. THE LAW MUST PROVIDE
CLEAR GUIDELINES ON HOW
OFFICERS INTERCEDE. WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE IF THEY DO
NOT. AB TWENTY SIX PROVIDES A
CLEAR FRAMEWORK TAKE CONCRETE
REPORTABLE STEPPED INTERCEDE.
PROTECTS OFFICERS FROM
POLITICIAN WHEN THEY DO INNER
CITY. AND OFFICERS WHO USE
EXCESSIVE FORCE OR FAILED IN A
SEAT. SHOULD NOT WEAR BATCH.
THAT CAN'T BE CONTROVERSIAL. TO
ME LIVE WITHIN A LOVELY HARMED
OR INDEED BECAUSE OF
PREVENTABLE UNNECESSARY POLICE
VIOLENCE. PLEASE A SWORN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. ALSO
PROTECT FROM. PLEASE FIND.
MAYBE TWENTY SIX AND- CLOSER TO
THAT A REALITY FOR THESE
REASONS I SUPPOSE THE TWENTY
AND- DO SO AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN THANK YOU
HELLO YES OKAY HI DON MY NAME
IS BETTY WILLIAMS I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA HAWAII NAACP IN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HAWAII
NAACP STATE CONFERENCE WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL A.
B. TWENTY SIX WHICH IS THAT
WHICH IS A CLEAR GUIDELINES FOR
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY WHILE
DEMONSTRATING. WHEN WITNESSING
EXCESSIVE FORCE BY ANOTHER
MEMBER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
AS WE ALL KNOW ON MAY TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY GEORGE
FLOYD WAS ARRESTED FOR
ALLEGEDLY USING A COUNTERFEIT
BILL DURING THE WITH THE REST
THE SUPERVISING OFFICER KNELT
FOR MANY FOR EIGHT MINUTES
WHILE HE WAS HANDCUFFED WITH
TWO ADDITIONAL OFFICERS FURTHER
HIM A FOURTH TO AND WATCHED TO
A THE CROWD DID NOT BECOME
INVOLVED WHILE THE PUBLIC
WITHOUT WAY BY THE BY THE OF
ALSO SHOULD DESTROY OF MISTER
FLOYD. WITH EQUALLY TROUBLING.
THAT THE OTHER THREE OFFICES
BILL TO. THE SUPERVISING ALL
DOES. MINNESOTA'S TO INTERFERE
LAW CURRENT HELD LAW YOUR-
SEVEN OFF- INTERFACE WITH PRESS
AND I'M SORRY ANOTHER. USING.
FOR- AB TWENTY SIX QUARTER A
MEASURES STERN THE REQUIRED OF
PEACE WILL BE. YOU ARE GOING
KEEP GOING TO I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE JUST KEEP. CORRECT.
DUTY TO INTERCEDE AND CERTAIN
OUTCOME FOR FAILURE DURING THE
KELP HAWAII AND I SEE IS WITH
THE ROLE OF THE C. AN AND
CLAIMS AND MYSTERY OF OFF WERE
TO OUR- THE NEW YORKER IN THE
IN CO FOR HELP YOU BRIDGES AND
IN. TRUST BETWEEN POLICING
COMMUNITY COULD BETTER IN BILLS
COULD BE PAUL ON IMPROVED THE
OF LIFE OF AFTERNOON PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE AREAS OF AT AFTER
HOUSING AND CIVIC AND. THE BILL
WHICH THE EFFORT TO THE CULTURE
OF THE LAW FORCED PRACTICE.
CONCERN AFRICA AMERICAN WHO ARE
TO. DEPICTED OF EXCEPT USE OF
FORCE AND IN A BIT THE
CALIFORNIA IN EIGHTEEN URGES
THIS JUST BY. A PAST AB TWO SIX
ONE OUT FOR HESITATE. THANK YOU
ANY MY NAME IS WILLIAMS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CAL HELLO.
STATE CONFERENCE IN. EIGHT
FIFTY. THANK YOU OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESS IN THE AND
SUPPORT. AND WITNESSES IN CON
ROOM. AT&T OPERATE CAN YOU UP
THE LINE ANY WITNESS ON THE FAR.
HERE ARE SUPPORT OF CATALAN
THEN. ZERO AND WE HAVE A COMING
FROM THE LINE TO THE SIX.
PLEASE CALL. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS DISCOURAGED TO
CALL NURSES ALSO IN SONGS TO
THANK. THANK YOU. N. FROM LINE
NUMBER OLD PLEASE GOT. MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SIR BROWN THE FACT
UNDER OF THE CAL TEACHER THIS.
WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
I WOULD HAVE NUMBER. NINE
SEVEN. SHE KEPT REBECCA CAN OF
A NATIONALIST OF SOCIAL WORK
POWER CHAP AND TOOK. THANK YOU.
ADELINE NUMBER TWO TEN BAKER
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA FIVE
FOR EVERYTHING A LOT THE CAN
BOARD OF. IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
POINT YOU. NINE NUMBER TWO
ELEVEN- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS SAM NASH OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE AT NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN LEVINE
UNITED MAGIC WORKERS ASKED ME
THIRTY NINE THIRTY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ALL WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GIVE ME WHAT WITH THAT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY DOCTOR
OFTEN BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINE
I HAD. WELCOME TO ATTEND THE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND LINE
NUMBER ONE NO. FORTY SEVEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE FORTY
SEVEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. YES
HI I'M SORRY IT'S JUST THAT I
HAVE WE HAVE SOME OF OUR AN
ISSUE THE NUMBER BUT HARD TO
TELL WHEN IT'S OUR TURN BUT
THIS IS MERRY MORENO IN FULL
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE BRITISH ARE SAUDI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
EFFECT. THE COURT OF AB TWO SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
DANIEL GUTERRES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AN UNEXPECTED FROM
MY NUMBER. ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
YEAH MANY HIGHER CAL CIVIL
AGREED THAT THE EARNS A AND WE
ARE ALL WANTS. THANK YOU. THEIR
LAST COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE UP TO NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JIM WOOD
BURKE ON B. OF THE IDEOLOGICAL-
CAL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ALL WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE. INTO PORT IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU NOW WE HEAR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I BRIAN SHERMAN
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S. AND COREY
SELVES ELOTE- CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS. YOU HAVE BOTH YOU
GENTLEMEN HAVE FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL OF MISTER SHERMAN- MISTER
CELSO. WILL WANT TO GO FIRST.
COREY SO LONG HERE MISTER CHAIR.
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY
SAYS HELLO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX- WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
LARGELY BECAUSE IT WOULD UNDO
PORTION OF LANDMARK LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE OF FORCE
REFORMS THAT WERE CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATED WHILE CODIFYING
PROVISIONS THAT WILL CONFUSE
STATUTES CAN PUT OFFICER SAFETY
AT RISK. OVER THE COURSE OF
MORE THAN ONE YEAR STAKEHOLDERS
WORKED ON SIGNIFICANT REFORMS
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT USE OF FORCE
STATUTE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
POLICIES. DEMAND AB THREE
NINETY TWO AND SB TWO THIRTY
WERE THE RESULT OF THIS
COLLABORATION THOSE BILLS
ULTIMATELY ENJOYED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT.
MOST OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDING THE STATE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTED S. B. TWO
THIRTY AND REMOVED ITS
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE NINETY
TWO BASED ON THE FINAL AGREED
UPON VERSIONS OF THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED INTO LAW. AB TWENTY SIX
HOWEVER HAD SIGNIFICANT NEW
REQUIREMENTS TO THE USE OF
FORCE POLICY PROVISIONS THAT
FORM THE BASIS OF THIS
COMPROMISE ON SB TWO THIRTY
MAYBE THREE NINETY TWO.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
THE USE OF FORCE POLICY REQUIRE
OFFICERS TO IMMEDIATELY. REPORT
POTENTIAL EXCESSIVE FORCE WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY REQUIRING
OFFICERS TO INTERCEDE IN THE
USE OF FORCE. IT OFFICER
REQUIRED TO REPORT THE USE OF
POTENTIAL EXCESSIVE FORCE
BEFORE ATTEMPTING TO STOP IT.
ADDITIONALLY AS B. TWO THIRTIES
PROVISION REGARDING OFFICERS
NEEDED INTERCEDING KNOWLEDGES
THE POSSIBILITY THAT OTHER
OFFICERS MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. REGARDING THE
THREAT POSED BY SUBJECT RELIES
UPON THE STANDARD OF OBJECTIVE.
REASONABLENESS WELL MAYBE
TWENTY SIX ELIMINATES THE
REFERENCE TO THE FORMER AND
REDEFINED EXCESSIVE FORCE. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENT REMOVING THE NEW
CRIME OF BEING AN ACCESSORY TO
AN EXCESSIVE FORCE- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY GIVEN THE FACT
THAT- WE NEGOTIATED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ACCOMPLISH
SIGNIFICANT REFORM- WELL
PROTECTING COMMUNITY OFFICER
SAFETY- THIS BILL SEEKS TO
BYPASS THAT HISTORIC
COMPROMISE- IN HAS BURDENSOME
NEW REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS TO AFTER
OFFICER SAFETY FOR THESE
REASONS WE MUST OPPOSE. AB
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THIS IS A MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE. THIRTY- THE
THOUSAND DEDICATED CAL PIZZA
AND MUST USE WHATEVER OPS THIS
TO AB TWENTY SIX BOB FRANKEN BY
LAW AS BILLS PROBLEM TO A
NUMBER WAYS. THE BILL REQUIRES
NINETIES BEEN FOUND BY A LOT
AGENCIES EMPLOYS THEM HAVE THAT
YOU YOU SIX OF THAT WE IN.
GREAT FALLS INJURY ARE OF A
NUMBER OF. OR YOU HAVE FAILED
TO USE THAT. ARE JUST QUALIFY
HOLDING I. THAT'S P. ALSO BEING
AS A PEACE. I MEMBERS EXISTING
LAW PRETTY EX. USE OF FOR. BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT. HELD FROM THE
BELIEVE ARE. THE OVER. REQUIRED
LADY A OF THIS. AND I. AND
APPEARED TO BE BECAUSE- CLASS
BUT- AB TWO SIX CONTAINS NO
WHAT THAT WOULD LIMIT THE RETRO
APPLE. OF THE SEVERE PENALTY
FOR LONG. STEFANEK AB TWENTY
COULD RENDER OFFICER
IMMEDIATELY CALL. SERVICE
PLEASE STOP. BASED ON THE BUT
WE HAVE HERE SOMETHING PRIOR
DURING TIME WHEN USE OF
STANDARDS K. LOWERED. FAILURE
WHICH MANDATES THAT THEY BE
DISCIPLINE SAME MANNER AS
YASSER WHO COMMITTED THE
EXCESSIVE FORCE. REQUIRING AN
OFFICER TO BE PUNISHED OF THE
CIVIC CENTER DR FOUND TWELVE
YEARS BECAUSE OF FORCED. INTO
RETIREMENT DISPROPORTIONATE AND
UNJUST. SHARES YOU KNOW THAT
REMEMBER THIS COMMITTEE
RECENTLY AMENDED ONLY.
MARKETABLE CALIFORNIA. WHICH
TRANSFECTION DIDN'T TO READ
PURCHASE MY- WE'RE NOT FINISHED
TO THE SAME EXTENT BECAUSE THIS.
WHO KILLED AFFECT. ALLEGED AND
THE GOVERNOR CREATE AND STATE
LAWS CHANGED AS A RESULT OF
PASSAGE BUT SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN SKINNER. THEREFORE WE
MUST HAVE THE APPROPRIATE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE THE
POSITION OF THE PEACE OFFICERS
WHO WITNESSED ANOTHER OFFICER'S
BALL IN THE GREAT BODILY INJURY
OR DEATH OF MILICEVICTHE-
MANDATED JUST. LEFT CLICK ON
THE SUBMIT. EXISTING LAW
ALREADY REQUIRE AND TO IN ONE
ANOTHER ON YOU USE THAT FORCE
AND ALSO A OFFICERS TO REPORT
THIS TO FORCE TO SERVICE TO
PROVIDE. LAST WEEK- A MEMBER OF.
IN THE BILL THIS THE FUNDING
CALL COULD. FOR EXAMPLE WORK
INTO IN. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PURPOSES OF THIS BILL. ALSO
MOBILE ONE FORCED ME TO SEIZE
MOST ARE EXEMPT FROM AB TWENTY
SIX THANKS FOR CALLING
ADDITIONAL CONFUSION SECURITY
ESPECIALLY DURING JOINT TASK
FORCE OPERATION. FOR THE
REASONS AND THEN OTHERS
RIVERSIDE SHIPS THE NATION THE
POST AB TWENTY SIX RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOTEBOOKS. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN A ROOM. ARE ANY WITNESSES ON
A VIDEO CONFERENCE. AT&T
OPERATOR WILL NOW GO TO PHONE
LINE. YOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS APPLY NET THEN IS ZERO
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MATTHEW SEVERAL AND I'M HAPPY
SAYS HE'S A LOS ANGELES DEPUTY
SHERIFFS OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE BOTH A
RADICALLY IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT FALL WE
HAVE ALL. WELL MY NUMBER ONE
SIXTY THREE I APOLOGIZE. YOUR
MEMBER ID ON THE BILL. WHATYOU
DOT YOUR MEMBERS JONATHON
FELDMAN THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION- ALSO COSTA
RICA THANKS. THANK YOU. FOR THE
NEXT FIVE WE HAVE A ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT
EASILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT LINE IS
TWO HUNDRED AND ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER MEMBERS RANDY
PERRY ON BEHALF PORAC IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HOPPED
HOLDEN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE TO A-
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CAREY MEMBERS BRENDAN UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE LAST
ONE WE HAD IN Q. INCLINE OVER
TO EIGHTEEN. HI RUBIO LUCIEN ON
BEHALF OF THE HAVE CRITICAL
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
AND SAN DIEGO DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- APPRECIATIVE OF
SOME RECENT CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR WE OPPOSE THE LESSON
NEEDED. AND HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK OUT A COUPLE OF REMAINING
ISSUES TO A POTENTIALLY GO
NEUTRAL OR POSSIBLY EVEN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE
OPPOSITION IN THE QUEUE OKAY.
Q. AND BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MISTER
CORK I THINK IS THE FIRST
QUESTION- MOVE THE BILL- SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL I
THINK WE ABSOLUTELY NEED A WAY
TO DECERTIFY POLICE OFFICERS WE
DON'T HAVE A- AND THIS WOULD
GIVE US THAT OPPORTUNITY-
SECOND. OF SOME OF THE
OBJECTIONS- OF THE OPPOSITION
IN PARTICULAR- YOU'VE ALREADY
CONCEDED- ON THEM YOU SAID THAT
WHEN YOU FIRST ARRIVE THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO PUNISH THE
OBSERVING OFFICER. SO I HAVE I
HOPE THEY LISTEN MORE CAREFULLY
TO WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY. THIS
IS SOMETHING WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
AND I WOULD JUST SAY TO THE
OPPOSITION. UP PLEASE FIND A
WAY TO WORK WITH MR HOLDEN ON
THIS. I'LL ALSO NOTE THAT WELL
YOU'VE OBJECTED THAT THIS IS A
NEW DETERMINATION OF EXCESSIVE
FORCE THIS IS IN A VERY SHORT
DIFFERENT SITUATION. THEN THE
BILL THAT WE PASSED- TWO YEARS
AGO. AND SO WE NEED A
DEFINITION NOW IF YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH IT PLEASE WORK
WITH MR HOLDEN I'M HOPING WE
CAN- WELL WE WILL PASS A BILL
LIKE THIS AND PLEASE DON'T BE
LEFT BEHIND. PLEASE HELP US
MAKE IT A GOOD BILL THANK YOU.
MR LEE. SEVERAL THAT WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND HOW IMPORTANT
THIS CONVERSATION IS- I
DEFINITELY WELL I HEARD OF THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS AND I AM
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION BELIEVES
IN GIVING SECOND CHANCES TO
PEOPLE THAT DEBTS UP DID
SOMETHING DECADES AGO- I DON'T
WHEN I READ THE BILL I DON'T
SEE IT AS RETROACTIVE A FIRE
TRUCK TO USE THAT IS THAT'S
TRUE IT IS IT IS NOT
RETROACTIVE BUT ALL RIGHT RIGHT
WELL I DO AND I ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM A STELLAR RECORD
I DO HOPE THAT THEY WILL. COME
TO A MIDDLE GROUND WITH YOU
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE GIVEN VERY
CONSERVATORY AND MAKING CHANGES
THAT MAKE SENSE TO IT. AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS
WELL. IN OTHER QUESTIONS. YOU
MAY CLOSE MISTER. HOLD UP WELL
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE. THE
MEMBERS F THE COMMITTEE WITH
THEIR THEIR COMMENTS THAT SORT
OF. WAS WHAT I WAS GOING TO SAY
THAT THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
BILL THE TALKS ABOUT
RETROACTIVITY- BUT IT IS CLEAR
THAT THERE'S A NEED. TO DO
SOMETHING. AND WE HAVE WORKED
VERY HARD TO IN THE PREVIOUS
ITERATION OF THIS BILL WHEN WE
INITIATED IN THE SENATE. AT THE
END OF LAST SESSION- TO NOW- TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE TRYING
TO HEAR WHAT THE CONCERNS WERE.
VERY ENERGETIC INDICATED THAT-
THERE NEEDED TO BE SOME-
ADDRESSING. A RETALIATION. THAT
WAS LAW ENFORCEMENT'S INSERTION
INTO THIS BILL. I AGREED WITH
IT. HAD MADE ALL THE SENSE IN
THE WORLD. WE REMOVED WHEN
THERE WAS CONCERN- OF PUBLIC
INTERNET WEBSITES. WE TOOK THAT
OUT OF THE BILL. WE REMOVE THE
REVISION THAT WAS PUT IN. THE
PREVIOUS BILL- IN THE- IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON. A REVISED
DEFINITION OF THIS. OF
NECESSITY. WE TOOK THAT OUT OF
THE BILL- AND AS IT. RELATES TO
THE MOST CURRENT- REMOVAL. THE
ACCESSORY TO A CRIME. WE HAVE
ALSO TAKEN THAT OUT- THE BILL.
PRESERVES AND OFFICERS RIGHT TO
PETITION- THEIR EMPLOYMENT
AGENCY- DURING THE
INVESTIGATION TO INDICATE. AND
SHOW EVIDENCE WHY THEY DID
INTERCEDE AND SO THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DO THAT AND EVEN IF
THEY DON'T AGREE. AND THE
AGENCY DECIDES THAT THEY DID
NOT INTERCEDED EVIDENCE THAT
THEY PRESENTED WAS NOT
SUFFICIENT. THEY STILL HAVE A
RIGHT TO CHALLENGE
APPROPRIATELY AT THE NEXT
LEVEL- SO THAT THEY ALWAYS HAVE
PRESERVED THEIR RIGHTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR VOICES ARE
HEARD- I JUST THINK THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN I THINK OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THAT THE CHEER FOR YOUR-
HEARING THIS BILL I THINK IT IS
A VERY TIMELY INAPPROPRIATE AND
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS.
HOW CAN I ALSO BUT I WILL
CONTINUE MY DOOR IS ALWAYS OPEN.
SO I'M WILLING TO HEAR
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND
THOUGHTS ON THIS BILL FROM THE
OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
CHANGES ALONG THE WAY. GEN OKAY
SO MR HOLDEN- I PROBABLY NO
BETTER NAME ANYBODY ELSE HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS. TO WORK.
THROUGH THESE DAYS DIFFICULT
ISSUE- I DO HAVE A QUESTION OR
TWO. FOUR MISTER SHERMAN AND MR
CELL THE FELLOW- IF THEY'RE
STILL ON THE LINE. YES MISTER.
SO YOU HERE MR THANK YOU YOU
HEAR MR HOLDEN. REALLY WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU. SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE LAW ENFORCEMENT BETTER.
AND I'M NOT JUMPING ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE YOU KNOW MR
HOLDEN EYES ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND EVERYBODY OVER HERE NOT
EVERYONE DOESN'T ELECTED
OFFICIAL. I HAVE HAD IMPECCABLE
BOB. CAREERS YOU KNOW IF YOU
SAY THE WORD SHRIMP OR SHRIMP
OR SHRIMP GATE WE'VE WE'VE HAD
OUR OWN. THAT WE HAD TO CLEAN
UP. AND WE'VE HAD PEOPLE WHO'VE
DONE SOME MEAT TO STUFF. THAT
WE HAD TO CLEAN UP OUR HOUSE.
AND SO WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO ASK.
LAW ENFORCEMENT. HOW DO YOU
HELP US BECAUSE YOU'LL GET A
BILL LIKE THIS EVERY TIME IF
YOU DON'T HELP US HELP YOU.
MEETING UP HOW DO WE GET RID OF.
WHITE RACIST SUPREMACIST WHO
ARE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS IS
ALL THIS IS GETTING PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD NEVER BEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND YOU MAY I'M
UNION BACK YOU MAY HAVE A- A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT. AND
REPRESENT THEM. BUT THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT WEEK BY WEEK MONTH BY
MONTH IT MAKES IT REALLY HARD.
FOR US TO DEFEND YOU TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. EVERY DAY WHEN
THEY SEE SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS
MR HOLDEN IS MAKING A VALIANT
EFFORT. AND I STILL BELIEVE
THAT THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE LAW ENFORCEMENT BETTER
THE ONLY WAY YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
RECRUIT MORE. MINORITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS IS WITH LAWS LIKE
THIS WERE YOU ALLOWED. THIS
BILL REALLY JUST ALLOW YOU. TO
BE ABLE TO ROOT OUT THE BAD
ELEMENTS. BETTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT RIGHT NOW. THIS
WITH THIS LOT THAT. AND IT
PROTECTS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
BRAVE ENOUGH. AND GUTSY ENOUGH
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT WITHOUT
THE FEAR OF RETALIATION. OR THE
CAREER STEIN. THIS IS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS START STEP PROCESS.
AND SO IF THIS IS NOT ENOUGH TO
READ OUT THE BAD ELEMENT. AND
I'LL SAY IT ON HERE. THAT MIGHT
BE 1% OR LESS BUT THAT 1% IT'S
KILLING YOU SO WHAT CAN YOU.
RECOMMEND TO MR HOLDEN. THAT
WILL HELP US GET TO A PLACE.
WHERE TRUST. AND I USED TO WORK
FOR YOUR HONOR IT BECAUSE A LOT
OF PROBLEMS BEFORE. MMHM BUT
WHEN PEOPLE OF COLOR I'M MORE
AFRAID OF BEING INCARCERATED.
OR DEPORTED. BY PEOPLE WEAR
BADGES THAT'S A PROBLEM AND WE
NEED TO CORRECT IT WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO CORRECT IT SO
THAT ALL OUR COMP COMMUNITIES
NOT ONLY FEEL SAFE BUT WE CAN
WE MOVE FORWARD. DO YOU HAVE
ANY IDEAS. OF HOW TO ROOT OUT
INDIVIDUALS WHO PROBABLY SHOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN. LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN THE FIRST PLACE
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T DO ENOUGH
SCREENING WE DIDN'T DO ENOUGH
MENTAL HEALTH- EVALUATIONS OR
MAYBE THEY WERE JUST TOO YOUNG
OR MAYBE NOT. BEEN ABLE TO
HANDLE IT WHAT CAN WE DO
OTHERWISE FOR TO KEEP COMING
BACK WITH THE FIXES THAT WE
BELIEVE. WE'LL MAKE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BETTER. BUT RIGHT
NOW WE'RE NOT GETTING ANYTHING.
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T EVEN GET
MORE IN A LOT WHEN YOU WHEN
YOUR OFFICERS ASSEMBLY REALLY
HORRENDOUS. LIKE A MISTER FLOYD
SNACK. I'M HEARING THAT HOW DO
YOU KNOW WHEN TO STOP. WELL
MISTER FLOYD WAS IT WHEN HE
STARTED CRYING FOR HIS MOTHER.
WHEN IT WAS. WHEN THE AFTER HIS
HANDS IN HIS POCKET AND HAD HIS
KNEE ON HIS NECK. WHEN IT WHEN
DO YOU AS A AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. THAT'S WHY
THE DID THE STANDARD IS HIGHER.
BECAUSE YOU'RE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER YOU'RE NOT
SOME KID JOY RIDE IN A CAR.
THAT'S UNDER AGE THE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE HECK THEY'RE DOING.
YOU ARE SPECIALLY TRAINED
OFFICERS. THEY SHOULD KNOW WHEN.
ANOTHER OFFICER IS PUTTING SOME
ONE IN DANGER YOU GO TO DEVELOP
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SITUATIONS
YOU SEE THIS ALL THE TIME. SO I
BELIEVE I DO YOU NEED MORE
TRAINING. OR WE NEED TO REALLY
HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT. HOW
MUCH PROTECTION DO YOU NEED TO
GO TO PROTECT PEOPLE WHO REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE OFFICERS ANYMORE.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S REALLY ABOUT
AND WE HAVE ENOUGH RESEARCH.
HAS BEEN GIVEN TO THIS
COMMITTEE TO SHOW. THAT
DESTRUCTION ARE FOR EVERYBODY
REALLY IT IS A HARD JOB. AND I
WILL ADMIT IT EVERY DAY IS
PROBABLY IF NOT THE HARDEST JOB
YOU COULD POSSIBLY HAVE IS VERY
DIFFICULT SO MR HOLDEN'S BILL
IS ALLOWING YOU AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO MAKE A DRASTIC CHANGE. I
KNOW YOU TRIED IT BY THE BALLOT
IT'S LIKE THE BALLOT IN THE
BILL HE TRIED BY THE BALLOT. IT
DIDN'T WORK. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WANT YOU TO CHANGE
PROP 47-57. AND IN MAY BE DOWN.
ALL THE CHANGES YOU WANT LAST
YEAR. AND EVEN ELECTED FOLK
THAT YOU PROBABLY WON'T AGREE
WITH YOU STILL FIGHTING WITH.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THE PEOPLE WANT
AT THE BALLOT. AND PUTTING
TARGETS ON ELECTED OFFICIALS.
BY PUTTING TARGETS ON BLACK
PEOPLE'S BACK YOU THINK THAT'S
GOING TO WIN THEM OVER. AT THE
END OF THE DAY YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE. TO CHANGE BECAUSE THAT'S
THE WAVE IT'S GOING. IT'S
HAPPENING NO MATTER WHAT YOU DO
TO ANY OF US. THE WAVE IS HERE
IT'S HAPPENING AND THERE'S
NOTHING YOU CAN DO ABOUT IT
EXCEPT. EITHER PARTICIPATE IN
IT. FOR THE DEFECTS OF WHAT
WILL HAPPEN WITH THINGS THAT
YOU WON'T LIKE. AND WE WILL GO
TOO FAR TO THE LEFT. WE WILL SO
WE NEED YOUR HELP MR HOLD I
KNOW IT'S A VERY LONG SPEECH
WERE ARE A QUESTION THAT I HAVE
FOR MISTER SHERMAN MYSELF STILL.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS. ON HOW
TO HELP MR HOLDEN. READ THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OF PEOPLE
WHO PROBABLY SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LEICESTERSHIRE'S THIS COURSE
THE STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
HAPPY TO TRY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION WERE MORE THAN WILLING
TO CONTINUE SPEAKING WITH- THE
AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL- WE RAISED SIMILAR
OBJECTIONS TO THE BILL LAST
YEAR WHICH ULTIMATELY DIDN'T
MOVE- AGAIN NOTED WITH
APPRECIATION THE REMOVAL OF THE
LANGUAGE ON THE ACCESSORY- AND
I WILL ALSO TELL YOU SORT OF.
INDEPENDENT I GUESS RELATEDLY
TO THIS BILL THAT- WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE NOTION OF
SOME TYPE OF SYSTEM OF YOU KNOW
DECERTIFICATION ARE AS YOU SAID
GETTING RID OF THE BAD APPLES
WHO SHOULD NOT BE PEACE
OFFICERS BUT WE'RE WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT IDEA WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH- BOTH SIDES
IN BOTH HOUSES SINCE LAST YEAR
ON TRYING TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S AGREEABLE THAT
WORKS- WE COULDN'T CROSS THE
FINISH LINE LAST YEAR- BUT WE
ARE. WE ARE COMMITTED TO THAT-
IN IN SOME FORM OR FASHION TO
FIND A WAY WHERE MANAGEMENT-
I'LL JUST SPEAK FROM A
MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE CAN
ADDRESS THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE
THERE ARE OFFICERS. WHO ARE
ACTING OUTSIDE OF THE LAW ARE
ACTING OUTSIDE OF THE POLICY
BECAUSE FRANKLY IT'S DIFFICULT
A LOT OF TIMES AND I DON'T WANT
TO TURN THIS INTO A LABOR
RELATIONS MANAGEMENT OR
MANAGEMENT VERSUS LABOR ISSUE
BUT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
CHALLENGES- WIND THERE ARE
FOLKS WHO SHOULDN'T BE PEACE
OFFICERS AND YES THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR. DUE PROCESS
AND THAT SHOULD BE OBSERVED BUT
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT- THE
STATEMENT THAT YOU MADE IN THAT
THAT MANY OTHER AUTHORS AND
PROPONENTS OF HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT
IN TERMS OF- CHANGE AND AGAIN
SO I WOULD JUST REITERATE THAT
WE ARE. SUPPORTIVE OF THE
NOTION OF- AS AS OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS ARE WILL
SPEAK FOR THEM- BUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING THERE IS AN EFFORT
ONGOING TO ADDRESS THAT THE
CHALLENGES WITH THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR- I WOULD JUST NOTE
ARE. YOU KNOW MORE OF THIS
QUESTION OF YOU MUST
IMMEDIATELY REPORT. THE
EXCESSIVE FORCE AND THEN YOU
MUST INTERCEDE AGAIN WHICH HAVE
FIRST WHICH CALL. FOR THAT AND
MAYBE IT'S JUST SOME
CLARIFICATION THAT NEEDS TO
TAKE PLACE BUT IT'S NO REALLY.
AND THEN FRANKLY- LANGUAGE THAT
EXPRESSES THE NOTION OF. WHEN
ANOTHER OFFICER ARRIVED ON THE
SCENE THAT DOESN'T HAVE ALL THE
FACTS IN HAND OF AN OFFICER
WHO'S BEEN THERE LONGER THAT
WAS CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED
LANGUAGE. NOT MINUTES BEING
REMOVED BY THIS BILL SO THERE'S
SOME SPECIFIC THINGS BUT AGAIN
GENERALLY TO YOUR POINT MISTER
CHAIR- WERE PLEASED TO CONTINUE
SPEAKING NOT ONLY ABOUT THIS
BILL BUT ON THE REFORM EFFORTS
GENERALLY. IN OUR AND I WOULD
ALSO HOMES CARE ABOUT GOING
WITH. CORY I WAS. TRYING
CHAMBER WHAT THE REVELATION OF
THE NATION'S- OF HELLO TO
ACTUALLY ECHO. LARGELY THE
COMMENT- MICHAEL TO OUTDOOR- WE
ARE ALSO- INTERESTED IN NOT
HAVING A BAD COPS AMONG OUR
RANKS ACROSS OF THE FORTUNE-
BECAUSE WITH. ALL SORTS OF
PROBLEMS AND THAT THE
ASSOCIATION WERE REQUIRED BY
LAW TO. DEFEND THEM- SO WE'RE
NOT INTERESTED IN HAVING BAD
COPS AND I THINK WE CAN ALL
WORK TOGETHER HALL ON-
DEFINITELY THE DISSERTATION- OR
OPEN TO IT. AND WE'D LOVE TO-
WORK WITH THE. AUTHOR AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. HELLO THE
POINT I'M MAKING IS. WE NEED
YOUR HELP TO GET THIS DONE. YOU
KNOW I'M A CITY EMPLOYEE FORMER
CITY MANAGER AND SEE LOS
ANGELES I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO FAR. SOMEONE WAS CIVIL
SERVICE STATUS IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. AND SO I GET I GET
THAT. BUT IF YOU PUT IN THE
WORK YOU CAN GET PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD BE WORKING FOR
GOVERNMENT OUT OF THEM- ALI ONE
OF THE PROUDEST. TIMES SINCE
I'VE BEEN CHEERS COMMITTEE HAD
BEEN WHEN MY OWN POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE- DENOUNCED.
BABCOCK'S I DON'T SEE A LOT
WITH THE OTHER ASSOCIATIONS ON
HERE. I DON'T SEE A WHOLE LOT
OF PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THE
GANGS. DARREN A LAD SIN L. A.
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. I DON'T
SEE YOU GUYS TALKING ABOUT HOW
YOU GONNA GET RID OF THEM. AS
YOU DEFENDING SO WHEN YOU COME
TO US AND TELL US. THAT YOU.
WANT TO HELP. BUT YOU BRING ME
BILLS ON THIS COMMITTEE EVERY
DAY TO PUT MORE BLACK AND BROWN
FOLKS IN JAIL BUT YOU'RE NOT
PREMIUM NOT ONE. BILL TO HELP
US GET RID OF BAD COPS. DAY YOU
DO THAT THE DAY YOU HELP MR
HOLDEN. WILL BE THE DAY. THAT
YOU'LL GET THE FAITH OF THE
COMMUNITY BACK AGAIN. THE AND
IF IT'S YOUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT ALL COPS BEEN AS A
UNION I GET THAT BUT YOU NEED
TO BE HONEST ABOUT THAT AND NOT
SAY YOU'RE DOING ONE THING AND
ANOTHER I'VE LOOKED AT YOU GUYS
SHIP YOUR HANDS YOU PROMISED ME
YOU WOULD WORK ON PROP FORTY
SEVEN FIXES IN FIFTY SEVEN
FIXES. INSTEAD TURN AROUND TRY
TO KILL. SO YOU'VE GOT TO BE
HONEST ABOUT WHAT YOU REALLY
WANT TO DO. AND IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE GENUINE
ABOUT IT WOULD BE DISINGENUOUS.
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE WHO
TOOK AMENDMENTS THEY PROBABLY
DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE. HE'S
TRYING TO WORK WITH YOU. AND
THEN YOU COME HERE IN MASS. AND
TRY TO KILL THE BILL. DOES NOT
RIGHT. SO IT'S JUST IT IS TIME
THAT WE STOP THIS FARCE AND
REALLY TRY TO MAKE. REALLY TRY
TO GET RID LAW ENFORCEMENT
START HAVING PEACE OFFICERS
JUST WANNA SEE YOU GOTTA STOP
BEING LAW ENFORCEMENT BE PEACE
OFFICERS SO WHEN YOU COME TO
SEE. YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT
ATTITUDE. THEN PUTTING PEOPLE
DOWN HURTING THEM. SO I'M NOT
SURE COULD THIS. I WANT THIS
BILL TO GET THROUGH BUT MOST
IMPORTANT I WANT YOU TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR. TO MAKE IT
WORK FOR BOTH SIDES. CHEERS
RECOMMENDED I GO. ON AB TWENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MANAGE THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY. OUR CAN. CORK
HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO. C. R. TO
SAY OUR TURN NOW WICKS. LEE AT
LI I. IT MEASURES ON CALL TALK
THANK YOU RESEARCHER YOUR.
MISTER KALRA. AB TWO FIVE SIX
CAR CRIMINAL. PROCEDURE
DISCRIMINATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
DESPITE PUBLIC HEALTH INSURANCE
IS CHALLENGING YOUR
CALIFORNIA'S GLOBAL TO PASS
SOME OF THE MOST MEANINGFUL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS IS
LEGISLATIVE HISTORY AND AS THE
WORLD WITNESSED THE KILLING AND
TORTURE GEORGE FORMER POLICE
OFFICERS. THE SET IN MOTION A
MOVEMENT FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
THAT UNDOUBTEDLY. GOVERNORS ARE
NEED TO READ OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM OF THE ILLS. OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM. AMONG THESE
CALLS A CALIFORNIA ACIAL
JUSTICE ACT WAS HISTORIC. IT
WAS A PROFOUND STEP FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING INSTITUTIONALIZED
IMPLICIT RACIAL BIAS IN OUR
CRIMINAL COURTS BY EMPOWERING
DEFENDANTS TO OBJECT OBJECTIVE
CHARGES CONVICTIONS OR
PUNISHMENTS. BASED UPON RACE
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN.
THE ACT OVERTURNED A MORE THAN
THIRTY YEAR LEGAL PRECEDENT
ESTABLISHED IN THE CASE OF THE
KLASKY B. CAMP. KNOWN AS THE
MCCLUSKY DECISION THE US
SUPREME COURT. HAD FOR TOO LONG
REQUIRED THE ACCUSED IN
CRIMINAL CASES TO PROVE
INTENTIONAL DISCRIMINATION WHEN
CHALLENGING RACIAL BIAS IN THE
LEGAL PROCESS. THIS INSISTENCE
ON PROOF OF INTENTIONAL OR
PURPOSEFUL DISCRIMINATION.
ESTABLISH A LEGAL STANDARD THAT
WAS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET.
IN A DISSENT JUSTICE WILLIAM
BRENNAN WROTE THAT THE DECISION
WAS DRIVEN BY A FEAR OF TOO
MUCH JUSTICE. THE PRACTICAL
EFFECT OF THIS WIDELY CONDEMNED
DECISION ALLOWED RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION TO PERVADE OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM UNCHECKED. IN SO
DOING CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN SOME
OF THE WORST RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN TERMS OF CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS AND SENTENCES IN
THE COUNTRY. A BLACK PERSON'S
OVER EIGHT TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE INCARCERATED THAN A WHITE
PERSON. THE PERSONALLY. THE
CRIMES THIS IS ONE OF THE WORST
DISPARITIES IN THE COUNTRY FAR
WORSE THAN ANY SOUTHERN STATE.
BUT YOU KNOW THE DEFENDANTS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE CONVICTED OF
BOTH THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE CONVICTED OR OTHER CASES.
THIS MESSED. BLACK LATINO
DEFENDANTS. OR MORE LIKELY TO
RECEIVE A FELONY VERSES MISTER
CONVICTION ONE COMPARED TO
WHITE DEFENDANTS BLACK MEN
CONVICTED OF A FELONY OR 42%
MORE LIKELY TO BE SENTENCED TO
PRISON THAN A WHITE MAN
CONVICTED OF A FELONY FILIPINO
MAN CONVICTED OF A FELONY A 33%
MORE LIKELY TO BE SENT TO
PRISON. THIS TROUBLED HISTORY
OF PROSECUTING AND
INCARCERATING PEOPLE OF COLOR.
ARE MUCH HIGHER REACH THE
GENERAL POPULATION. NEEDS TO BE
RECKONED WITH THE WE DID RECKON
WITH IT LAST YEAR. AS WE PASS
ON THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THE
RACIAL JUSTICE ACT. HOWEVER THE
APT APPLICATION OF EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW SHOULDN'T
BE LIMITED. TO THE ACCUSED WHO
HAPPEN TO BE TRIED CONVICTED.
AND SENTENCED IN THE CRIMINAL
COURTS AFTER JANUARY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR. THAT IS WHY
RETROACTIVE RELIEF IN THE
CALIFORNIA RACIAL JUSTICE ACT
SHOULD BE AFFORDED TO ALL.
THOSE WITH PAST INJUSTICES. AB
TWO FIVE SIX IS THE RACIAL
JUSTICE ACT FOR ALL OF THE
GRANT DOES THE JUDGMENTS
RENDERED PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TO USE
THE PROTECTIONS OF THE ACT. TO
PETITION THE COURT TO SEEK
POTENTIAL REMEDY INVOLVING A
RACIAL BIAS IN THEIR CASE.
ADDITIONALLY AB TWO FIFTY SIX
MAKES A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL NON
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO THE ACT.
THE REQUESTED A PERSON IF THEY
DEMONSTRATE THE RACISM TAINTED
THEIR TRIAL. MAY SEEK A RETRIAL
RESENTENCING THIS BILL DOES NOT
RELEASE PEOPLE OR GUARANTEE AN
EARLIER PAROLE DAY. THE WITH
PRIOR BIASED CONVICTIONS AND
SENTENCES DESERVE EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW AND IT'S AND IT'S
A COMMON SAYS IT'S A
COMMONSENSE RECOGNITION. OF HOW
UNBELIEVABLY DIFFICULT IT WAS
FOR CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS. TO
PROVE RACIAL BIAS WAS A FACTOR
IN THE CASE. ADDITIONALLY
PROVIDING A MECHANISM FOR
RETROACTIVE RELIEF WILL ALLOW
THE STATE TO REALIZE
SIGNIFICANT CORRECTIONAL
SAVINGS. COLLEAGUES I'M
IMMENSELY PROUD OF THE WORK WE
ACCOMPLISHED TOGETHER BUT IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE NOT STOP
UNTIL EVERYONE IS AFFORDED AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO PURSUE EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE RACIAL
JUSTICE ACT. TO ILLUSTRATE WHY
WE NEED THE RACES JUST SUCK FOR
ALL YOU'LL HEAR FROM WITNESSES
WITH FAMILY THAT ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. FOR WHICH RACE
PLAYED A FACTOR. JOY RODRIGUEZ
BROTHER HUGO CHAVEZ WHO IS
CURRENTLY IN PRISON AND
FIGHTING THE CASE AN APPELLATE
COURT AND ME GO MAKE THEM SON
OF. OF MAKE MICHAEL MCCANN WHO
IS ALSO CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
OR PROSECUTORS WERE ABLE TO USE
RACIAL UNDERTONES THE CASE.
ALSO ON THE LINE NOT PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BUT AVAILABLE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON THE
RACIAL JUSTICE ACT IS THE TASHA
MR THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU.
AT&T JOY RODRIGUEZ ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. I AM CAN YOU MAY
PROCEED. OKAY ARE THANK YOU-
HELLO AND I WANT TO THANK ME
FOR BEING HERE FOR CONSIDERING
THIS ALL IMPORTANT ISSUE MANY
JOYFUL WE GET BUT PEOPLE OF
FAMILY MEMBER I AM HERE TODAY
TO GIVE MY BROTHER HE WOULD
HAVE SUPPORT. MAKE THANK YOU
WHAT WAS REYES AND IN THE HOUSE
WITH ANY PREDOMINANTLY.
COMMUNITY KNOWN AS OUR
COMMUNITY AT THE AGE OF THIRTY
ONE. YOU WILL HAVE A CAREER BY
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGIES AND NO
PRIOR COMMIT CRIMINAL
CONVICTION. UNCHECKED RACIAL
BIAS FROM PROSECUTOR AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT GAME EXPERTS DURING
TRIAL LET YOU GO BEING FOUND
GUILTY OF A MURDER HE DID NOT
COMMIT. AND RESULT IN A
SENTENCE OF A HUNDRED AND FIVE
YEARS TO LIFE. I ASKED THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD CAREFULLY
CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING EXAMPLE
FROM THE TRIAL PROCEEDINGS IN
WHICH- HE WOULD BE ON THE
DEPEND. ON NUMBER ONE THE
PROSECUTOR. WHO USED ASPECTS OF
LOCAL CULTURE AND GANG ACTIVITY
INTERCHANGEABLY WHICH CREATOR
RACIAL BIAS AGAINST YOU GOING
YOUNG HISPANIC MALES. NUMBER
TWO THE DA EXPLICITLY USE THE
TERMS TO FEDEX REGAIN MEMBERS
CONTINUALLY THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF THE TRIAL SO SEATING
GANG ACTIVITY WHICH I QUOTE A
PARTICULAR NEIGHBORHOOD.
REFERENCING THE ALMA COMMUNITY
CENTER AS A BREEDING GROUND FOR
GANG MEMBERS NUMBER THREE THIS
RESULTED IN CREATING A
REPRISALS. INSPIRED YOUR CALL
ON REASONABLY BELIEVED HER LIFE
WAS IN DANGER STATING AND I
QUOTE GIVN THE NATURE OF THE
TESTIMONY AND RECURRING PEOPLE
IN THE AUDIENCE. THAT BASED ON
DESCRIPTIONS OF WHAT GANG
MEMBERS LOOK LIKE AND TAX
REFORM THE CONSTANTLY AS IF
THEY'RE GANG MEMBERS AND IT
MAKES ME UNCOMFORTABLE. THE
JURY CAME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE. AND
MYSELF A HARD WORKING MAN THE
ONLY TO HISPANIC MALE SITTING
IN THE AUDIENCE WERE THERE TO
HARPER THIS YEAR WENT ON TO
SAY. AND I QUOTE I HAVE WILL BE
TRIED TO LISTEN TO EVERY SINGLE
THING THE TERM HE'S ABSENT. AND
I HAVE TO SAY CURTAIN HAS BEEN
PULLED BACK ON A DIFFERENT
POPULATION. THIS YEAR THIS JURY
MEMBER REQUESTED THAT THE COURT
REMOVED THE AUDIENCE FROM THE
COURTROOM EXPRESSING CONCERNS
OF. WALKING ALONE AFTER LEAVING
THE COURTHOUSE AND THE OFFERING
PERSONAL INFORMATION SUCH AS ON
NAMES AND WORKPLACE DURING JURY
SELECTION. REPORT DID NOT
ADDRESS MANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM
THE OBVIOUS RACIAL BIAS BEHIND.
THE JUROR'S CONCERNS THE FACT
THANK. USED THE PROSECUTORS
OFFICERS IN COURT. THE JURY
THAT YOU'RE THAT HISPANIC FROM
PARTS POP. THE BALD HEAD WITH
TO ARE MEMBERS. IT HAPPENED
BEFORE AN DIRECT EVIDENCE BE
WORKING IN THE FIVE. THE JUROR
COULD NOT HAVE UP WITH THE-
ANYMORE CONCLUDE ABOUT YOU WILL
WITHOUT SEEN DIRECT. DID COME
HOW THE OF. TO GIVE YOU GOING
SO OTHERS A CHANCE AFFAIRS.
WITH REGIONAL. BIAS OR MIS READ.
BY MAKING THE RATE OF RACIAL
JUSTICE ACT. RETROACTIVE I WANT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOUR
SINCE YOU'RE CONSIDERING. SO
WHAT. THANK YOU. ANOTHER
WITNESS YES- THERE'S ONE MORE
MIKEL MIKEL VICTIM. HE SAID I
SEE THREE BUT YOU'RE THIRTY ONE
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OKAY
ME GO MAKE THEM. YES I AM
ONLINE. IF YOU CAN BE SECRETIVE
TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LISTED THE MERGER AND I WILL BE
READING A STATEMENT ON BEHALF
OF MY SON WHO IS SERVING TO
TWENTY FIVE YEAR SENTENCES FOR
A CRIME COMMITTED WHEN HE WAS
JUST THE BOAT. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL THE MERGER AND I AM A
HUMAN BEING AND JUST LIKE ANY
HUMAN BEINGS OF THIS WORLD. I
HAD MADE A POOR CHOICE WHEN I
WAS FIFTEEN YEARS OLD IN THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND. WHICH I HAVE
BEEN PAYING FOR THE LAST TWENTY
ONE YEARS. IN PRISON. I'M NOT A
MONSTER VOTE EAGLE. AT THE TIME
I THEIR SIXTEEN YEAR OLD KID. I
HAD LIED AND DENIED ANY
INVOLVEMENT IN MY CASE BUT I
HAD PULLED INTO A WORLD OF
RACIAL CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE ALL.
THEY WANTED BOTH THE CONVICTION.
I AM BY NO REYES. BUT THE ZERO
SAN OF MY CASE NOT GIVE ME A
FAIR PRICE. MOTOR JUDY POOL OF
MY PEERS. EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
ALL GOD'S CHILDREN. A LOT OF
PEOPLE FORGET THAT AND LOOK AT
SKIN COLOR. BOTH VICTIMS IN MY
CASES WERE WHITE. IT BREAKS MY
HEART EVEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE THEY WERE MY FRIENDS.
WE DID NOT SEE COLOR BUT IN
COURT. HE TURNED INTO A WHOLE
DIFFERENT WORLD. I AM MIXED
RACE AND HALF BLACK. MY WHOLE
CASE WAS BASED ON LIES AND
RACIALLY MOTIVATED TO GET THE
CONVICTION. IN TRIAL PROSECUTOR
CALLED ME A TERRORIST. I CAN
PROVE EVERYTHING BEING A FACT
BECAUSE IT IS ALL. IN MY
TRANSCRIPTS AND DOCUMENTS. HE%
HIRING TURNING COULD NOT STAND
AGAINST MY THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN MADE. RACISM REALLY EXIST
THAT THE POWERFUL COURT SYSTEM
TO WHICH HAD BARRICADED ITSELF
WITHIN ITSELF FOLLOW NO ONE TO
GO AGAINST THEM. WOOD FLICK
COURTS AND LOW THAT CAN BE
MANIPULATED TO THEIR FACEBOOK
HI MICHAEL THE MERCHANT CAN
HONESTLY SAY I DID NOT GET A
FAIR TRIAL AND ALL THE
RAILROADS AND ALL. THREE SHOULD
BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. MY
HEART GOES. OUT ALONG WITH MY
PRAYER TO ALL PEOPLE ALONG WITH
THE FAMILIES THAT HAVE FALLEN
TO BEING A VICTIM OF A CRIME.
BUT THERE'S LOCAL PEOPLE THAT
MADE SOME WRONG CHOICES WHEN
THEY WERE YOUNGER AND HAVE
FALLEN VICTIM TO SYSTEM
OPERATION DISCRIMINATION. AND
OVERLY HARSH TREATMENT ALONG
WITH SENTENCES. JANE BUT THE
RACIST WAYS AND THINKING OF
NEED TO STOP THOUSAND PRISONERS
REALLY HAVE FALLEN VICTIM TO
RACIAL NFAIR TREATMENT STEP
SEND THEM TO PRISON JUST
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN. I'M NOT SAYING EVERYONE
BUT I PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED
RACISM DURING MY FILE AND FELL
VICTIM TO IT POLICE ARE MADE
CHANGES DR. APPETITE FOR
EXCELLENT. HELLO REFLECT. HELLO
THE TRUTH CAN BE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BUT THERE ANY ONE IN
THE AUDIENCE READY. IN SUPPORT
ANYONE ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING WANTED TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT. AT&T WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE CALLS. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS THE ONE
AND THEN ZERO AND WE HAVE LINE
WONDER GOAL. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SENATE BREMBO ON THE HEALTH OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AT OUR NEXT
LINE IS TWO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH COMMITTEE GOING
BACK AS THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS CO SPONSOR. AND
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN ORDER
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CALL
INS WE ASK GROUPS TO GIVE US
PERMISSION TO READ THEIR NAMES
IN THE RECORD. THAT RIGHT SIR
THAT WOULD BE GREAT COALITION
FOR. THANK YOU. THE COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
INITIATE JUSTICE. ECONOMIC
PROJECT LEGAL AID AT WORK.
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA RACIAL RACIAL
JUSTICE ALLIES OF CINEMA
COUNTY. NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER. PROJECT REBOUND
CONSORTIUM SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE THIRD SHIFT BAY
AREA. NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW FRESNO BARRIOS UNIDOS. HEY
WORD BURNS INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA
INNOCENCE COALITION THE ALAMEDA
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND
PUBLIC DEFENDERS RACIAL JUSTICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THE
NEXT COMING TO COME FROM A LINE
OF TWO TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THE NEXT LINE IS MY
NUMBER SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DENICO RETURN ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
LINE IS TWO THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR CHILD MEMBERS
GREGORY CLAIM ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THEN THE
NEXT LINE IS. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN.
THE NEW YORK CAL WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
OUR NEXT LINE IS LINE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GIVE ME WHITE
WITH ASEAN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT LINE IS TWO THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT LINE OF ONE OF
SEVENTY FOUR PEOPLE HAD.
RECEIVE HER INITIATES OUTFITS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. I'M EXCITED
TO THIRTY FOUR. M. S. ONE WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT LINE IS ONE OF FORTY
SEVEN PEOPLE HAD. NINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YEAH. OKAY MAILER IN
OAKLAND WHERE INCIDENTS ON THE
PLATE THANK YOU THANK YOU WHAT.
THE NEXT LINE OF THE. ONE FORTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS CECILIA CHAVEZ PRO KHALISTAN
FARE- I'M WITH TELECOM VALLEY
AND KOKKO STRUCTURE- I WOULD
LIKE TO DO THE SAME AS MR GLENN
IN ORDER TO BE A FISHING WITH
READING OUT THE LETTERS OF
SUPPORT MAY I READ THAT DITION
OFFLINE ON. DEFINITELY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO ON BEHALF OF
SUPPORTING OUR AB. TWO TWO
FIFTY SIX WE ALSO HAVE THE
YOUNGLINGS FREEDOM CENTER
KELLER SAID THE COMMUNITY IN
SAN DIEGO REAP REUNITING
FAMILIES CROCKER PROCTOR.
COMMUNITY UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE COURAGE IN
OAKLAND. CEMETERY PARTICIPATORY
DEFENSE KERN COUNTY
PARTICIPATORY DEFENSE. WISTERIA
ORANGE COUNTY URBAN PEACE
MOVEMENT IN OAKLAND. PRODUCTS
IN GILROY THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA NEXT GEN
AND ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
THE- CALIFORNIA PARTICIPATORY.
DEFENSE NETWORK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ON THE NEXT
LINE OF THE. ONE FIFTY FIVE.
THE LEASE CONTRACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
H. M. THE NEXT LINE IS. TO
TWENTY. GOOD EVENING- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS A PLAN FOR
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET COSPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND I WILL ALSO BE
WITH READING OFF A LIST OF
SUPPORTERS- WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ACLU DIGNITY AND
POWER NOW AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE. CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
ASSEMBLY RIGHT CALIFORNIA-
LUTHER GLAAD'S BURKE UNITED FOR
ECONOMIC JUSTICE COURAGE
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES UNITED. TO
AND I'LL WALK. THANK YOU ASIA
RIDLEY FOR ACTION COMMUNITY
I'VE FOR AND GOVERNOR AND
EMPOWERING CORPORATE BIG
ISLANDER COMMUNITIES THE YMCA
BERKELEY AND OAKLAND. THE FINAL
GRADE. OKAY OUR STATE HUMAN
RIGHT IN FIFTY YEARS. ARE
JUSTIFIED. NATIONAL FOR LESBIAN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. ASPECT AND WHITE
PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT LINE IS
ONE EIGHTY ONE PEOPLE HAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE THANK THE PORT.
THANK YOU. I WANNA NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD MY NUMBER ONE
NINETY THREE YEAR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT LINE WOULD BE TO
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MARMARIS CALL ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNICATION WORKERS
ASSOCIATION LOCAL NINETY FOUR
FIFTEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY FOUR. YES THIS IS NOW
THE HIGHEST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY WE ARE
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THE LAST LINE FOR SUPPORT
IS TWO THIRTY NINE PEOPLE HAD.
EIGHT EMILY HELLO ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE YELLOW IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THAT WAS THE LAST CALLER. WE DO
HAVE A LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY
TWO THAT YOU UP HERE. I AM.
GOING WITH CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
WHAT THANK YOU. FOR WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY- ANYONE IN THE QUEUE
OF THE SUBJECT. WELL NOW GONNA
GO TO OPPOSITION I HAVE A-
LARRY MORSE THE SECOND CD EIGHT.
ON THE PHONE EIGHTY ANTI
HOPEFULLY. WE'RE GOOD NOW. CAN
YOU HEAR ME I CAN CERTAINLY
HEAR YOU YES DEFINITELY. THANK
YOU SIR LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION LAST
YEAR'S CDA A VIGOROUSLY OPPOSED
THE PASSAGE OF AB. TWO FIVE
FOUR TWO FOUR VERY SOUND.
REASONS YOU MAY NOT BE AWARE OF
THAT OPPOSITION HOW RUTHLESS
BILL DESPITE ITS MASSIVE IMPACT
ON PUBLIC SAFETY NEVER EVEN HAD
A HEARING IN THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. NOW
DESPITE MYRIAD AMBIGUITIES
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS POSED BY
EIGHTY TWO FIVE FOUR TWO WE ARE
PRESENTED WITH AB TWO FIFTY
SIX. WHICH PROPOSES TO MAKE ITS
PROVISIONS RETROACTIVE DESPITE
THE FACT THAT THE PROPONENTS
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDED
RETROACTIVE APPLICATION LAST
YEAR. FOR MANY OF THE SAME
REASONS WE OPPOSED AB TWO FIVE
FOUR TWO WE MUST ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWO FIVE
SIX WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
POLITICALLY UNPOPULAR TO OPPOSE
A BILL THAT HAS GIVEN ITSELF
THE NAME THE RACIAL JUSTICE
ACT. BUT WE BELIEVE THE JUSTICE
IT PURPORTS TO CREATE IS
ILLUSORY AT BEST AND WILL
ULTIMATELY COMPLICATE EFFORTS
TO CREATE A FAIRER AND MORE
EQUITABLE JUSTICE SYSTEM. AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO ENDEAVOR
TO CREATE A BOWL WORK DESIGNED
TO ELIMINATE DISCRIMINATION IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM A
GOLD WHOLEHEARTEDLY EMBRACED BY
CDA. BUT IT DID SO IN A WAY
THAT CREATED A TREMENDOUS RISK
OF DENYING JUSTICE TO VICTIMS
OF EVERY RACE ETHNICITY AND
NATIONAL ORIGIN. LIKE
INSTITUTING A SYSTEM THAT WOULD
REVERSE THE CASE EVEN IF THERE
WAS NO SHOWING THAT THE
DEFENDANT. WAS DEPRIVED OF A
FAIR TRIAL. FOR EXAMPLE. IF
THERE IS A MASH ALONG OFFICER
IN. IN THE CASE. ONLY WAS TO
TAKE THE UNDISPUTED VIDEOTAPED
STATEMENT FROM THE DEFENDANT.
WHICH IS COVERED THAT OFFICER
WAS DISCOVERED TO HARBOR BIASES
AGAINST THE DEFENSE. THE BILL
MANDATES THAT THE DEFENDANT'S
CONVICTION WOULD HAVE TO BE
REVERSED DESPITE THE FACT THAT
FIFTY PEOPLE OBSERVE THE
DEPENDENT SHOOTING AT HIS
VICTIMS THE WITNESS OF BIAS WAS
REVEALED TO THE JURY. THE
WITNESS DID NOT EVEN TESTIFIED
AND ALL THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
MURDERED BELONG TO THE SAME
RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUP AS- AB
TWO FIVE FOUR CREW WHICH AGAIN
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
RETROACTIVE. IS SIMPLY RIDDLED
WITH AMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE
INADEQUATE DEFINITIONS AND
UNANSWERED LEGAL QUESTIONS. THE
BILL WOULD OVERTURN A
CONVICTION IF THE DEFENDANT WAS
CHARGED OR CONVICTED OF A MORE
SERIOUS OFFENSE NOT TO FIND.
THE DEPENDENCE OF OTHER RACES
ETHNICITIES OR NATIONAL ORIGINS
WILL COMMIT SIMILAR OFFENSES.
NOT DEFINED. AND ARE SIMILARLY
SITUATED. NOT DEFINE IN THE-
HOUSTON MORE FREQUENTLY SOUGHT
VAGUELY DEFINED OR OBTAIN
CONVICTIONS FOR MORE SERIOUS
OFFENSES AGAINST PEOPLE WHO
SHARE THE DEFENDANT'S RACE
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN.
THE VAGUE DEFINITION OF MORE
FREQUENTLY SOUGHT OR OBTAINED
OR MORE FREQUENTLY IMPOSED. I
MEAN IF THE TYPICAL DATA
DEMONSTRATES A QUOTE UNQUOTE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
COMPARATIVE GROUP. WHY IS THE
DEFINITION OF SIGNIFICANT.
THERE IS NOT THE 5% 10% FIFTY
PERCENT- WALLY COULD ENTIRELY
UP TO A JUDGE WITHOUT PROVIDING
ANY GUYS EQUALLY TROUBLING THE
BILL DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY
GUIDANCE AND ASSESSING THE
RELEVANT PERIOD FOR COMPARISON
PURPOSES IS IT FIVE YEARS TEN
YEARS TWENTY YEARS AGAIN WE
DON'T KNOW. WHAT QUALIFIES AS A
**** ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL
ORIGIN AGAIN THE LOG THIS BILL
PROVIDES NO GUIDANCE TO
DEPENDENCE CHARGED WITH THE
SAME CRIME CAN BE OF THE SAME
ETHNICITY BUT A DIFFERENT-
DIFFERENT NATIONAL ORIGIN OR
RACE OR BE OF THE SAME REYES
BUT A DIFFERENT ETHNICITY OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN. WHICH IS THE
RELEVANT GROUP FOR COMPARISON.
NONE OF THESE COMP ISSUES HAVE
YET BEEN ADDRESSED BY THE
PUBLIC COURT IN THIS BILL SEEKS
TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
RETROACTIVE- EVERY DEPENDENT
BELONG TO AT LEAST ONE MORE
RACIAL ETHNIC OR NATIONAL
ORIGIN GROUPS. PRACTICALLY
EVERY SINGLE CONVICTION THAT
HAS EVER OCCURRED IN CALIFORNIA
CAN NOW BE RE OPENED AND
POTENTIALLY REVERSED DESPITE
INDEPENDENT NOT HAVING BEEN
DENIED A FAIR TRIAL BY ANY
REALISTIC STAND. THE COST
ESTIMATE OF THIS LAW IS
INCALCULABLE AND THERE IS NO
PROVISION FOR ANY REIMBURSEMENT
TO THE COUNTIES FOR THE COSTS
THEY WILL INCUR IN COMPLYING
WITH THESE PROVISIONS. THERE
WILL BE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PEELS THE WAY EVIDENTIARY
HEARINGS AND TRIAL DELAYS BUT
THE REAL COST WILL BE IN
COMPLYING WITH THE DISCOVERY
DEMANDS THAT THE BILL WILL
CLOSE. BASED ON A RELATIVELY
LOW THRESHOLD SHOWING AB TWO
FIFTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE POLLING
REVIEWING AND REDACTING FILES
POTENTIALLY GOING BACK DECADES
SINCE THE BILL SETS OUT NO TIME
FRAMES OR LIMITS ON THE
RELEVANT COMPARISON GROUPS.
UNDER AB TWO FIFTY SIX
DEFENDANTS WILL BE ABLE TO
COMPEL LENGTHY AND COSTLY
EVIDENTIARY HEARING INVOLVING
THE TESTIMONY OF ATTORNEYS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS JUROR
EXPERTS OR OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. BASED
ON THE DEFENDANT SHOWING A MERE
POSSIBILITY. THAT A VIOLATION
OCCURRED. WE WOULD RESPECT URGE
AUTHORED A TABLE DOES. UNTIL
COLOR COURTS ARE ABLE TO OFFER
SOME GUIDANCE REGRET REGARDING
MANY OF ITS MOST POOREST
PROVISIONS. WE REMAIN MORE THAN
WILLING TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS OF AB
TWO FIFTY SIX TO IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS THE SHARED GOAL OF
ELIMINATING DISCRIMINATION AND
A FAIRER AND MORE EFFECTIVE
MANNER. IN THE MEANTIME WE'RE
STRENUOUSLY OPPOSED TO AB TWO
FIFTY SIX. AND ASK FOR A
NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU MISTER
MOORE. OTHER ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE AUDIENCE. BAYLOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE-
IN THE ROOM. AND. ON THE PHONE.
AT&T ARE ANYWAY IF YOU WOULD
LIKE ADDITION ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q. BY
ONE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WITH ASSOCIATE OUR
POSITION WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
OUR COLLEAGUE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU SIR FOR YOUR COMMENT. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME GREAT
THANK YOU WE'LL BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
ANY QUESTIONS MR QUIRK. FIRST
OF ALL MOVE THE BELL. AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY- BUT THIRD IN READING THE
ANALYSIS THEY HAVE MANY
CONCERNS ABOUT. SOME OF THE
SAME THINGS THAT THE DA BROUGHT
UP IN TERMS OF A DEFINITIONS
AND I JUST WANTED TO GET YOUR
WORD THAT YOU WOULD BE
ADDRESSING ALL OF THOSE ISSUES
AS YOU BRING THIS BILL FORWARD.
YES YES AND- TO THOSE ISSUES
AND BY THE WAY THE START OF A
PHENOMENAL JOB ON THE ANALYSIS-
A NUMBER OF THOSE ITEMS- THAT
REQUIRE CLARITY OF WHAT WERE
DRAWN FROM THIS REALLY
PHENOMENAL SIXTY PAGE BRIEF
DONE BY A RETIRED JUDGE AS
COUSINS THEY WANT HAS HE'S PER
TIME REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
READ IT- AND HE OFFERS SOME
GUIDANCE ON THAT. AS WELL AND
SO- WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ON A
DAILY ON THE LANGUAGE HOWEVER
THAT WHATEVER CLARITY IS DEEMED
NECESSARY. EXCELLENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THIS WAS ABOUT K. I
THINK I SAW HEAR THE CARE.
THANK MISTER KALRA- AS YOU KNOW
I SUPPORTED BILL LAST YEAR AND
I THINK THIS IS REALLY AND- IN
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ACT IN THE
JOB SYSTEM SOMETHING THAT IS.
AS YOU MENTIONED YOUR OPENING
SIGNIFICANTLY LACKING AND THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THE U. S.
JUSTICE SYSTEM PROVIDES FOR AN
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL TO COME
BEFORE THE COURT AND BE HEARD
AGAIN AS A FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE THAT IS. PART OF WHAT
I THINK MAKES OUR SYSTEM SO
ARTFUL IS THAT WE DON'T
INCARCERATE PEOPLE NEVER LOOK
BACK AND- AND SO YOUR EXTENDING
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN.
POTENTIALLY IMPACTED BY BIAS
AND A LACK OF JUSTICE I THINK
IS REALLY WONDERFUL MY CONCERN
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE THE ARE
GOING TO DO WITH THE CLARITY
AND I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING ON
THAT MY CONCERN IS REALLY WITH-
THE FEASIBILITY OF THIS AS MANY
OF US KNOW THE COURTS ARE WERE
OVERBURDENED PRIOR TO COPE ED
AND HAVING A HARD TIME MEETING
JUSTICE BECAUSE OF THAT. VAST
NUMBER OF CASES BEFORE THEM
THAT'S ONLY EXACERBATED WITH
THE COVERED CRISIS BUT I DON'T
EVEN AFTER WE GET THROUGH CO
THAT I THINK WE WILL CONTINUE
TO SEE OVERBURDENED COURTS. AND
TO OPEN THIS UP AND WANTS TO
EVERY SINGLE PERSON
INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA WHO
MAY HAVE EXPERIENCED BIAS.
COULD POTENTIALLY OVERWHELM THE
COURTS AND I UNDERSTAND THE
STANDARDS ACTUALLY. ACHIEVE THE
END RESULT IS HIGH BUT YOU MAY
HAVE THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WERE INCARCERATED THE FILE
PETITIONS. WHICH THEN THEY
DESERVE TO BE ANALYZED AND
THOUGHTFULLY REVIEWED AND GIVEN
THEIR MOMENT IN COURT. AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW THE COURT SYSTEM
WOULD DO THAT IF WE WERE TO
JUST OPEN THIS TO EVERY PERSON
RETROACTIVELY AND I'M
WONDERING. IF YOU'VE WORKED
WITH JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT
ISSUE OR WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE. YEAH YOU KNOW THIS IS
CERTAINLY A QUESTION OF THAT.
WILL A PROPERLY BABY BOTTOM
SURE IT- FISCAL COMMITTEE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOU. RAISING THE
ISSUE NOW OF CERTAINLY OPEN TO
DISCUSSIONS. ON HOW WE MIGHT
PHASE IN. THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
RETROACTIVITY SO AS NOT TO
OVERBURDEN OUR COURT SYSTEM ONE
THAT SPENT ELEVEN YEARS THE
COURSE ON VERY SENSITIVE
ESPECIALLY. TO THE RESOURCES
THE DA'S PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND
THE- COURT SYSTEM AS A WHOLE
THE JUDGES HAVE. THIS ISSUE HAS
BEEN RAISED BY JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AS AS A POSSIBLE OFF POSSIBLE
OPTION TO CONSIDER. AND SO WE
NEED TO FIGURE IT'S BECAUSE YOU
CAN IMAGINE SORT OF MAYBE SOME
OF CONCORD TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT
WOULD BE INEFFECTIVE PHASE AND-
SET UP. BUT PRIVATE PRIORITY NO
COULD BE GIVEN. TO THOSE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED SO THE
STATECAN REALIZE POTENTIAL
CORRECTIONAL SAVINGS AS WELL.
BECAUSE THAT IS ONE OF. THE
COMPONENTS OF. IT IN A LONG
TERM OF THIS TYPE THE JUST IS
THAT OF. WOULD SAVE MONEY BUT
WE UNDER. IT'S NOT LIKE THERE'S
MANY DIFFERENT BUCKETS SO THE
COURT SYSTEM HAVING TO HEAR
CASES. IS A REAL. ISSUE THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY SHORT ANSWER IS
ABSOLUTELY- IT IS AN ISSUE THAT
THE THEY WERE ALSO TALKING
USUALLY COUNCIL ABOUT. IN TERMS
OF HOW WE SET UP THAT. SYSTEM
SO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ANSWER AND YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS
ON THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY BUT WE'LL WITH HOLD MY
RIGHT TO CHANGE MY VOTE ON THE
FLOOR IF IT HAS AN ADDRESS AT
THAT TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
THE SUPPORT- AND JUST A COUPLE
COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO BE HER
FOR THE OPPOSITION YOU KNOW
JUST VERY SPECIFICALLY ON THE
ISSUE OF HARBORING BIAS IN
OFFICE ARE REVISED IN SPECIFIC
CASES THE VICE S. B. EXISTS
EXHIBIT TOWARDS THE DEFENDANT
CAN BE SOME RANDOM ACT THAT'S
NOT RELATED TO THE DEFENDANT
BUT PUTTING THAT ASIDE- THE
PROSECUTOR THE DA'S. PUTTING
OUT HOW DO YOU DETERMINE THIS
HOW DO YOU DETERMINE THAT WELL
THE END OF THE DAY THERE'S A
LOT. OF DIFFERENT STANDARDS OF
PROOF. STANDARDS EVIDENCE WE
DEAL WITH EVERY DAY IN THE
COURT SYSTEM THERE WAS A POINT
IN TIME. THAT THOSE DEFINITIONS
HOW TO BE MORE FINE TUNED AND
MORE AND BETTER DEFINED AND
THEY CHANGE OVER TIME. BASED
UPON- CASES ACTUALLY RUNNING
THROUGH THE SYSTEM THE REALITY
IS THAT. WHEN IT COMES THE
RACIAL JUSTICE ACT. THAT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S IT MAY
BELIEVE. THAT OF ALL TO HOLD
OFF A RETROACTIVE YOU WILL KNOW
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT. WE
NEED TO HAVE THE STANDARDS- OF
NOT ONLY IN PLACE TO ROOT OUT
RACISM. A PARTICULARLY SYSTEMIC
RACISM AND BIAS MY SYSTEM. BUT
WE NEED TO GET THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE RE FULLY HEARD IN
COURT. ULTIMATELY THERE WILL BE
CASES WILL BE HEARD BY JUDGES
AND DOES THEIR JOB THE
APPELLATE COURTS. AND THE
SUPREME COURT TO BETTER DEFINE
AND GIVE MORE STRUCTURE- AND
THE DA'S KNOW THAT- THAT THAT'S
HOW. LANDMARK LEGISLATION.
LANDMARK. POLICY LANDMARK
DECISIONS. ARE SO. DEALT WITH
BY FORWARD THE BOTTOM IS WHAT
EVEN MORE PUT UP. THE OPPOSING
OF CALLED RACIAL JUSTICE ACT.
IS STANDING BY THE STATUS QUO
THE LEASE TO A BLACK PERSON BE
INCARCERATED EIGHT TIMES. THE
RATE OF A WHITE PERSON OR A
BLACK MAN BEING CONVICTED OF A
FELONY. OF BEING 42% MORE
LIKELY BE SENTENCED TO PRISON
THAN A LIGHT NEGATIVE DONNIE
THAT'S THEIR SYSTEM THAT
THEY'RE STANDING BY. RIGHT NOW
THAT'S THE STATUS QUO AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY OPPOSED TO
LAST YEAR THE LAST YEAR THEY
POSE THEY SAID WE ALREADY HAVE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE. WELL CLEARLY THEY'RE NOT
WORKING AND SO I JUST ASK THAT
WE CAN EXTEND THIS- I TO ALL
THAT HAVE BEEN IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT. SOME OF
OUR CAN INDICATED THAT WE HAVE
HAD SOME POP HONEST AS TO HOW
WE ACTUALLY CAN CAN HAVE THESE
CASES HEARD IN A WAY THAT'S
ORDERLY THAT MAKES SENSE- AND-
THE- THE FACT THAT- WE'RE EVEN
HERE IS A TESTAMENT TO THIS
LEGISLATURE SUPPORTING. THE
RACIAL JUSTICE ACT LAST YEAR
I'M GRATEFUL REPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS AND
FOR THE COMMENTS AND- TO THE
WITNESSES THEY SHARE THEIR
STORIES OVER A HUNDRED ORGAN
NEARLY HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
SOME OF THEIR SUPPORT. AND
THANK YOU THE EIGHTY TWO FIFTY
SIX SPONSORS AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION AMERICAN
FRIENDS SERVICE COMMITTEE ALL
BIGGEST OF YOU IN RIGHTS. HAVE
A KILL POLICY PERMANENT
PRISONERS CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR RESPONSIBLE JEKYLL THIS FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS.
INITIATE JUSTICE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS CALIFORNIA NEXT
GEN AND SILICON VALLEY DE BUG
WITH THAT MR CHAREST UP
YESTERDAY I BOTH. ON AB TWO
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU AND I TO
COME INTO. ONE OF. LAST YEAR A
CALLBACK FOR- OF I'M I WAS THAT
CAN HELP UP EVERYTHING ON SIDE.
AND I'VE BEEN FULL DISCLOSURE.
AND BASICALLY BECAUSE OUR SURE
IF. MISTER KALRA COULD BE TO
FOR. DID YOU SHOULD. WASN'T
REALLY HELPFUL IN SAYING THAT
THEY WOULD. THEY WOULD ACTUALLY
WORK WITH THE JUDGES. AND THE-
PJ'S AND- AND CHIEF JUSTICE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED IT WAS A REAL
CONCERN OF MINE WHICH I
EXPRESS. TO MISTER KALRA. AND
WE DIDN'T HEAR TO BUILT ON THE
SIDE. TO HIS CREDIT HE KEPT
WORKING AND WORKING IT IN. THE
WATER AT. TO WHERE- I SAID LOOK
IF YOU IF WHAT WE COMMONLY CALL
OVER HERE THE JAILBREAK IT.
ALLOWED HIM TO TRY TO TAKE IT
ONTO THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
SENATE SIDE SINCE THEN BECAUSE
IT WASN'T THEY DIDN'T GIVE
THROUGH SINCE THEN HE'S PUT IN
A LOT OF WORK. HE'S BEEN A LOT
OF WORK TALKING TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WHICH MAKES IT NOT ONLY
A BETTER BILL BUT- MOST
IMPORTANT- IT GIVES ME- SOME
CONFIDENCE THAT SOME KIND OF
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WILL COME
OUT OF THIS. AND AS FAR AS
FUNDING- WE WERE LUCKY RIGHT
NOW WILL FLUSH. AND SO WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET MONIES
TOWARD THIS SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
THIS HAPPEN. AND THE REASON WHY
MAY NOT BE ENTIRELY THIS IS A
GOOD REASON- RACIAL INJUSTICE
AFRICAN AMERICANS. BUDGET IS
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
BILLS FOR D. ACE. THERE'S A I
JUST SAW A RETIRED. ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER- CALLED AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN. KID THE N.
WORD. NOW THEY'RE LOOKING AT
ALL THREE HUNDRED CASES THAT HE
WAS INVOLVED IN. AND THEY MAY
ALL BE OVERTURNED BECAUSE OF
THIS I THINK EVERY D. A. N.
CALIFORNIA IF NOT THE COUNTRY
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE KNOWN. IF
THIS INDIVIDUAL HAD MADE RACIST
COMMENTS- IF YOU LOK AT OJ
MARC. BERMAN I DON'T THINK THEY
WOULD PUT HIM ON THE STAND IF
THEY KNEW. HE HAD MADE SOME
RACIAL SLURS AND WAS RECORDED
SO. I THINK FOR THE D. A.'S.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THEIR CASES STICK.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BUILT FOR
THEM TO. NOT JUST FOR- AFTER
AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE TREATED
UNJUSTLY THIS WILL HELP MAKE
SURE THAT NONE OF THEIR CASES
BE OVERTURNED AND HOW MUCH HOW
MUCH TIME AND RESOURCES WOULD
IT IS GOING TO TAKE FOR THEM TO
DEFEND IT AGAIN. IT IN COURT AS
THESE PRISONERS COME OUT. AND
START TO BOB GOOD APPELLATE
COURT ANYWAY. THE WHAT I JUST
SAID THIS ONE OFFICER. POSSIBLY
THREE HUNDRED CASES SO IT IS IN
EVERYONE'S INTEREST ON BOTH THE
DA SITE AND FROM A JUST SOCIETY
AND- IT IS DONE. I REQUEST FOR
THE PAST FOUR NINE VOTE I DON'T
BELIEVE IT YOU MIGHT THINK. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS WE WERE
JUST. OF WHICH DRIVING THROUGH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON EIGHTY TWO FIFTY SIX AT
THE BILL'S IMPROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED BY SOME MEMBER KALRA
THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER GENSER IRAQI LACKEY NO
BARRICADE CAN STARKEY HAD AYE
CORK. AYE CORK AYE SANTIAGO
CIERTA SINGER TONO WICKS LEE.
WE IT'S ALL THANK. SO WE
NORMALLY GO FOR THE FOR THE
FRESHMAN MEMBERS HERE- MEMBERS
THEY HAVE BILLS LIKE MR LACKEY-
WICKS- ARE THE GENERALLY GO
LAST- SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO MR
MCCARTY. HIPPIES HERE NOT HERE
PATTERSON. STONE STONE. WICKS.
AND IF THEY'RE NOT THERE WILL
DO MR LACKEY. WE GOTTA KEEP UP
WITH WHAT OUR PROTOCOL. IF I'M
NOTHING ELSE AT LEAST I'M
OBSERVANT I NOTICED SOME OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE HERE. SO ALL
RIGHTS ARE DOING NOW AB
EIGHTEEN RIGHT. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU ALL FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT THIS PARTICULAR BILL-
IT WOULD PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
FACILITATE THE TESTING OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT FORENSIC
EVIDENCE KITS. COLLECTED PRIOR
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN. THIS ITEM
SHOULD LOOK A LITTLE FAMILIAR
TO MOST OF YOU. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. THE VEHICLE- FOR
THIS GOAL LAST YEAR WAS TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY ONE AND A PASSED
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE REBUILDING TWENTY
TWENTY THAT THERE ARE AT LEAST
THIRTEEN THOUSAND. NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE UNTESTED RAPE KITS
IN THE POSSESSION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CRIME
LABORATORIES THIS NUMBER. IS
COMPRISED OF HORRIFIC STORIES
FROM EACH OF OUR DISTRICTS. DNA
EVIDENCE COULD BE PIVOTAL WHEN
THE ASSAILANT IS UNKNOWN TO THE
VICTIM. FURTHER CAN CONSOLIDATE
CRIMES AND CATCH REPEAT
OFFENDERS. I COULD GO ON AND ON
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S
NECESSARY AT THIS POINT I DO
HAVE NAY NESTLE ARNOLD BEST
WOMAN THE PRESIDENT CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED. I THINK
HOPEFULLY ON THE LINE. I'M
STILL HERE. ALL RIGHT YOU MAY
BEGIN. FIVE MINUTES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN ARAMBULA
MEMBERS CRIME VICTIMS UNITED IS
EXTREMELY- PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND WE APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS DILIGENT AND
ASSISTING VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT THANK JUSTICE- SEXUAL.
STATISTICALLY AN MAY KNOWS
PUBLIC THE UNDER CRIME THERE IS.
HE'S BRAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
COME FORWARD- TO NOT ONLY
REPORTER CRIMES TO TRY TO HAVE
THEM PROSECUTED IT IS A GREAT
SERVICE TO HAVE THEIR CASES
SHELVES FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD- IT'S REALLY TRULY RE
VICTIMIZING THESE BRAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE COMING
FORWARD. TO TALK ABOUT
INTERMENT- VIOLENCE AGAINST
THEM. I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO HAVE THAT TYPE OF JOB
THAT NIGHT- ALTHOUGH SB EIGHT
THIRTEEN AND S. B. TWENTY TWO
PROVIDED SOME FORTIFIED AVENUES
FOR VICTIMS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
TESTING RAPE KITS THE ONES THAT
ARE PRIOR TO TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE
STILL SITTING ON A SHELF
APPROXIMATELY OVER. THINK THAT
JACK NUMBER THIRTEEN THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE KIDS-
THAT THIRTEEN THOUSAND VICTIMS
THAT ARE OUT THERE SEEKING
JUSTICE BUT ALSO WHAT I THINK
IS CRITICAL TO UNDERSTANDING IS
HAVE THESE CORRECTED BEFORE THE.
DNA IS- NO LONGER DO DEAL TO
TEST IT IS QUITE. AS WE ALL
NOTED BE ONE OF THE MOST UNDER
A CRIME. IT IS ALSO A CRIME AND
THAT IS A REPEAT OFFENDERS AND
PACKED AVERAGE RATE THIS THANKS
NINE TIMES BEFORE EVER EVEN
BEING CAUGHT ARCHITECT INCOMING
FOR. SO IT'S TWO FOLD AFFECTED
BY NOT HAVING- SEATS GET. KIDS
TOUGHEST THAT IS THE VICTIMS
ARE IN A WAITING PATTERN AND
TRYING TO SEEK JUSTICE AND
BEING RE VICTIMIZED BUT WE ALSO
HAVE SOME WHAT I WOULD BELIEVE
THE WORST OFFENDERS OUT UP ON
OUR STREETS. GENERALLY THESE
PEOPLE PREY ON THE MOST
VULNERABLE WHETHER THEIR
CHILDREN OR WOMEN OR MEN THEY
TEND TO BE THE MORE VULNERABLE
VICTIM POPULATION AND THEY'RE
OUT THERE STILLPREYING ON
BECAUSE THEY HAVE ON LARGELY
UNDETECTED. THEREFORE I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AND ASKED
THAT THIS- COMMITTEE DO AN AYE
VOTE SO THAT WE CAN BRING NOT
ONLY JUSTICE TO VICTIMS BUT
THAT WE CAN ALSO. TAKE FROM-
EXTREMELY VIOLENT PERPETRATORS
OFFERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
ARE ANY WOULD HERE IN THE- AND
WITNESSES. OUR INDIVIDUAL
CONFERENCE ROOM AT&T DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE ON THE
LINE ON THE PHONE. WE DO HAVE
FROM LINE A ONE OR THREE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT YOU SURE
MEMBERS ALEX TOWARDS A STRATEGY
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF WE TO
HELP IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SUPPORT WE HAVE
THE LINE NUMBER TWO FORTY NINE.
LARRY MORSE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER MOORE.
AND LINE NUMBER. ONE NINETY
SEVEN. REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THEN ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT IT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AND WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE FORTY SEVEN. THIS
CHAIRMAN I NUMBER ONE FORTY
DOLLARS. VERY A LARGE CHUNK THE
THANK YOU. FOR WE DO NOT HAS
ANYMORE IN THE QUEUE RESEARCH
THEIR- OKAY PERSIMMON TALKING
OVER SOMEONE TO IF WE DIDN'T
MISS ANYONE- NOW IT IS SURE YES.
RIGHT SURE WHAT THE RESEARCHERS
LOCATION IN SANTA ANA POLICE
OFFICERS PROFICIENT YEAH ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. IS THAT IT AT&T.
FOR SUPPORT THAT IS THAT THERE
ARE NO OTHER AND SUPPORT ON THE
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY I BELIEVE WE
HAVE MARGO GEORGE C. PDA. ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- I'M MARCO GEORGIAN I'M
HERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION I AM A
RETIRED ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER AFTER THIRTY PLUS
YEARS OF BEING A PUBLIC
DEFENDER WE ARE OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN BECAUSE THAT
MICROMANAGES THE LIMITED
RESOURCES OF. CHANCE TO THE
DETRIMENT OF CURRENT
PROSECUTIONS AND AN AFFRONT
INDIVIDUALS. AWAITING TRIAL AND
THOSE WHO WOULD BE EXONERATED
ONCE THE DNA AND THEIR CASE IS
OUR COMPLETE. THIS BILL
REQUIRES SAID OLD SEXUAL
ASSAULT KITS TO BE ANALYZED IN
THE DNA TESTED REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER IT'S NECESSARY TO
PROSECUTE THE CASE. THE
DEFENDANT HAS ALREADY PLED
GUILTY. OR ANY OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCE SO THAT THE DNA
CAN BE ADDED INTO A STATE AND
NATIONAL DATABASE. LAB TESTING
IS NOT AN UNLIMITED RESOURCE
JUST LIKE DOCTORS AND NURSES IN
THE HOSPITAL WITH THEIR ONLY SO
MANY BANDS PROSECUTORS AND
CRIME LABS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TRY IT TRIAGE THEIR WORK AND BE
NIMBLE TO RESPOND TO CURRENT
CRISES. THE LIMITED. RESOURCE
IS A CRIME LABS ARE NOT
HYPOTHETICAL SITUATIONS. LAST
YEAR TRYING TO PUT A HUMAN FACE
ON THE INNOCENT- INDIVIDUALS I
TALKED ABOUT A FORMER CLIENT
TONY WHO WAS CHARGED WITH AN
ARMED ROBBERY AT A CONVENIENCE
STORE. BUT IMAGINE THAT IT'S
YOUR INNOCENT FAMILY MEMBER THE
STORE VIDEO DEPICTED THE ROBBER
WHO LOOKS LIKE YOUR FAMILY
MEMBER DROPPING ITS BASEBALL
CAP AS HE FLED THE STORE. YOUR
BROTHER SAID THAT HE DIDN'T DO
THE ROBBERY. SO YOU DEMANDED
THAT THE DEFENSE ASKED THE
PROSECUTION TO TEST THE CAP FOR
DNA. THE CRIME LAB WAS SO
BACKED UP WITH THE DNA REQUESTS
THAT IT TOOK MONTHS FINALLY
YOUR BROTHER WAS EXONERATED
AFTER SPENDING EIGHT MONTHS IN
JAIL FOR A CRIME HE DIDN'T
COMMIT. THAT TIME IN JAIL HAD
COST THE LOFT IS JOHN AND HIS
APARTMENT. ALL THE DNA TESTING
HAS GOTTEN FASTER AND COSTS
LESS NOW IT STILL REQUIRES
EXPENSIVE EQUIPMENT AND TRAINED
CRIMINALIST. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR NO VOTE ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
HI THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE AUDIENCE. ANY WITNESSES ON
VIDEO CONFERENCING AND OUR
GREAT AT T. R. W. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN IF. ZERO AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP MISTER
SHARE. OKAY THANK YOU. BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER K. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I AM RATHER
SPEECHLESS BUT I WILL TRY THAT
SO I KNOW HAVING SAT ON THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE AUTHOR FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW THAT HE AND I
SHARE THE GOAL OF HAVING ALL
CRIMES- SOLVED AND THAT
EVERYBODY IN A SHOULD BE TESTED
BUT THE FACTS THAT. PEOPLE WHO
ARE VIOLATED IN THIS WAY THAT
THEN GO THROUGH THE HIM YOU
HUMILIATION. AND DISCOMFORT AND
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT WORDS TO
USE TO DESCRIBE WHAT HAPPENS.
WHEN SOMEONE GOES THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF HAVING A RAPE KIT
COLLECTED OFF OF HIS OR HER
BODY. TO THEN SAY THAT THOSE
TESTS SHOULD NOT BE TESTED.
BECAUSE WELL THERE'S OTHER
THINGS THAT SHOULD BE TESTED IS.
SHOCKING TO ME IT SHOULD ALL BE
TESTED AND I AM I WOULD LIKE TO
JOIN A CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL I
AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IS
PRIORITIZING A BILL BEING
CARRIED BY MISS DOLLY WHICH
WILL ENSURE THAT WE FULLY
FUNDS. THE RAPE TEST PROCESS SO
THAT THERE ARE DOCTORS
AVAILABLE TO DO THIS FOR WOMEN
THAT NEED IT BECAUSE THERE ARE
MANY AREAS IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
YOU CAN'T GET THIS DONE IN A
QUICK FASHION WOMEN SIT IN
THEIR CLOTHING THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN RAPED IN FOR DAYS. BEFORE
THEY GET THIS. PROCESS DONE AND
SO IT IS INCUMBENT UPON EACH
AND EVERYONE OF US TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE VICTIMS ARE
SUPPORTED. THAT THEIR TESTS ARE
RUN AND THAT THEY GET THE
JUSTICE THEY DESERVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CLARK. YOU KNOW
JUST BECAUSE A D. A. DECIDED
THAT. THERE WAS ENOUGH EVIDENCE
THEY DIDN'T NEED TO PASS THAT
TO LOOK AT THE DNA IS NOT A
GOOD REASON FOR ME EVEN IF
PRISON PERSON PLEADS GUILTY.
SOME PEOPLE FEEL ALL THE
EVIDENCE IS SO MUCH AGAINST ME
I'LL JUST BE GUILTY BECAUSE
BOB. I MEAN THAT HAPPENS AND SO
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
TEST EVERY SINGLE. ONE AND I
THINK I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE
AGAINST IT. NOW THEY DO HAVE A
CONCERN. I FRANKLY CAN'T. LOOK
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SET THEIR OWN
PRIORITIES AND I DON'T THINK
THAT THEY WILL NEGLECT THE
CURRENT CASE BECAUSE OF THE S.
AND FRANKLY THEY NEGLECTED THE
OTHER LOVE WHERE WE TELL THEM
THEY HAD TO REPORT ON ALL THE
CASES THAT THEY HAVE AT ALL OF
THE KIDS THAT THEY HADN'T DONE
THEY'LL DO THEIR OWN THING
THERE'S NOTHING HERE THAT SAYS
THEY HAVE TO GO TO JAIL THE
SOMETHING WASN'T TESTED BY THE
DEADLINE IN THE BILL. SO I
THINK IT IS DISINGENUOUS TO
MAKE THAT ARGUMENT AND I HOPE
THE- THE- PUBLIC DEFENDERS WILL
REVERSE YOUR POSITION ON THIS
SCALE I ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THE MONEY
TO THE LOCAL AGENCIES SO THEY
CAN DO THIS THIS IS A YEAR
COULD ALLOCATE WHATEVER
MILLIONS. OF DOLLARS IT TAKES
TO DO IT. AND YOU'VE ALREADY
DONE TWO MILLION TWO MILLION
TIMES ON THE HEAD. THAT'S
WHAT'S KNOWN IN THIS STATE AS A
BUDGET DOES- IS IT GOING TO BE
GET. MISTER CHAIR WOULD LIKELY
TO GET THAT MONEY IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR. I HEAR IT ON BUDGET
SO FIVE OKAY SO THIS MR LACKEY.
PERFECT WELL WE'LL MAKE SURE IT
GETS IN THERE AND IT'S NOT THAT
MUCH MONEY SO AGAIN PUBLIC
DEFENDER WILL PLEASE REVERSE
YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU THE
NEW YORK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE MISLED. THE
WITNESSES MUTUM CELLS BECAUSE
WE GET A LOT OF FEEDBACK. THIS
BILL. IS THAT. WHEN I CAN'T
RELATE- AND I HEARD OF WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S. WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT INNOCENCE. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. FOURTEEN THOUSAND.
INNOCENT PEOPLE. THE RUN
THROUGH. TORTURE AN EXPERIENCE
THAT'S ON DESCRIBABLE. I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MR
LACKEY IN NOT THAT I THINK
YOU'VE ALL SAID ENOUGH THEM NOT
ONLY WILL I SUPPORT BILL YOU
AND I NEED GOT SOME WORK TO DO
TO MAKE SURE WE GET THAT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO GET OUT. TO
THE LOCALS SO JEFF RECOMMEND IN
OUR- ON AB EIGHTEEN BEST A
MEMBER RCKY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY I
PARA QUE HAN THERAPY HAD HIGH
COURT. I WORK AT A SAN DIEGO.
CA R. TWO C. R. TWO I WICKS. LI
LI I. THE MEASURE PASSED. YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD DO A. B. THREE
NINE FIVE A LOT OF ROOM FOR
ENTRY OF A VEHICLE. THAT WILL
MAKE YOU HERE MAKE THIS QUICK.
I WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
ALL MEN THE BILL. AS OUTLINED
BY THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER. THE STATE TO FORCIBLY
ENTERING A VEHICLE WITH THE
INTENT TO COMMIT THEFT OR ANY
OTHER FELONY IS GUILTY OF AN
UNLAWFUL ENTRY OF A VEHICLE
THIS LANGUAGE. WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE PENAL CODE
SECTION FOUR FIVE NINE WHICH
OUTLINES CALIFORNIA BURGLARY
STATUTE. EVEN THOUGH WE JUST
GOT THIS LETTER LIKE A WEEK AGO.
SO WE ACCEPT THAT THAT
AMENDMENT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
I HAVE. ANYBODY ELSE-
LIEUTENANT BRANDON YEP LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. YEAH MEMBERS
HEARING THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECOND I'LL KEEP THAT EVEN
SHORTER- THE L. A. COUNTY FAIR
BILL AND WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT IN THE
AUDIENCE C. N. NONE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE- COUGH. VIDEO
CONFERENCE SEEN NONE- AT&T ARE
THERE ANY. AND SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. SORRY IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE CALL HAD. SURE MEMBERS
JONATHON FELDMAN AGAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK. AND WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS CHAIR RYAN SHERMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION SANTA ANA POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WITHIN THE MAILING
OF THE MONEY CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND WE DO HAVE A LINE OF
GETTING AT THEIR LINE NUMBER
ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LARRY MORSE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I HAVE-
MARGO GEORGE AND C. P. B. A. N.
KATHY BRADY IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER. FIVE MINUTES
LATER YES. WELL I'M NOT SURE
IF- KATHY IS GOING TO WITHDRAW
OUR OPPOSITION THAT- THIS IS
MARGO GEORGE AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AGAIN- THE
AMENDMENT WILL NOT SATISFY OUR
CONCERNS. AND THAT'S BECAUSE AB
THREE NINETY FIVE- CREATES A
NEW CRIME WHICH IT TURNS
BASICALLY AIN'T MALICIOUS
MISCHIEF FOR VANDALISM- BY ONE
OF THOUSANDS OF HOMELESS PEOPLE
LOOKING FOR SHELTER IN OUR
URBAN AREAS INTO A FELONY.AB
THREE NINETY FIVE IS
DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING LAW
AUTO BURGLARY BURGLARY IS
ALREADY A LAW CLERK WITH THE
EXACT SAME PENALTIES. COURTS
HAVE ACCEPTED BROKEN WINDOWS IS
EVIDENCE OF FORCIBLE ENTRY AND
THAT'S CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE
THAT THE B. ICAL LET'S LOCKED
FOR DECADES- PROPHETICALLY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. AND
PEOPLE BEING MALCOLM THE COURT
FOUND THAT A LOT CAR WITH AN
UNLOCKED FRONT WING WINDOW.
SATISFIED THE STATUTE WHERE
THERE WERE SIGNS OF FORCED
ENTRY AND THEN AGAIN THE SOME
THIRTY YEARS LATER AND PEOPLE
BE. RIVIERA THE COURT FOUND
THAT THERE WAS JUST CANCEL
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT
THE CAR'S DOORS WERE LOCKED
SOLELY BASED ON THE CAR.
WINDOWS BEING BROKEN. SO I KNOW
ON THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
NOT MENTION THIS THIS YEAR AND
I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS ONE OF
HIS CONCERNS. IN THE PAST THE
AUTHOR HAD SAID THAT THIS WAS-
AN ISSUE. BECAUSEIN URBAN
AREAS LIKE SAN FRANCISCO AND
LOS ANGELES TOURISTS AND
RESIDENTS. I HAD TO SHOW UP IN
COURT TO TESTIFY- IF THE CASE
WE'RE GOING TO TRIAL BUT EVEN
IF YOU AMEND IT TO MAKE A NEW-
ON A NEW FOR. LOBULAR
DESCRIPTIVE THEY WILL STILL
HAVE TO RETURN TO TESTIFY-
CRIMINAL SOLUTIONS ARE
PENALTIES NOT THE SOLUTION TO
EVERY PROBLEM NOT EVERY
INCIDENT OF IMPROPER BEHAVIOR
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BY A NEW
LEGAL PROHIBITION AND INCREASED
PUNISHMENT. ALTHOUGH THERE MAY
BE A PROBLEM OF INCREASE
VEHICLE THEFT IN OUR URBAN
AREAS IT IS NOT A PROBLEM
NEEDED TO BE SOLVED BY STATE
LAW WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE ON AB THREE NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
YOURS AND KATHY BRADY.
AVAILABLE HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME WELL YES-
I'M CATHY BRADY. I'M CAPPY
BRADY AND I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER AND I'VE WORKED
FOR THIRTY YEARS SWELLED DOC
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND JUDGES TO TRY TO
WORK OUT- THE SPECIAL PENALTIES
THAT COME DOWN ON IMMIGRANTS
FROM EVEN MINOR CALIFORNIA
CONVICTIONS. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT TO
THIS LAW THAT WILL- CHECK SOME
OF OUR MAJOR CONCERNS ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS. WE STILL WOULD
OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE IT
SEEMS THAT THERE ARE ALREADY
SIXTEEN TO THREE FELONIES AND
WILDFLOWERS SUCH AS VANDALISM
AND THEFT. THAT COVER THIS
PARTICULAR OFFENSE. AND AT THIS
MOMENT IT DOES NOT SEEM TO BE A
GOOD TIME TO BE CREATING MORE
CRIMES AS WE TRY TO
DECRIMINALIZE BUT I DO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING
THE IMMIGRATION AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE AUDIENCE IN
OPPOSITION. ANY IN THE
CONFERENCE TELECONFERENCE ROOM.
AT&T ARE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE BETTER IN OPPOSITION. YOU
HAVE MY NUMBER TWO TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER TWO
TWENTY FOUR- YES SORRY BOUT
MATTY HAYDEN CALIFORNIA'S
YOU'LL READ THAT BECAUSE THE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
ONLY HAVE ONE NUMBER SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD
ARNELLE ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES I HAD OKAY OUR JOB LEVEL
I'M ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT BUT I
WOULD HAVE BEEN EVEN BETTER
BURKE AMONG SUPPORTERS OF
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS OFFICERS
CALIFORNIANS KNOWLEDGE
UNIVERSITY POLICE HE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS- AND THE- OF COALITION
OF PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. ALL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR LEVEL. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN A POSITION
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU AND ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MR QUIRK- TO THE
PROSECUTOR INTO THE CHIEF
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S ARM I HAVE
ALWAYS OPPOSED MAKING OUR
SYSTEM- MORE- PUNISH PEOPLE
MORE I DON'T THINK THAT HELPS
BUT IN THIS CASE WHAT WE'RE
REALLY DOING. IS TRYING TO CALL
CRIME A CRIME AND MAKE SURE
IT'S PROSECUTED THAT'S THE
POINT OF THIS FRANKLY- I'M
UPSET WE'VE TRIED TO PASS THIS
BEFORE I'M UPSET IT HAS BEEN
FOUGHT IN APPROPRIATIONS IT
CETERA. THIS IS THIS IS
PROSECUTING THE CRIME THAT'S
ALREADY A CRIME IT IS VERY EASY
TO GET INTO A CAR WITHOUT
BREAKING A WINDOW I AM SURE THE
AUTHOR. WILL CAN GIVE US- MANY
MANY STORIES- OF PEOPLE WHO
DON'T DO THIS WHO DON'T BREAK
WINDOWS AND GET INTO CARS- IT
FURTHER AS I READ THIS. I HAVE
A PERSON WE'RE TRULY COLD AND
HUNGRY AND JUST SAT AND
SOMEBODY'S CAR. IT SAYS WITH
INTENT TO COMMIT A CRIME
THERE'S NO CRIME HERE SO AGAIN.
I WOULD JUST ASK THE- A PUBLIC
DEFENDERS TO RETHINK THEIR
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR ANYBODY ANYMORE QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU MAY
CLOSE MR LACKEY. WELL I'D LIKE
TO CLOSE BY THANKING OF. MY
FELLOW COLLEAGUES TO COURT. I
DON'T KNOW FOR SUPPOSED TO USE
THEIR NAMES UT AS- IT IS IT'S
NOT MY APOLOGIES IF I BROKE
SOME RULES. BUT THIS SEEMS
PRETTY PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
FOLKS I MEAN IT'S A IT'S ONE
THAT I HOPE I CAN EARN YOUR
SUPPORT AND I'M THANKFUL FOR
THE CO AUTHORSHIP OF MISS OF RK
AND I WOULD ASK THAT- YOU VOTE
AYE THANK YOU THANK YOU AND FOR
CLARITY YOU YOU WILL BE TAKING
SOME AMENDMENTS LATER FROM
UNDERSTANDING. NOT IN THIS
COMMITTEE. WHAT'S THAT YOU PLAN
AMENDED BILL AFTER JUST
COMMITTEE YEAH THAT'S TO THIS
CAME TOO LATE WE ARE DONE
BEFORE JUST JUST WANNA CLARIFY
ABSOLUTELY EXACTLY EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE STILL OPPOSING. THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH MY
COMMITTEE THE TO MAKE SURE IT
DOES COMMITTEES TO MAKE SURE IT
GOT TO WHERE WE CAN GET IT DONE
SO I CAN ACTUALLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ON AB THREE NINETY
FIVE ISOMER LACKEY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
LACKEY I POWER KEY HAND BAKKIE
HAD. A CORK BY CORK AYE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HIESINGER
TO. THE R. TWO I WICKS LEE. WE
NOW. THE MEASURE PASSES THANK
YOU. OUR MR MCCARTY AB. FIVE
FOUR FIVE NINE FOUR MCCARTY LAW
ENFORCEMENT POLICIES NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN. THANK YOU
A MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- THIS IS
A FOLLOW UP FROM LAST YEAR'S
BILL NO VIEW OF YOU HERE WERE
HERE LAST YEAR. I RELATE TO
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS AND
GIVING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THE- ROLE TO INVESTIGATE-
INCIDENTS WITH AN UNARMED
CIVILIAN THIS WILL THIS ELEMENT
WAS IN LAST YEAR'S BILL IT WAS
A BIT COMPLICATED SO SOME OF
THE PARTY SAID ONCE YOU COME
BACK NEXT YEAR WITH A FRESH
BILL. ESSENTIALLY THIS CLIP
THIS CHANGES THE LOOP AS FAR AS
THE INVESTIGATION PROCESS WHEN
THERE IS LET ME GIVE YOU TWO
EXAMPLES RIGHT HERE IN WEST
SACRAMENTO ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO
THERE'S A TRAGIC SHOOTING. AT
THAT SENIOR CITIZEN YOU KNOW
LOST IT LAST NIGHT BROUGHT OUT
A GUN WAS POINTING AT PEOPLE
THE WEST SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT DEFENDED THEMSELVES
AND SHOT AND KILLED THE
SUSPECT. WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE SECOND FROM THE WEST
SACRAMENTO POLICE DEPARTMENT
THEY HAVE A PROCESS ALREADY- ON
THE RULES WHERE THE ADJACENT
DEPARTMENT COMES AND BECOMES
THE THAT THE LEAKS OF THE CITY
WEST SACRAMENTO'S PARLAY
INVESTIGATION BUT THE DEAD
JASON CITY IS PART AT LEAST
BECAUSE THERE'S ALWAYS
DISTRUST AS FAR AS POLICE
POLICING THEMSELVES. THIS
PRACTICE IS IN- MOST OF OUR
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT PARTS
OF OUR LARGER JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA CITIES
ARE STEPPING UP BEING AND DOING
THIS THIS WOULD JUST MAKE IT A
LOT OF LAND IN CALIFORNIA THAT
CITIES HAVE TO HAVE- IN
ADJACENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
JURISDICTIONS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION- THEY WOULD NO
LONGER BE THE LEAD- WE HAVE-
OUR LOCAL- DA HERE. IN IN BACK
OF ILL WILL DROP A POINT LAST
YEAR THE SHOOTING WITH THE
MONTERO SENT A FAMILY MEMBER
HERE FROM A LITTLE BIT AFTER
THE SHOOTING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT- OF- OF- BACK AVAIL-
THE SENSUALLY DESTROYED
EVIDENCE AND SELL THE DA SAID
IN THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
HAVING THAT GAINED THE POLICE
POLICE. THEMSELVES OF THIS WILL
CLOSE IS THAT LOOPHOLE AND
BRING MORE- COMMONSENSE IN. TO
INVEST- AGAIN WE ARE WORKING
WITH- LAW ENFORCEMENT THE-
POLICE CHIEFS IN THE DA'S
ASSOCIATIONS ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH US THEY'RE NOT
LISTED AT SUPPORT JUST YET. BUT
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM AND WE
ARE WORKING IN LISTENING TO
OPPOSITION AND THINK THAT
THERE'S A MIDDLE GROUND WE CAN
COME TO YOU. AS THE BILL-
PROGRESSES THROUGH THE PROCESS
UP WITH THAT NO IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY I WOULD ASK MY
WITNESSES TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND TESTIFY. AND
PROCEED WITH THE HEARING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CAN YOU
WITNESSES MAY BE AGAIN YOU HAVE
A- ROBERT STRAIN CHIEF OF
POLICE WEST SACRAMENTO. AND
ASHLEY MONTEREY ROSA. SAYS
SISTER. EVENING GO AHEAD MOST
VULNERABLE. HI EVERYONE I'M
HONORED TO HAVE BEEN AFTER MY
TESTIMONY FOR EIGHTY FIVE NINE
FOUR FOR THOSE THAT DON'T KNOW
I'M ACTUALLY BONTA WROTE THAT
THE SURVIVING SISTER OF MY
BROTHER SEAN MONTERROSA ON JUNE
SECOND OF TWENTY TWENTY MY
BROTHER SEAN WAS KNEELING WITH
HIS HANDS UP WHEN OFFICER
GERAKAN OF THE VALLEJO POLICE
DEPARTMENT SHOT THROUGH THE
WINDSHIELD OF AN UNMARKED
PICKUP TRUCK WITH AN A. R.
FIFTEEN. SEAN WAS BASICALLY
KILLED IN A DRIVE BY A MONTH
AFTER MY BROTHER'S MURDER THE
PRESIDENT OF THE POLICE UNION
MICHAEL NICOLINI OF LALE
ORDERED THE DESTRUCTION OF
EVIDENCE THE WINDSHIELD WAS
DESTROYED AND THE UNMARKED
PICKUPTRUCK WAS PUT PUT BACK
INTO SERVICE AS NOTHING HAD
EVER OCCURRED SINCE JUNE SECOND
INFORMATION OF WHAT'S BEEN
CALLED QUOTE UNQUOTE BAD
SPENDING A RITUAL OF THE BOND
VALLEJO POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN LEAKED TO
THE PUBLIC AND SPARKED NATIONAL
OUTRAGE IN THESE BAD BENDING
RITUALS. METAL DOOR THE OFFICER
INVENTOR THING IF I HAVE
ANYBODY THAT KILLED CELEBRATED
BY A BARBECUE AS AN INITIATION
PARTY I SAY ALL THIS TO SAY
OFFICER THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
LIKE WILL DOUBLE LAYER POLICE
DEPARTMENT CANNOT UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES AND MY BROTHER'S
CASE IT'S BECOME A POLITICAL
GAME OF HOT POTATO D. A.
CHRISTIAN ABRAMS OF SOLANO
COUNTY HAS ACCUSED YOURSELF
SHORTLY AFTER THE FOOTAGE WAS
RELEASED. FURTHERMORE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE YET BUT DATA SAID
HE WOULD REVIEW THE ENTIRE
VALLEJO POLICE DEPARTMENT
INCLUDING MY BROTHER'S MURDER
ONLY FOR HIM TO REJECT WHAT HE
SAID AND ONLY INVESTIGATE THE
DESTRUCTION OF EVIDENCE ON THE
FOUR MONTH ANNIVERSARY OF MY
BROTHER'S DEATH MY SISTER AND I
ALONGSIDE FIFTEEN OTHER
NONVIOLENT PROTESTERS ARRIVE TO
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR ANY SOME SONG
AND DEMANDED THAT HE APPOINTED
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AND
INVESTIGATE JOHN CASE AND THE
CORRUPT. AND VIOLENT POLICING
OF THE VALLEJO POLICE
DEPARTMENT INSTEAD GOVERNOR
NEWSOM LET'S LISTENING TORPEDO
PROJECTED TO TAKE ACTION THE
SECRET SERVICE AND CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL INSTEAD HOW DOES
THE RESIDENTS HOW TO SPEND
TWENTY THREE HOURS IN THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY JAIL WHILE WE
WERE DEMANDING SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD JUST BE A GET ON SO MY
QUESTION IS HOW PARTY IMPACTED
FAMILIES NEED TO GO IMPACTED
FAMILIES SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PUT
THEIR BODIES ON THE LINE AND
FURTHER TRAUMATIZE THEMSELVES.
MY HOPE. IS AB FIVE NINE FOUR
IS THAT K. AS YOU LIKE BROTHERS
DON'T GET SWEPT UNDER THE RUG.
THEY MUST BEEN IN. AND NON BY
GROUP INVESTIGATING OFFICER
ABOUT SHOOTINGS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. GOOD EVENING
MISTER TO MA'AM THANKS FOR THE
UP TO BUY TODAY A FIVE FOUR MY
NAME IS ROB AND PLACE YOU THEM
FOR THE BUCK WHAT. WHAT GREAT
POWER COMES GREAT RISK. THE
MODERN POLICE LEADER KNOWS THE
ADDRESS THE AMOUNT OF THE DOOR
PLEASE I FOR. ENGAGES APPROACH
AND PROFESSIONAL SCRUTINY OF
POLICE ACTION INVOLVED THE USE
OF FORCE. THE PROFESSIONALISM
OF THE- OF THE SKIRT PROFOUNDLY
IMPORTANT ONE OF POLICING
COUNTER RESULT IN THE DEATH OF
A COMMUNITY MEMBER OF POLICE
OFFICERS. AB FIVE NINETY FOUR
CREATE CLEARLY DEFINED ROLES
FOR THE INVESTIGATION OF
OFFICER INVOLVED FATAL INCIDENT
SO THAT THE PEOPLE. CAN BE MORE
REASONABLY ASSURED THAT THESE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE INDEPENDENT
AND LEGITIMATE. AT THE STATE
MANDATE PATHWAY FOR COST
RECOVERY FOR INVESTIGATORS BUT
EXPENSIVE IS NOTABLE AND
IMPORTANT. WHAT TECHNOPOLIS
BERMAN MIKE ALL YOUR WOOD
COUNTY AGENCIES EMPLOYED THAN
ONE HUNDRED COMMUNITY POLICE
OFFICERS. SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT BODY HAS
USED AB NINE FIVE NINETY FOUR
ALIGNED APPROACHES TO
INVESTIGATING FATAL POLICE
ENCOUNTERS. WITH APPROACH WAS
CONCEIVED AFTER RESEARCHING
SIMILAR METHODOLOGIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN MY PRIOR ROLE AS
THE CHIEF INVESTIGATOR FOR THE
OLD COUNTY DA'S OFFICE. NEIL
COUNTY OFFICER CRITICAL
INCIDENT PROTOCOL UTILIZES AN
INDEPENDENT AGENCY COUPLED WITH
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT TO CONDUCT A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION A BOXER ACTION IN
FAILING TO. WHAT THE
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETE
FULLER REVIEW THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ISSUED A
SUMMARY TRIBUNE FINAL AND MAKE
THIS AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
THIS PROTOCOL BEEN UTILIZED
OVER TEN TIMES THE BOOK FATAL
AND NON FATAL ACCIDENTS SINCE
IMPLEMENTATION. HAS WORKED WELL
REAL COUNT. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE'S NO THAT INCREASING OUR
PROFESSION'S CREDIBILITY
PERCEPTION OF LEGITIMACY AND
OVERALL COMMUNITY CONFIDENCE IS
OF PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE. THIS
IS THERE WAS BROAD SUPPORT FOR
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO TAKE ON
THESE INVESTIGATIONS AND HOLE
IN THE EARLY ITERATIONS OF AB
FIFTEEN OF SIX. MANDATE
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL REFLECT
A PRAGMATIC CORRECTIVE STEP
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALLER AND EVEN
SOME MEDIUM SIZE ABLE TO CROSS
THE STATE. I DO BELIEVE THERE
WILL NEED TO BE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE FIT AND IMPLICATIONS
OF THIS APPROACH WITH LARGE
AGENCIES. OFTEN LARDED WITH THE
EXPERTS WITH VASTLY MORE
EXPERIENCED IN THE SPACE-
TRANSPONDER KEY STEP IN
CONTEMPORARY BEST PRACTICES.
LIKELY VALIDATING THEIR
INVESTIGATIVE CAPACITY IN
PROFESSIONAL. I COULD ALSO SEE
THAT A POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
WORKLOAD ON SMALLER NEIGHBORING
JURISDICTIONS COULD BE SO
TACTIC BUT AT THE MEASURE
DIMINISHES THAT SMALLER
AGENCIES CAPACITY TO SERVE
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY. THIS ASIDE
I BELIEVE AB FIVE NINETY FOUR
WOULD BE A GOOD STANDARDIZED
APPROACH FOR SMALL TO MEDIUM
SIZED AGENCIES THAT SUPPORT
THIS APPROACH TO ACHIEVING
INDEPENDENT DESTINATIONS ON
OFFER INVOLVED FATAL INCIDENT
ALL THREE LAUNCH FORTUNATE
DIDN'T INCOMPETENCE. AND HAVE
SEEN IT SUCCESSFULLY. AND
UTILIZED. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING INPUT ON BILL.
THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN AN
COMMITTEE. THAT WOULD SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN THE CONFERENCE
ROOM. TELECONFERENCE ROOM-
EIGHTEEN T. ARE THERE ANY-
PHONE IN SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY SEVEN
OKAY LET'S HEAR FROM THEM. WHAT
WHAT BACKING A VALID NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE ONE
NUMBER TWO TWENTY FOUR. YEAH
I'M AT A HIGHER CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
ONLY HAVE ONE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
NINE. MARKET GEORGE OF THE HALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO FIFTY SEVEN.
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS RON RAPP ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THE NEXT ONE IS MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. IS
IT NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WE ARE IN
BETWEEN- WE DO SUPPORT THE
PRINCIPLE THAT THEY SHOULD NOT
THAT. THAT THAT THERE SHOULD BE
LONG PORTION NOT INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES HOWEVER THIS BILL
DOES NOT ESTABLISH AN
INDEPENDENT ENTITY TO
INVESTIGATE IT SHIFTED INTO A
DIFFERENT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE SO WE'RE NOT SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT. LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMMENT IN QUEUE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CANACCORD ON ON BEHALF
OF THE CANTICLE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING
UP MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
CORY'S ALLSTATE ZILLOW- COUNTY
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION ON
THE PHONE. PRETTY OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CORY CELLS L. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FIVE NINETY FOUR AS NOTED
THE BILL WOULD PRECLUDE AN
EMPLOYING AGENCY FROM HAVING
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY IN
CONDUCTING A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION- BUT WOULD NOT
APPLY TO OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS RESULTING IN THE
DEATHS OF UNARMED CIVILIANS
THAT IS ALREADY COVERED. BY
LAST YEAR'S AB FIFTEEN OH SIX-
WELL SOME LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES SIMILAR TO WHAT IS
REQUIRED BY THE BILL AS YOU
RECENTLY HEARD OTHER AGENCIES
FOR VARIOUS REASONS HAVE FOUND
IT MORE APPROPRIATE AND OR
FEASIBLE TO UNDERTAKE THESE
INVESTIGATIONS THEMSELVES SOME
LARGER AGENCIES MAY BE BEST
EQUIPPED TO TAKE ON THE
DIFFICULT INVESTIGATION
CONTEMPLATED BY THIS BILL.
ARTICULATELY AS IT RELATES TO
SHERIFF'S OFFICES THERE MAY BE
NO CITY POLICE AGENCY FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
EITHER IN THE CASE OF A POLICE
INITIALLY THERE MAY NOT BE A
CITY POLICE AGENCY AT ALL- IN A
SMALL COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE- FOR
THE POLICE AGENCY OR DIS OFFICE
THAT EXISTS MAY NOT BE CAPABLE
OF HANDLING THIS TYPE OF
INVESTIGATION GIVEN THE SIZE
AND- EXPERTISE OF THEIR STAFF.
WITHOUT OFFENSE TO THEM JUST
THE WAY THAT I CAN BE
SOMETIMES- RELATEDLY WHEN THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE MAY BE THE
ONLY AGENCY AND I COUNTY A
QUICK TO INVESTIGATE SUCH
CASES. THIS BILL WOULD
EFFECTIVELY PUT ALL THE BURDEN
ON THAT SHERIFF'S OFFICE TO
COMPLY WITH THE BILL WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION OF RESOURCES AND
COSTS- AGAIN LAST YEAR'S AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX HAS NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED YET. BUT AB FIVE
NINETY FOUR WOULD FURTHER
COMPLICATE MATTERS RELATED TO
INVESTIGATING IMPORTANT CASES
FOR THIS REASON THAN THOSE
STATED ABOVE CSSA UNFORTUNATELY
MUST OPPOSE AB FIVE NINETY
FOUR. HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR- BUT IN THE CURRENT FORM.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. THEY YOU. ARE THERE
ANY. ANYONE INSIDE THE CHAMBER
THAT. SEEING NONE THERE IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION.
AND NOW AT&T TO THE FRONT OR
ANY PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION. OF A.
B. BIARLAH MORE. THE PROJECT
AND IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION IT
IS. ONE ZERO. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY QUEUING UP. OKAY BRING
IT TO THE BODY IT TO THE- LIST
MR LACKEY HAS A QUESTION. OR
COMMENT FOR. LITTLE BIT OF BOTH
I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST OF ALL-
ASK YOU A VERY DIRECT QUESTION
HOW WOULD AGENCIES- GET
FINANCIALLY REIMBURSED. IT
WOULD BE A REQUIREMENT LIKE WE
SEE WITH SO MANY AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA DOING THIS
NEARLY. YEAH I AGREE I AGREE
HERE YEAH. LIKE WE SEE AGENCIES
DOING THIS TODAY I MEAN. WE'VE
SEEN THE NUMBER OF OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS GO DOWN
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL CONTINUE TO
GO DOWN WITH. A GOOD HANDS
TRAINING- WITH AB THREE NINETY
TWO AND TWO THIRTY THE
RESOURCES FROM THE BUDGET A FEW
YEARS AGO. SOME OF THESE OF
COURSE WILL NOW GO TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
JURISDICTIONS THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE TEAMS ALREADY DOING
INVESTIGATIONS AND SO THE
ADJACENT THAT THE TURKS IN THE
CASE OF DEPARTMENT WOULD COME
OVER AND HELP LIKE SO MANY OF
THESE. THESE ARE DOING TODAY
WITH THEM TO USE EXISTING
POLICY SO IT WOULD BE FINDING
OUT OF THESE FUNDED OUT OF
EXISTING- LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RESOURCES. OKAY SECONDLY. ON
THESE VERY RURAL. PORTIONS OF
THE STATE AND WE HAVE MANY OF
THEM. YEAH WHERE- THEY HAVE
HUNDREDS OF MILES. IF NOT
THOUSANDS. OF MILES TO- TO
PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SERVICES FOR AND SO THEY DON'T
REALLY HAVE. AGENCIES THAT ARE
RIGHT NEXT TO THEM THE BUT UP
NEXT TO A MISSILE THAT PUTS HIM
AT A VERY EXTREME A
DISADVANTAGE IN FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS WELL BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEY'RE FUNDING. IS ALSO NOT
THAT STRONG AND I JUST I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS. BILL BECAUSE IT
ALSO PRESUPPOSES MISTRUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT. HAVING DONE THESE
KIND OF INVESTIGATIONS WITHIN
MY OWN AGENCY. FOR A LONG TIME
I COULD TELL YOU THAT- THIRD
THERE'S STRONG INTEREST IN
GETTING TO THE TRUTH.
INDEPENDENT OF- SAME AGENCY
CONNECTION SO I CAN I'M SORRY
BUT I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS. THANK
YOU YOU MAY ANSWER THE QUESTION
I WOULD YEAH- SO I THINK THERE
ARE TWO POINTS THAT BROUGHT
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP BY THE
OPPOSITION AND BY MY SUPPORTER
FRANKLY THAT SHE FROM. WEST
SACRAMENTO TALKING ABOUT LARGE
URBAN AGENCIES THINK OF L. A.
P. D. L. A. COUNTY SHERIFF THEY
HAVE EXPERTISE DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE RELIC SHERIFF TO BRING
IN. CITY OF PALMDALE I'M NOT
SURE THEY HAVE A POLICE
DEPARTMENT SO. WE'RE WILLING TO
THINK ABOUT THAT INTERACTION
BUT HAVING ANOTHER POLICE
DEPARTMENT PART OF IT I THINK
THIS BRINGS ABOUT MORE PUBLIC
TRUST THAT THE UMPIRE CALLING
BALLS AND STRIKES ISN'T YOU
KNOW LEAN ON ONE TEAM- IN THE
RURAL AREAS TO I THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT WILL
CERTAINLY LOOK AT THINKING
ABOUT. THE DALAI DISTRICT UP
THERE AND I'LL TURN US THERE'S
NO JURISDICTION AROUND THE
ATLANTA PROBABLY ISN'T ALTURAS
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THAT COUNT
IT'S THE STATE'S THE COUNTY
SHERIFF. SO I THINK THOSE ARE
REASONABLE THINGS BUT I DO KNOW
THIS THIS IS THE FUTURE OF
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THE POLICE CHIEFS
ARE SAYING WE WANT TO DO MORE
OF THIS. THEY KNOW THAT THERE
IS DISTRUST. MAYBE THERE
SHOULDN'T BE AS YOU SAY BUT
THERE IS COMMITTEE DISTRUST
HAVING HAVING MORE INDEPENDENCE
IN THESE INVESTIGATIONS BRINGS
ABOUT I THINK A BETTER OUTCOME
BRINGS ABOUT MORE COMMUNITY-
BUYING INTO THE PROCESS AND SO
THIS IS HAPPENING ACROSS OUR
STATE. AND THE MORE
JURISDICTIONS THAT DO THIS
WHETHER THEY I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE EVERY DEPARTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S WE CAN GET 90% OR
80% BUT I THINK IT'S A BIG A
BIG VICTORY FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU MR QUIRK. YEAH MY CONCERN
IS THAT I DON'T SEE THIS
ENGENDERING ANYMORE TRUST AND
HERE'S WHY. THERE ARE ALREADY
CONCERNS WHEN THE DA R.
INVESTIGATES A POLICE OFFICER
THAT HE OR SHE IS- PREJUDICE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE POLICE.
THERE ARE ALREADY CONCERNS-
THAT YOU KNOW OFFICERS IN ONE
DEPARTMENT ARE GOING TO BE- HOW
CAN THEY SAY DIFFERENTIAL TO AN
OFFICER FROM ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT. IF YOU WANTED TO
SET UP A SEPARATE UNIT MUCH
LIKE YOU DID FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WHERE I.
SUPPORTED THE BALLOT WAS A CO
AUTHOR I COULD FEEL SUPPORTIVE
BUT I JUST DON'T SEE THIS
REALLY ADVANCING THE FOOTBALL
SO THAT'S MY CONCERN. THE DO
YOU ANSWERING YOUR SERVICE YEAH
YEAH- WHAT WHEN I PROPOSED THIS
LAST YEAR I TALKED TO A FEW
POLICE CHIEFS AND IF YOU D.
A.'S AND THEY SAID WHILE NOT A
PERFECT SYSTEM THIS WOULD
IMPROVE THE PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TRANSFER OF
EVIDENCE IS LESS LIKELY TO BE
TAMPERED DESTROYED LIKE IT
WASN'T DELAY I SIT BACK BILLS
VALLEJO. THEY THOUGHT NUMBER
ONE THERE'D BE ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SURE HEY
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T DESTROY THAT
WINDSHIELD. READ THE DEPUTY IN
THE BACK SHOT THROUGH IS A R.
FIFTEEN AND YOU KNOW MAYBE WE
SHOULDN'T. DESTROY IT THAT THIS
LET'S TAKE A PAUSE ON THAT
HAVING ANOTHER SET OF EYES. AND
VOICE IN THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
BUT ALSO- YOU KNOW THEY THOUGHT
THAT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
WITH WITH THE WITH THE OVERALL
COMMUNITY SO- THIS IS ACTUALLY
AN IDEA THAT I GOT FROM. LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN WE WERE GOING
AND WORKING ON FIFTEEN OH SIX
AND GRANTED NOT ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUPPORTS IT. BUT I
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA THEY
HAVE A ONE OF MY CITIES HERE
DOES THIS THE OTHER IS THINKING
ABOUT DOING IT. AND I BELIEVE
THAT THE MORE CITIES THAT DO
THIS SO MAKING INVESTIGATIONS
MORE INDEPENDENT AND BRING
ABOUT- TRUST AND THANK YOU FOR
THE MOTION THE SECOND THANK YOU.
READ THE OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. YOU MAY CLOSE.
THOUSAND ELIGIBLE. OKAY I'M I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BECAUSE IT
IT BEGINS THE PROCESS OF-
HAVING MORE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SCRUTINY IT WELL IT MAY NOT BE
PERFECT WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING SO. RESPECTFULLY ASK
EVERYONE FOR AN AYE VOTE. I'M
AB FIVE NINE FOUR FIVE THE
MEMBER MCCARTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER IRAQI NOT VOTING LACKEY
NOT BODING BARRICADE CAN.
BERWICK HE HAD AYE COURT NOT
VOTING FOR NOW CORK NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I SEE OUR
TOWN NO SEE OUR TURN NOW WICKS.
WICKS I LI LI I. THE MEASURE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. NUMBER OF.
MR PATTERSON YOUR NEXT. ANIMAL
WELFARE AB TWO FIVE THREE.
WHERE. WE'RE SANITIZING THE
AREA RIGHT NOW. AFTER MR
MCCARTY. THANK YOU. TWENTY TO
PUSH THE BUTTON YOU GET A GOOD
YES WE CAN. UP UP WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MOTIONS AND- LET ME
JUST. BASICALLY PURPOSES- IS
REALLY IS A LOT OF RISING. THE
MANNER IN WHICH WITH RESPECT
TO. COPYRIGHT RESEARCHERS HOW
THE NOTIFICATIONS ARE NOT
DISTRIBUTED- SO LAW ENFORCEMENT
APPEARS AT THE SPIKED IT'S
COMMON FOR THE ATTENDEES TO
FLEE. THEY LEAVE A LOT OF THE
BIRDS BEHIND LAW ENFORCEMENT
THEN TAKES POSSESSION- OF THE
ANIMALS AND FILES A PETITION
WITH THE COURT TO HUMANELY
EUTHANIZE. BEFORE DOING SO
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A PUBLIC
NOTICE OF DESTRUCTION OF THE
ANIMALS TO BE POSTED IN A HARD
COPY NEWSPAPER FOR THREE
CONSECUTIVE DAYS. THE STATUTE
THAT DICTATES THE PRACTICE. OF
PUBLICIZING THE SEIZURE ND
PROPOSED DESTRUCTION OF
ROOSTERS USED IN ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED.
FOR DECADES AND WAS WRITTEN
LONG. SO AB TWO FIFTY THREE
SIXTY UPDATE THE PENAL CODE SO
THE PUBLIC NOTICES MAY BE
PUBLISHED THROUGH ADDITIONAL
SOURCES RATHER THAN SOLELY A
PRINT NEWSPAPER. AND THE
SOURCES INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED TO SOCIAL MEDIA OUTLETS
AND OR ONLINE PUBLICATIONS
THROUGH NEWSPAPER WEBSITES.
CURRENTLY- AGENCIES ARE FACED
WITH WHAT AMOUNTS TO A-
BASICALLY A VERY HIGH COST
MONOPOLY. I'VE SEEN- RECEIPTS
FROM CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE NEWSPAPERS
CHARGE EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLAR RANGE
JUST FOR THE THREE DAY MINIMUM
SO CURRENT LAW IS SETTING UP
WHAT LOOKS LIKE TO BE AN
OUTDATED AND EXPENSIVE METHOD.
THAT SO THAT THE HARD COPY
NEWSPAPERS RECEIVED UP
EXCLUSIVITY WHEN IN FACT WE'RE
SEEING A DECLINE IN THE
CIRCULATION OF THE HARD PRINT
NEWSPAPERS WHAT THIS BILL TRIES
TO DO IS TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
REALITIES OF TODAY. BY ALLOWING
US TO TAILOR THE MESSAGE TO THE
GEOGRAPHY THE DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP
THE LANGUAGE GROUP IT SECTOR.
SO BY ALLOWING THOSE THAT WANT
TO PUBLISH THAT THE AGENCIES TO
PUBLISH THESE NOTICES. ONLINE
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO PUBLISH
THEM MUCH MORE FREQUENTLY MUCH
MORE WIDESPREAD AND IN THE
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES FURTHER
INCREASING PUBLIC AWARENESS FOR
THE PURPOSE- BUT THE
NOTIFICATION AB. THIS BILL
RECEIVED A UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
LAST YEAR I'M HOPING WE CAN.
ACHIEVE THAT HERE AGAIN I HAVE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF- CHAU A BUTCHER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. SHIP WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTER BUSH LOOK.
YOU MISTER CHAIR- GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS HE SHAUN
MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PLEASED THAT
TO SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIFTY THREE I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
FOSTERING THIS LEGISLATION AB
TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD AFFECT
THE PUBLICATION NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS AT THE SEIZURE AND
DESTRUCTION OF LISTER'S. USEFUL
COPYWRITING- MANY NEIGHBORING
STATES HAVE MAYKOP ACTIVITIES A
FELONY AFTER MANY OF THESE
OPERATIONS HAVE MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS ONLY A
MISDEMEANOR MANY OF WHICH ARE
HELD IN FRESNO COUNTY. AND WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN THAT THE TIED OF
THE CONCERNS OUTLINED IN
ANALYSIS REGARDING IMPORTANCE
OF USING YOU SPEND FOURTEENTH
OFFICIAL NOTICES IN A MANNER
THAT IS ACCEPTABLE TO EVERYONE.
HOWEVER WE AND YOU NEED TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGH INCREASINGLY ARE USING
DIGITAL MEDIA- WITHOUT
AFFECTING THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
REQUIRED DUE PROCESS AND EQUAL
PROTECTION PROVIDED THEIR
STATUTES. WE WOULD LIKE TO
SIMPLY UPDATE THE STATUTE SO
THAT THE NOTICE TO DESTROY MR
HUGHES WILL **** FIGHTING CAN
BE PUBLISHED. REGIONALLY- WE- I
APPRECIATE IT AGAIN- ASSEMBLY
MAR PATTERSON OFFERING IT
LEGISLATION AS HE MENTIONED-
DISAGREED BILL GET PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY LAST HEARING
COMMITTEE SO WE HOPE. THAT WE
CAN ONCE AGAIN HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT AND WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. ARE ANY
WITNESSES THAT ARE IN THE
TELECONFERENCE ROOM. EIGHTEEN
T. ARE THERE ANY TELEPHONE
WITNESSES THEY WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU TWO ONE ZERO
THANK YOU UP. IN SUPPORT. AND
WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY QUEUING UP
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
ONCE
AGAIN A ONE MAN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE A SUPPORT
COMING FROM THE LINE OF TWO
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING. THURMOND HI JOHN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- THIS
YEAR YOU CAN REX WHAT THE FCK
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONCE AGAIN IT IS ONE NINE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AND I DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP FOR
SUPPORT AS OF NOW. THANK YOU-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I HAVE
A- WHITNEY UP POSSIBLY S. C.
NPA BY PHONE AND KATHY SURE
ACLU. S. AFTERNOON- COUNTY
SHERIFF AT THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA- WE RESPECTFULLY NOT
DEPOSED EIGHTY TWO FIFTY THREE-
EIGHTY TWO FIFTY THREE BUSINESS
A REQUIREMENT FOR PUBLICATION
OF NOTICE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN ANIMAL FEED IN CONNECTION
WITH ANIMAL FIGHTING ARE GOING
TO BE DESTROYED. THE
APPLICATION IS A SPECIFIC ONE
BUT THE PRINCIPLES INVOLVED
ABROAD WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
TAKES ACTION THAT AFFECT
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS IT MUST GIVE
NOTICE IN A WAY CALCULATED TO
REACH THOSE WHOSE INTERESTS ARE
AFFECTED AND SO THAT THE FACT
THAT NOTICE HAS BEEN GIVEN HOW
CAN BE VERIFIED. THERE ARE WELL
OVER A THOUSAND DIFFERENT CODE
SECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA LAW THAT
PROVIDES FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO
GIVE NOTICE IN A NEWSPAPER OF
GENERAL CIRCULATION OF VARIOUS
FACTIONS WITH AFFECT PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS INCLUDING EVERYTHING
FROM PUTTING THE CONTRACT OUT
TO DEAD NOTICES REGARDING
PROPOSED LOCAL BALLOT MEASURES.
AND WHEN THE GOVERNMENT EITHER
PROPERTY AND INTENT TO DESTROY
IT AWKWARD BUT IT PERMANENTLY
IT MUST GIVE NOTICE IN A
NEWSPAPER OF GENERAL
CIRCULATION NEWSPAPER OF
GENERAL CIRCULATION IS DEFINED
IN THE GOVERNMENT CODE OBJECT
AND SUBJECT TO COURT
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER A
PUBLICATION. MEETS THOSE
CRITERIA. THE STATURE TOUR
REQUIRE FROM. OF NOTICE IN THE
NEWS. ARE IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE'S MAKING SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC GAP INFORMATION ON
GOVERNMENT ACTIONS THAT AFFECT
THEM. THEY ARE INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT NOTICES PUBLISHED
IN AN INDEPENDENT FORUM. THAT
CAN BE INDEPENDENTLY VERIFIED
THAT THERE IS A RECORD OF THE
NOTICE. AND THAT NOTICE IS
ACCEPTABLE. AND THAT IT IS
GIVEN AWAY TO. MAXIMIZE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES WILL BE ABLE TO SEE A-
NEWSPAPER NOTICES MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS. THERE MAY BE
OTHER WAYS TO MEET THEM AND WE
WOULD WELCOME A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT THOSE WAYS MIGHT BE.
BUT ALLOWING NOTICE BE
PUBLISHED ON A SOCIAL MEDIA
OUTLETS BELONGING TO A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY OR ON A LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERNET WEBSITE
SURELY COULD NOT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. WHICH COULD NOT
BE INDEPENDENTLY COULD NOT
VERIFIABLE THERE IS NO RECORD.
WITHOUT STRONGER PROTECTIONS IT
WILL BECOME A SIMPLE MATTER FOR
AGENCIES TO PURPOSEFULLY OR
INADVERTENTLY. AREA NOTICE ON A
TWITTER FEED THAT NO ONE READ.
THIS MAY NOT SEEM LIKE IT
MATTERS MUCH MORE TALKING ABOUT
THESE ROOSTERS BUT REST ASSURED
THAT IS THE FOUNDER FOR
PUBLICATION IS CHANGED IN THIS
WAY HERE. WE WILL SPEAK OPPOSED
NO TO SEE A CHANGE IN THE SAME
WAY ELSEWHERE IN THE LAW WHEN
MUCH MORE MAY BE AT STAKE. WE
URGE YOU NOT TO CHANGE ANY
NOTICE REQUIREMENT WITHOUT
PUTTING IN THE CAREFUL THOUGHT
AND ANALYSIS THAT IS NEEDED
JUST LOOK AT ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS WE RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE. THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESS. AND
CHAIN. THAT OPPOSE. ANY OTHER.
SHARE BERNIE BERNSTEIN CAL
SORRY YOU ARE HERE OKAY GO
AHEAD. HEY I AM SORRY ABOUT
THAT- AGAIN GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I WAS TRYING TO KEEP IT AS
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS- I'M
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY TWO FIFTY
THREE PER FEW REASONS- FIRST.
AND FOREMOST WE FEEL THIS IS
THE BEST WAY TO REACH INTO A
COMMUNITY- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PUBLIC IS AWARE OF IT YEP
REQUIREMENTS IN A NOTICE I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT IT. BROADBAND IN INTERNET
ACCESS WHILE MORE PEOPLE MAYBE
TRIBUNE ONLINE TOO DIGITAL
FORMS OF COMMUNICATIONS THERE
THIRTY THREE FELLOW THAT IF
INTRODUCED SO FAR BEST SESSION.
TO ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES. I
AM BROADBAND ACCESS AND IT IS
IN THE ARE MORE WORLD. THAT LIE
THE STOCK THAT TO PRIVATE. THAT
RELY ON ART PRINT OUR MEMBERS
PUBLICATIONS TO GET THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED HI- FOR
EXAMPLE. ALSO- IN FRESNO THE
COSBY WHICH WAS MENTIONED
REACHES FIFTY THOUSAND- PRINT
SUBSCRIBERS ON A REGULAR BASIS-
WHEREAS FRESNO SHERIFF'S-
TWITTER FEED ONLY REACHES
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FOLLOWERS ON
IT A BIT ON THE BASIS- AND ALSO
I WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT LEAVES
NEWSPAPERS THAT ARE A NEWSPAPER
OF GENERAL CIRCULATION- IS A
TERM OF ART AND THEY HAVE BEEN
FOUND BY A QUARTER TO REACH
UNSUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PAID
SUBSCRIBERS IN THE AREAS THAT
THAT THAT THE PUBLICATION
INSTANCE A SIR- AND SO FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN CHAMBER.
THAT OPPOSE. ANY WITNESSES IN.
IN THE ROOM. NOPE AND THEIR
DEAR AT&T ARE ANY WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION. YOU
ARE OPPOSITION IT AT ONE IT MAN.
ZERO WE DO HAVE SOME PARTICULAR
GOVERNOR TO BE JUST A MOMENT.
COMING FROM THE LINE OF. TWO
SIXTY TWO. YEAH. HOLD ON ONE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
AND REGINA BROWN WILSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
BLACK MEDIA- I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST REGISTER THAT WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION I'M THE BILL
I'M NOT BECAUSE I'M JUST THIS
PARTICULAR BILL BUT WHAT IT
DOES IN GENERAL THE PUBLIC
NOTICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY OTHERS
QUEUED UP FOR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU A QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I HAVE MISTER LEAVE
PERSON. MR QUIRK IN IN THIS
WEEK'S THANK YOU AND SOMEWHERE
PATTERSON BRING THIS I JUST
WANT TO GET A SENSE OF HOW
PERVASIVE AND LARGEST PROBLEM
IS HOW MANY **** ARE BEING
EUTHANIZED EVERY YEAR. AB HOW
DO I KNOW. WELL I MEAN IT SAYS
EVERY PUBLICATION IS ABOUT
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS I JUST
WONDER HOW MUCH IS IT COSTING
LAW EFORCEMENT AGENCIES WELL I
THINK THE POINT THAT I WAS
TRYING TO MAKE HERE IS. THAT
FOR THREE. DAYS OF LIMITED
LINAGE- THESE CHARGES ARE
ASTRONOMICAL. THE REALITY IS
THAT IT DEFEATS THE VERY
PURPOSE OF THE NOTIFICATION.
BECAUSE IT LIMITS THE BREADTH
AND THE SCOPE AND THE- ABILITY
NOTICE OUT TO CHOOSE THE
GEOGRAPHY THE LANGUAGE. OF THE-
DEMOGRAPHICS. AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE APPROACHING AND I
UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND AS A YOUNG PERSON I
DEFINITELY AND SYMPATHETIC TO
MODERNIZING ANTIQUATED AND
QUICK MENUS BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING HOW OFTEN DO THEY
HAVE TO DO THIS LET'S PUT IT
THIS WAY IT'S ENOUGH. IT'S A-
IT'S ENOUGH TO WHERE THE PRICE
TAG. FOR THE FRESNO- SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IS VERY VERY HIGH
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT OF
THESE ACTIVITIES. THE BIRDS ARE
ARE- TAKEN IT INTO THEIR
CUSTODY. AND IT IS-
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT- TO
JUSTIFY 800-021-1000 DOLLAR
PRICE TAG FOR. LIMITED
DISTRIBUTION. SO I THE OTHER IS
WE'RE THE WE'RE BASICALLY
ALLOWING PEOPLE. DO YOU HAVE
CHOICES. IF THEY SEEK TO DO
THIS IN A MORE DIRECT WAY OR
DEMOGRAPHIC WHERE GEOGRAPHIC
WAY- AND HAVE A OF A MULTITUDE
OF CHOICES. R. AS COMPARED
280-001-0000 NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PLUNK DOWN AT A
NEWSPAPER THAT THAT HAS THAT-
CERTAINLY HAS OF CIRCULATION
BUT THE QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
IT IS A- DIRECTED ARE TIED TO-
WHERE THE- BIRDS WERE TAKEN
WHERE THE- LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOLKS THANK THAT THE OWNERSHIP.
MAY RESIDE THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS SO IT'S TARGETED LESS
EXPENSIVE AND ULTIMATELY GETS
TO THE POINT. WHERE THE ABILITY
TO DO WHAT NOTIFICATION SHOULD
DO GET TO THE PEOPLE DO IT IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS EXPANSION OF
DISTRIBUTION RATHER THAN
CONTRACTION. AND BE ABLE TO GET
THE- SATISFACTION THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING THESE
NOTIFICATIONS CANCEL THAT.
INTEREST IN THE OWNERSHIP OF
THOSE PLAN I UNDERSTAND
DEFINITELY HAVING THE
SATISFACTION OF EXPANDING THOSE
OPTIONS OF NOTICING FOR
ROOSTERS ARE **** OR OTHER
ANIMALS THAT ARE APPREHENDED-
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THE PRACTICAL IMPLICATIONS
OF IT SO THAT'S WHY ASKING THE
NUMBERS AND I DON'T MEAN IT AS
AN OFFENSE I GENERALLY WANT TO
KNOW HOW BIG THE PROBLEM IS. SO
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO GET THOSE
NUMBERS TO US THAT WOULD BE
GREAT- BUT I THINK THE
PRINCIPAL'S REPORT OF PUBLIC
NOTICING SO A FORTY TODAY I
WON'T BE VOTING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL- BUT DEFINITELY WOULD
WANT TO KNOW HOW BIG THE
PROBLEM IS. LET ME LET ME
STIPULATE THAT IT IS A REAL BIG
PROBLEM YOU'VE DEALT WITH AN
AWFUL LOT OF BIG ISSUES TODAY.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS VERY
MUCH CONSTRAINED- THE
COCKFIGHTING PROTECTIVELY
PARTICULARLY IN THE VALLEY AND
IN SOME AREAS IN THE URBAN
AREAS AS WELL. AND PROVIDE FOR
A- CHOICE- WHICH COULD INCLUDE
THE NEWSPAPERS ARE COULDN'T
COULD INCLUDE- MINORITY- SITES
ONLINE SITES OTHERS SO THERE IS
A- SET OF CHOICES. MADE TO GET
TO THE END GAME WHICH IS. BE
SATISFIED THAT YOU'RE REACHING
THE PEOPLE THAT MOST LIKELY
WILL HAVE OWNERSHIP AND
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY COULD
HAVE SOME INPUT INTO THE
DECISION OF THE DESTRUCTION OF
THOSE BIRDS. THE CERK- LET ME
SEE IF I CAN CONVINCE MISTER
LEE. WELL SO HERE'S THE PROBLEM
NEWSPAPER CIRCULATION IS
PROBABLY ATTEMPT WHAT IT WAS
WHEN WE- SET UP THESE LAWS.
MANY MORE PEOPLE HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS TO TAKE THE NEWSPAPER.
YOU PROBABLY WELL IN THE IN
THE- IN SCIENTIFIC TERMS AN
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE THAT IS A
FACTOR OF TEN IT COULD EVEN BE
A HUNDRED BY THE TIME THIS
DECADES OVER BECAUSE FRANKLY
THE NEWSPAPERS KEEP ON
CONSOLIDATING AND AS THEY
CONSOLIDATE. THEY STOP COVERING
LOCAL NEWS I WISH I KNEW WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN EVERY CITY
COUNCIL THERE WAS A TIME I
COULD KNOW THAT. NOW I JUST
HAVE TO CALL PEOPLE UP BECAUSE
THE NEWSPAPER DOESN'T COVER IT
YOU KNOW NO WONDER-
CIRCULATIONS GOING DOWN WHEN
THEY DON'T COVER THE THINGS
THAT PEOPLE ALWAYS CARED ABOUT.
ANYWAY GETTING BACK TO THAT A
LOT MORE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET AND FOR THAT
REASON AND THE OTHER THING IS
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NOTICES I
MEAN YOU'VE GOT COLUMN AFTER
COLUMN BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE SAVE
NOTICES SHOULD BE IN THE PAPER.
HOW YOU CAN NEVER FIND IT. SO
THIS IS A MUCH BETTER SYSTEM. I
WOULD LIKE IT IF YOU COULD
THINK ABOUT. A WAY TO MAKE THIS
UNIFORM SO ANOTHER WORDS
SOMEBODY WHO LOST A PET. IN
BAKERSFIELD COULD DO RESEARCH.
AND IF THE PET ENDED UP IN
FRESNO WHICH IS ENTIRELY
LIKELY. THAT IT'S IN NOT IN THE
CITY THEY ARE IN THEY COULD DO
IT AN EASIER SEARCHING THIS
WOULD BE A MATTER OF. PEOPLE
COMING UP WITH COMMON WORDS TO
BE USED- BUT THIS IS JUST SO
FAR AHEAD OF WHAT YOU CAN DO
WITH THE NEWSPAPER. AND I JUST
I LOVE IT GREAT BILL. YOU WERE
ALWAYS BRINGING US BILLS HERE
AND PUBLIC SAFETY I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT YOU'VE BROUGHT US
TWO REALLY GOOD ONES TODAY
THANK YOU TO THE APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. WHICH WORKS
THANKS OUR TOP THANK YOU- I
DIDN'T VOTE FOR THIS BILL AND
TO COMMITTEE LAST TIME. LAST
YEAR- SO I DON'T THINK IT WAS
YOU CAN'T UNANIMOUS- COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR. THANK YOU MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN IN ATTENDANCE I WAS
HERE YEAH AND JUST LAID OFF
YEP- OKAY BUT MY CONCERNS THAN
WHICH ARE MY CONCERNS NOW- ARE
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE ACLU AND
THE NEWSPAPERS HAVE RAISED
AROUND THE SETTING PRECEDENT
FOR HOW PUBLIC NOTICES- GIVEN
IN OTHER SITUATIONS EVEN I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A VERY
NARROWLY FOCUSED. ISSUE THAT
YOU'RE BEING FACED WITH CAN YOU
JUST ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THE OPPOSITION
HAVE RAISED. WELL I THINK THAT
THAT. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
THE OPPOSITION- THEY'RE
ESSENTIALLY- ARGUING FOR A SET
OF CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE
OUTDATED AND ARE BEING LEFT
BEHIND BY THE VERY TECHNOLOGY
THAT IS- ESSENTIALLY FORCING
NEWSPAPERS TO STEW. PUBLISH
LESS HARD COPIES AND GO ONLINE
SO I FIND IT A BIT DISINGENUOUS
WHEN- THE NEWSPAPER ASSOCIATION
SUGGESTS THAT- WE'RE TREADING
INTO- AREAS HERE WITH RESPECT
TO LIMITED CONNECTIVITY NOT
EVERYBODY HAS. ACCESS TO THE TO
THE INTERNET. THE REALITY IS
THAT. ABOUT IT IS MUCH MORE
ADVANTAGEOUS TO UTILIZE A
NEWSPAPERS ONLINE.
ANNOUNCEMENTS THEN IT IS
PUBLISHED ANNOUNCEMENTS BECAUSE
OF WHAT I THINK HAS BEEN
MENTIONED HERE SO THESE ARE
KIND OF. OUTDATED STANDARDS. OF
ASSESSING EFFECTIVE
NOTIFICATIONS OVER REALLY
INTERESTED IN AFFECTED
NOTIFICATION WE ARE MODERNIZE
IN THIS PARTICULAR SPACE AND
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL ATTEMPTS
TO AN END HAVE YOU SAT DOWN
WITH ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS IN
TERMS OF THE NEWSPAPER
ASSOCIATION OTHERS WHO'VE
SHARED THESE CONCERNS AND TRY
TO WORK TOWARDS A COMPROMISE
THAT WOULD WORK FOR THEM.
THEY'VE NOT BEEN WILLING TO DO
THAT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN WILLING
TO DO THAT IS I HAVE A WITH
WHICH WE'VE GOT WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH THIS BEFORE B. AT LAST
THE LAST TIME A YEAR AGO. BEEN
THROUGH THIS BEFORE THIS IS
NOTHING NEW HERE AND THE
OPPOSITION IS THE SAME OLD-
STODGY INSTITUTIONAL OPPOSITION
THAT QUITE FRANKLY MISSES THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE. OF EXPANDING
AND EMPHASIZING AND
DISTRIBUTING INFORMATION AS MR
CORKER SUGGESTED. THIS MAY VERY
WELL DEVELOPED. A INTO A- OUR
ONLINE PRESENCE OF
INTERCONNECTEDNESS AND
COOPERATION AND CREATE TAG
INFORMATION WHERE YOU COULD GO
AND ACTUALLY SEARCH BUT UNLESS
THERE IS AN OPTION. TO THE HARD
PRINT MONOPOLY. NONE OF THAT
CAN CAN GAIN TRACTION. MISTER
CHAIR WOULD YOU MIND IF WE LET
THE OPPOSITION SPEAK TO THAT
I'M CURIOUS TO HEAR THEIR
RESPONSE. WOULD YOU MIND IF WE
LET THE OPPOSITION SPEAKS TO.
SURE THE NUMBERS. THERE MIGHT
STATE. IT CAN YOU GET BACK
ONLINE. THREE GOOD AFTERNOON
EVENING MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
BRITNEY BAR BODY- BUT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLISHED THE THIRTY
I'M A PLANS BY. EIGHT SIR AND
COULD YOU SPELL THAT SURE AND
I'M ALSO. YEAH COULD YOU SPEAK
MISTER POTTER REMARK OF. WHAT
HE SAID ABOUT YOUR GUISES PRESS
AND I GUESS AND WE TO MEET TO
TRY TO COME TO COME FROM ON
THAT. YEAH I MEAN I A FEW.
AGAIN ONE. I THEY ALSO TO CLEAR
THAT THERE'S NOT IN THIS THAT
KIRK- IT OR FOR- OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS FROM IN ADDITION
TO PREPAYMENT IN ANY PAPER
FEDERAL CIRCULATION THEY CAN
SHARE ONLINE AND IN FACT. THE
MPA MAINTAINS THE WEBSITE CALL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC NOTICE THAT
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
AUTOMATICALLY UP MOST THEIR
LEGAL PUBLIC NOTICES YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT IS SEARCHABLE AND
INCLUDES ALL THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FUNCTIONS. THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED. IN ADDITION TO
YOU KNOW IT'S OF COMING TO
TERMS OF A RANGE- WE STILL.
THAT NEWSPAPERS ARE THE BEST
WAY OF REACHING THE MOST AMOUNT
OF FOLKS. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY WHEN A
COURT OF LAW HAS DETERMINED
THAT THEY REACH A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF PAID SUBSCRIBERS IN
THE AREA THE NOTICE IS REQUIRED
TO BE PUBLISHED FOR- AND THAT
THE BROADBAND ISSUES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
EVIDENCED BY THE THIRTY THREE
BILLS SEEKING TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE- DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE
IS STILL IN EQUITY YOU KNOW
ONCE THOSE IN EQUITY HARD DRESS
PERHAPS WE CAN HAVE A BROADER
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE SYSTEM
OF PUBLIC NOTICES- BUT TO BE
FAIR. WHILE I EAT A WHILE MAY
BE BIG- WHAT GOING ANYWHERE
ANYTIME SOON SO THANK YOU. I
WOULD JUST ADD VERY QUICKLY WE
DID HAVE A CONVERSATION- WITH
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL YOU
KNOW WE COULD NOT REACH
AGREEMENT ON ON WHAT WOULD MAKE
SENSE OBVIOUSLY- YOU KNOW WE
ARE CERTAINLY OPEN TO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT LEADING ACLU
ARE OPEN TO THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT. WHAT KIND OF NOTICE
WOULD MEET THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
INDEPENDENCE AND VERIFIABILITY.
HAVING A RECORD OF THAT THAT
NOTED BUT BUT I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT HIS YOU KNOW PROBABLY
ALLOWING ANY KIND OF SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTING OR POSTING ON A
WEBSITE THAT THAT BELONGS TO
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT. AGENCIES
DOES NOT MEET THE- OKAY I'LL
I'LL I'LL BE VOTE NO ON THE
BILL TODAY IN IN THE HOPES
THAT- I COULD CHANGE THAT VOTE
ON THE FLOOR- WITH FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH ACLU IN
THESE PAPERS ASSOCIATION. THANK.
SO IT QUESTIONS POSED TO YOU
EARLIER ABOUT HOW OFTEN THIS
HAPPENS OR OR WHAT THE PROBLEM
THE EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM IS
JUST SIX MONTHS AGO THERE WAS.
TWO TO THREE THOUSAND
COCKFIGHTING ROOSTERS THAT WERE
PICKED UP. AND IN. CITY CHATS
WORKS- FEW YEARS BEFORE THAT
THERE IS A I THINK IT'S THREE
YEARS AGO WAS SEVEN THOUSAND- I
WORKED IN AN AREA WHERE THIS.
TYPE OF ACTIVITY WAS REPORTED
ROUTINE. AND YES POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAD TO GO OUT THERE
AND BREAK GOES UP ANIMAL
CONTROL WOULD COME OUT. AND IN
AND DAY OUT TO SMALLER AGENCY
THAT- WAS THERE AND SO IT IT IS
I THINK IT IS A PROBLEM I'LL BE
VOTING FOR YOUR BILL TODAY-
BECAUSE IT'S A ONE PROBLEM AND
I THINK CAN BE- SALT FROM A
COST PERSPECTIVE. BY BEING A
LITTLE BIT MORE BROAD. AND
USING THE TECHNOLOGY WHICH I
JUST DID- TO FIND SOME OF THE
ANSWERS TO THE QUESTION
EARLIER- BUT DOES. THAT GET AS
AVAILABLE TO US TO REDUCE SOME
OF THESE COSTS FOR THE CITY'S
IT TO THIS IS PERVASIVE AND-
SO. I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU BUT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTER PATTERSON I
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION
FIRST OF ALL UP. MR SANTIAGO
WHO'S BEHIND YOU WAITED C. HAS
A QUESTION. YOU MAY HAVE TO
COME TO A MIGHT SO WE CAN HEAR
YOU. IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE ALL CLOSE TOGETHER.
OKAY WE- OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU
SEE HERE. THE QUICK QUESTIONS
THE WAY AND HOPEFULLY
CONSIDERATIONS MADE FOR DOWN
AYE LOOK I'M GENERAL SUPPORT OF
SOMEONE TO GIVE YOU BETTER DOWN
CONTINUE MOVE FORWARD. BUT
THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE THAT
WILL CONCLUDE ON THE LINE YOU
KNOW L<c.cyan>G FOR A HYBRID SORT</c>
OF MODEL WHERE IT MAKES SENSE
IN SOME COMMUNITIES MAY NOT
HAVE ACCESS- TO- TO THE
INTERNET IS AS COMPARED TO THE
OTHER SIDE FOR ME. MASCHINEN
THE WAITER. WELL AGAIN I MEAN I
IF. I GUESS MY BUT MY SHORT
ANSWER IS I DON'T THINK SO-
THIS DOESN'T SEEM TO ME TO BE A
BIG HIGH HURDLE- TO GET OVER
WITH RESPECT TO THE END PROCESS
HERE. WHICH IS UTILIZING IN A
COST EFFECTIVE WAY. AT MANNER
IN WHICH THIS DISSEMINATING-
THAT THAT'S WIDE A POSSIBILITY.
OF INFORMATION. I THERE NUMBER
NUMBER TWO. THE THIS IS NOT.
APPROACH THIS THIS IS THIS IS.
THE CAN CHOOSE OF A ROW OF WAYS.
BUT IF THEY DID A- A LIMITED
PERHAPS A DEMOGRAPHIC AREA THEY
PICKED UP THE BIRDS UP AND THEY
WANT TO MANAGE. HOW THEY GO
ABOUT MAKING THE NOTIFICATIONS.
SECONDLY I THINK THERE ISN'T AN
INTEREST IN. THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE GOING TO- TO PUBLISH
TO FIND WAYS THAT ARE. NEW- AT
DIFFERENT BUT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO- HAVE IT THE- NOTIFIED OR
OR- SO THAT THEY CAN THAT THEY
CAN HAVE A RECORD THAT IT WAS
IN FACT. A PUBLISHED- THESE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT THESE
OTHER. OPPORTUNITY SUGGEST
WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING THAT THIS
IS A THAT THIS IS A TWEET. BUT
THIS IS A PERMISSIVE EFFORT TO
GO AND FIND AFFORDABLE WAYS. TO
DO THE SAME THING M. I JUST
WOULD COME BACK TO THE- PRICE
TAG OF 800-021-1000 DOLLARS-
FOR ACTIVITY THAT. THERE COULD
BE- DISTRIBUTED IN A IN IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT WAYS YEAH
I GUESS THIS IS ABOUT WHETHER.
WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO TOMORROW
WE'RE GOING TO GOING TO LOOK TO
YESTERDAY. PERMISSIBLE THE WORD
I WAS LOOKING FOR HIS FOR. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WITH WITH THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE MISSED BETTER. I'LL I'LL
I'LL I'LL LET THAT BE MY CLOSE
THIS THIS IS- AN OPPORTUNITY-
THAT IT SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE
THAT IT IS LIMITED IN SCOPE
THIS IS NOT. A REVOLUTIONARY
APPROACH HERE TO. CHANGE ALL OF
THE OTHER NOTIFICATIONS. BUT IT
IS A UNIQUE SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. WHICH HAS
DRAINED RESOURCES AT TO OUR OUR
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTICULARLY SHARES IN THESE
COUNTIES WHERE IT'S A IT'S A
HIGH. ACTIVITY LEVEL GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT THESE- DEPARTMENTS WILL
CHOOSE. AFFORDABLE ALTERNATIVES
TO THIS THAT WILL IN FACT HAVE
THE KIND OF- DISTRIBUTION THAT
YOU CAN CHECK YOU CAN VERIFY
AND GET STATEMENTS OF-
AFFIDAVITS A PERFORMANCE IF YOU
WILL. DO WE GET A NATIONAL OKAY
COLORADO ON AB TWO FIVE THREE
BASED ON THE NUMBER PATTERSON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS JONES
SAWYER NOT JONES SAWYER NOT
VOTING LACKEY LACKEY HI
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD AYE
CORK BY CORK I SAN DIEGO. SAN
DIEGO I SEE R. TWO C. R. TWO I
LICKS NO WICKS NO LI. LI NOW.
THAT MISSION. THE MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU PRESIDENT THAT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT SO
MR STONE YOU IMPATIENTLY
WAITING. FOR YOUR TO. AT. WELL
WE ALWAYS MAKE THE FRESHMAN
RIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ENDS MEMBERS I HAVE A COUPLE OF
BILLS HERE FOR YOU TODAY SO WE
START WITH THE AB TWO NINETY
TWO YES BUT ALREADY THAT AB TWO
NINETY TWO GIVES PEOPLE OUR
CARS FOR THE CHANCE TO
PRIORITIZE THEIR OWN
REHABILITATION AND REENTRY AND
GIVE THEM THE TOOLS TO WORK
TOWARDS THEIR OWN RELEASE.
THANK YOU. THE BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT CONSISTENCY PROGRAMMING
IN INSURING THAT JUST BECAUSE
SOMEONE IS BEING POTENTIALLY
TRANSFERRED THAT THAT WON'T
INTERFERE WITH THEIR
PROGRAMMING. FOR WILL DELAY
THAT TRANSFER TO ALLOW SOMEONE
TO BE ABLE TO FINISH THE
PROGRAM WE KNOW THE PROGRAMMING
WORKS. WITH OTHER PROGRAMMING
REDUCES RECIDIVISM THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT STEP IN
PROVIDING SOME CONTINUITY IN A
COVERT. TIME BUT ALSO AFTER A
COUPLE OF TIMES I ASKED HERE I
HAVE A- TODAY ON AB TWO NINETY
TWO. SO YOU HAVE A JAMES KING-
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
ON THE PHONE. YES GOT FIVE
MINUTES. GO FOR IT THANK. I
NUMBER MYSELF WELL I GRADING
LEGISLATION WITH THE NUMBERS ON
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
CONSIDERING THE BILL I ALSO
COULD PROGRAMMING ACT WILL BE
VERY COLD RUNNING FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN
CALIFORNIA PAY PRESENT ALL. ALL
CREDIT ARMENIANS MERIT. BASED
ON THE CONDITION. I THANK I
CARD OKAY AS COULD BAKER OF THE
RIGHTS. ALONE WHICH I READ WITH
INCARCERATED. OFTEN COME
HEALTHY I RESOURCE. WILL BE
INTRIGUED AT THE BY. ALL FORMS
ENQUIRED. AND EXTREMELY
POSTPONED THE OF. PROGRAM IN
OUR STATE CLEAN HI ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS ARE GOING TO
CORRECTION COMPLETED LOCATION.
MAYBE TRONG BECAUSE BUT STILL
COOPER EACH OF ITS. INSTEAD OF
PEOPLE MAKE USE BE PROUD WE HI
MICHELLE HOWEVER. CURRENTLY BY
THE. AS YOU LIKE TELCO
PROGRAMS- SECURITY ALL THE
CROPS. ONLY TO TRANSFER THE-
MORE GO. I ASKED HER THE
ADVERSE CURRENTLY AT
CONSEQUENCE. TRANSFERRED EVEN I
FIRST GOT MARRIED THREE TO GO
BACK WAITING HOW- ALL YEAR LAW.
AND LYFT SCREEN WILL. THANK IN
THE- ALL HERE AT WAITING ACTED.
SO CALLED. PERSONAL. THANKS
VERY HOW PEOPLE WHO PASSED AWAY
A COUPLE YOU CAN CLOSE HELP ME
NEW PATHWAYS BE A POLITICAL.
YOU ARE SCHOOL BOARD BECAUSE BY
POLITICAL. THE PROGRAM. HELLO
ALSO IT'S NOT BUT THE PARTY WE
HAVE MANY OF THE THAT PEOPLE
ARE HI. YOUR CREDIT ON YOUR
BILL IS PAID ABOUT GO INTO WORK
AT DAY OUR JOB SKILLS JOB.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE ARE JOB.
YOU HAD I STEPS. TO PUT. SURE
HERE'S- HI PROGRAMS COMBINED
HOPE. YOU'LL MEET WITH YOUR CAT.
HELLO BE CLEAR. WHAT WE ARE AT
REQUIRED TO HELPING UNDER YOUR
BEST. THANK IN YOUR WITH THE
ALBUM BELIEVED BILLION I'M YOU
NEED I'LL CALL. OKAY YOU CAN
PEOPLE CHANGE THEIR- NO WAY OUT.
BEFORE ONE EXAMPLE WOULD BE THE
PEOPLE INTO YOUR WHO WORK IN
CONTRACT. BECAUSE WE THINK WE
PRESIDENT OF THE MANY THINGS
INCLUDED OF. HOLDEN NINETY
CALLS. AND W. I'LL CALL THE
PERSON LOCAL BACK. ONE I
REMEMBER A FEW MONTHS AGO.
FIRST START. YEAH I GOT DOWN IN
THE CURRENT HEALTHCARE MEDICAL.
WELCOME NOT TELLS ME. WHO
PERSONALLY HEARD CHANGING.
FURTHER DAMAGE TO A LOT. YEAH
VERY MUCH ABOUT ACCESS CODE
ALSO VERY MUCH ABOUT WHAT YOU
BE. THIRTY SIX. ARE WE ABILITY
H. THE ONLY. I'M FROM. ABOUT
HOW WE TREAT OTHER BEINGS. I
WAS WHO WOULD BE DIRECTLY
IMPACT BY THE LEGISLATURE. OR
AT. THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN AND INSIDE
ANY WITNESS IN PORT ON SUPPORT
AND TELECONFERENCING. AT
EIGHTEEN T. PHONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OKAY ARE
IN SUPPORT IT IS ONE AND THEN
GROW AND WE HAVE LINE IS THE
ONE AND NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BYE NUMBER
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CANACCORD ARE NOT ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE TO DISCUSS PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER TWO FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE COULD
HAVE THE ADS OUTSIDE ORGANIZER
FREE YOU SEE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. EIGHT ZERO HOTLINE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE AT DOCTOR
OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
ONE BUT- GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS PREFERRED TO TALK ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ANTHONY MARTINO ON
THE APPLE CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IMPROPER
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARCO JOINING THEM BANG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND ART THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER ONE OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS GREGORY
SET OUT WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
PROUD CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT- IF I ALSO MAY EXPRESS
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF MY FELLOW
CO SPONSORS- BE TRANSFORMATIVE
IMPRISONED WORKGROUP- AND
RESTORE JUSTICE AND AS WELL AS
VOICE SUPPORT FOR SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BYE NUMBER TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. OKAY
YEAH THE CALIFORNIA I DO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND THE LAST
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
SH YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TERMS TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NOW WILL HAVE. COMMENTS FROM
OPPOSITION. LABOUR CDA AND
JONATHON FELDMAN CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
TERMINA MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
AB TWO NINE TWO OR LESS AMENDED
THE BILL WOULD INCREASE STATE
PRISON CON BUT IT'S FOR VIOLENT
OFFENDERS AND FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS SENTENCED PURSUANT TO
THE THREE STRIKES LAW EVEN IF
THEY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FITZ
PARTICIPATE. IN PRISON
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS SUCH AS
PART YEAH WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO
THE PARTS OF THE BILL THAT
WOULD LESSEN DISRUPTIONS IN
STATE PRISON PROGRAMMING AND
CREDITS INCREASINGLY CREDITS
FOR INMATES WERE NOT PHYSICALLY
BETTER ABLE BODIED AND
THEREFORE CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN
FIREFIGHTING TRAINING DESTROYS
PROPORTIONALITY IRONICALLY THE
PROPOSED CREDIT INCREASE
CREATES A DISINCENTIVE FOR
INMATES TO PARTICIPATE IN
FIREFIGHTING TRAINING AT THE
TIME AND HAVE A CALIFORNIA
DESPERATELY NEED THEIR
SERVICES. TO THE CONTINUED
RAVAGES OF OUR DEADLY WILDFIRES
REGULATIONS PROMULGATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AFTER PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN
WAS APPROVED BY VOTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ALREADY
PROVIDE GENEROUS CONDUCT CREDIT
WITH STATE PRISON INMATE AFTER
ABOUT FIFTY SEVEN THEY NOW EARN
TWENTY PERCENT. INMATES SERVING
SENTENCES PUTS SO THE THREE
STRIKES LAW NOW EARN THIRTY
THREE POINT 3% CONDUCT CREDITS
AND THOSE INMATES SERVING
SENTENCES FOR NON SERIOUS
NONVIOLENT FELONIES EARN 50%
CREDIT AN INMATE SERVING A TERM
FOR A VIOLENT FELONY-
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETES
FIREFIGHTER TRAINING EARNS 50%
CREDIT. AN INMATE WOULD
OTHERWISE CURRENTLY QUALIFIED
WITH A 50% CREDITS EARNED SIXTY
SIX POINT 6% CREDIT UPON
SUCCESSFUL CONFLICT OF
FIREFIGHTER TRAINING AS WE READ
THE BILL IT WOULD MAKE THESE
CREDITS AVAILABLE TO INMATES
WHO DO NOT PARTICIPATE IN PARK.
WIDE AND WITH IT IT MAKES YOU
FEEL IN. DANGER HIMSELF WITH
THE SAME CREDIT CAN BE AN
INCOME IN PRESENT GROW. CDA
CONTENDER IS THAT FALL TO MY
THE ARE. THIS. YEAH SURE
MEMBERS- GOOD EVENING IT'S
GETTING LATE SO I'LL BE BRIEF-
pCOLLEAGUE- THE CDA- YOU KNOW
THESE CREDITS WERE JUST
ADJUSTED AFTER PROP FIFTY SEVEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE THEY WERE
JUST INCREASED PROPORTIONALLY
ALL CATEGORIES OF OFFENDERS-
ANOTHER CONCERN WITH BUMPING
THE CREDITS UP- SO DRAMATICALLY
PROVIDING OFFENDERS IS THAT.
THESE ARE SOME OF THOSE HEINOUS
CRIMES AND SOMETIMES IT TAKES
TIME INCARCERATED AND
PROGRAMMING IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW SOMEONE IS
PUT FULLY REHABILITATED BEFORE
I WE CAN LOOK AT GRANTED
CONTROL. OF PROBATION OR SEND
THEM- I'VE GOTTEN TO ASSIST. SO
WE HAVE SOME CONCERN WITH
RAMPING UP THE CREDITS- SO
SIGNIFICANTLY. FOR THOSE
CATEGORIES OUTLINED. IN THE
BILL. HOWEVER WE DO FIND MANY
OF THE COMPONENTS OF THE BILL
THE BILL VERY COMMENDABLE- AND-
YOU KNOW. BY NO MEANS HAVE
CONCERNS WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
BUT- WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE
BILL I'M JUST BASICALLY THOSE
SECTIONS. SO WE ARE OPPOSED
THANK. THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN. THE CHAMBER. THAT
ARE NOT POSITION ANY WITNESSES
ON THE- ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING IN OPPOSITION.
AT&T DO YOU HAVE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION. OF THE
BILL. FLORIDA OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN IF. ZERO AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP
THE STRUCTURE. THIRTY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. C. N.
NINE C. IN. ONE GO AHEAD AND A
QUICK QUESTION MR STONE ON
SOMETHING THAT WAS SENT BY THE
OPPOSITION- WHEN INMATES
RECEIVE THESE CREDITS IT MAKES
THEM ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE RIGHT
DOESN'T GRANT THE RELEASE
THAT'S CORRECT SO THEY STILL
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE HEARING
AND BE GRANTED PRO BY THE
PROBOARDS. OPERATION WELL THE
IT IS TAKING TIME OFF OF THEIR
SENTENCE POTENTIALLY SO IT IS
GETTING THEM IDEALLY TO A PRO
BOWL EARLIER BUT IT ALSO MAY
REDUCE. OVERALL THEIR SENSE OF.
WHAT THE REAL ANSWER TO THAT IS
THAT WHEN. PEOPLE ARE CURSORY
DO TAKE THIS PROGRAMMING AND DO
THE WORK WHETHER IT'S FIRE CAMP
FOR OTHER OPPORTUNITIES THEIR
RECIDIVISM RATES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS. SO BY
FINDING WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
PROGRAMMING AND GET PEOPLE
THROUGH. THESE PROCESSES WE'RE
ACTUALLY CREATING. A SAFER
PUBLIC BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE LESS
LIKELY TO RE OFFEND- RECOMMIT
THAT'S THE VALUE OF THE
PROGRAM. RIGHT AND I COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE MOTIVATE
INDIVIDUALS ARE FRUSTRATED TO
DO THE WORK TO BE BETTER
CITIZENS AND- THE SUCCESS ON
THE OUTSIDE IT MAKES OUR
COMMUNITY SAFER. IT INCREASED
IT MAKES FOR BETTER OUTCOMES
AND IT SAVES US MONEY BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT CRUSHING PEOPLE FOR
QUITE AS LONG- BUT I GUESS I
JUST WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR.
IF WE GET THESE CREDITS THEY
SOMEONE IS SENTENCED TO TEN
YEARS AND I THINK IF THEY WERE
THAT A MODEL PRISONER BECAUSE
IN ORDER TO GET A TRUE 50% YOU
WOULD HAVE TO BE A MODEL
PRISONER- SO THEY GET. REDUCED
TO FIVE YEARS IN FIVE YEARS
THERE ARE ELIGIBLE FOR. A
HEARING THEY DON'T JUST WALK
AFTER FIVE YEARS BECAUSE THEY
THESE CREDITS ARE TO MY
MISUNDERSTANDING WELL THE
CREDIT BY EARNING THE CREDITS
YOU CAN BE A REDUCTION. IN THE
SENTENCE ITSELF GOT IT OKAY. SO
THEN THEY COULD YOU WALK THEY
HAVE THE RICH RECORD WITHOUT A
PAROLE HEARING. DOT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY YOU
MAY CLOSE THE SYSTEM I ASKED
FOR AND I WILL. THANK YOU THIS
IS I THINK IN ANOTHER IMPORTANT
STEP INTO- INTO CORRECTIONS AND
IN GETTING PEOPLE OUT WHO ARE.
WHO DESERVE TO BE UP SO HIGH I
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THIS
EFFORT IN. CHAIR RECOMMENDS AN
IBOOK. ON AB TWO NINETY TWO BY
SO MEMBERS DOWN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER IRAQI. OUR QUE HAN
BACKING HAD AYE CORK. AYE QUIRK
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I THINK
OUR TO SEE OUR TONO WICKS. LI
LI I. IMAGE THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS SO
AB FIVE OH THREE IS A BILL THAT
ESTABLISHES STATUTORY GUIDANCE
FOR NONCUSTODIAL WAR CHIP
PROGRAM THANK YOU OF OUR YOUTH
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAPPENS WITH
YOU THINK PROBATION OFTENTIMES
BECAUSE OF WHAT CONNECTIONS
THEY CAN BE A PROBATION FOR TWO
THREE YEARS OR MORE AND YET THE
BIGGEST SUCCESS WE HAVE ISSUES
IS WHEN WE DIVERT THEM FROM
BEING INCARCERATED IN FACT AS
SOON. AS A CHILD. IS
INCARCERATED. IN JUVENILE HALL
OR ANY OTHER. A PROGRAM THEY
ARE AUTOMATICALLY THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO RESET OF IT IS
HARMFUL TO THEM IT IS HARMFUL
TO THEIR FUTURE IT'S HARMFUL TO
THEIR FAMILY SO WHAT AB FIVE OH
THREE IS GOING TO DO IS END THE
SORT OF ENDLESS POTENTIAL CYCLE
OF PROBATION FOR USE AND IT
PROVIDES. A SIX MONTH.
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT KIDS WILL
NOT BE HELD LONGER THAN THE SIX
MONTHS OR BE ON PROBATION
LONGER THAN THE SIX MONTHS
UNLESS THEY ARE REVIEWED. AND
THERE BECOMES THAN A REASON FOR
THEM TO STAY ON LONGER. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THAT IF WITHOUT
THIS REVIEW KIDS ARE
LANGUISHING ON PROBATION. ARE
CONNECTED TO THE COURTS WITH
ALL THE STIGMA. AND THE TRAUMA
AND THE NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT
THAT REPRESENTS SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS GET THEM OFF OF
PROBATION AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
SET REASONABLE PROBATION TERMS
AND ENSURE THAT THESE YOUTHS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE THEN CAUGHT
UP FOREVER IN THESE ENDESS
CYCLES THAT PROBATION OFF THAT
THE PROBATION TERMS CAN OFTEN
REPRESENT. THIS IS ALSO A BILL.
ABOUT RACE IN CALIFORNIA MAKE
NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT. IF YOU
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THAT A-
BLACK OR BROWN YOUTH IS PUT ON
PROBATION AND PUT ON PROBATION
TERMS. SIGNIFICANTLY LONGER AND
SIGNIFICANTLY. MORE RESTRICTIVE
THAT AWAIT YOU. AND THIS IS
REPEATED AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND THE RACIAL DISPARITY
AS WELL AS THE PROCLIVITY OF
SOME. COURTS AND SOME PROBATION
SYSTEMS TO TIE YOU UP FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME IN THE NAME OF
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD
IT IS AN INVESTMENT FOR THE
CHILD IT'S THE SYSTEM
FUNCTIONING FOR THE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE SYSTEM. SO ALL
WE'RE DOING IS CREATING A-
CHANGING THAT THE EXPECTATION
OF HOW LONG A CHILD CAN BE ON
PROBATION UNLESS THERE'S AN
INDICATION FOR LONGER AND WE'VE
HEARD FROM JUDGES WHO DIDN'T
DON'T LIKE THE SIX THE SIX
MONTHS THEY'D RATHER HAVE ITIS
A YEAR. AND IN THEIR WORDS THEY
DON'T SEE THAT KID FOR ANOTHER
YEAR WELL THAT AGAIN IS FOR THE
BENEFIT THE JUDGE NOTFOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE CHILD THAT
ATTITUDE CANNOT BE PERVASIVE
ANY LONGER AS WE'RE DEALING
WITH KIDS ON PROBATION WE NEED
TO GET THEM OUT WE NEED TO GET
THEM BACK. INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH THE SPECTER AND THE
UMBRELLA OF THE PROBATION
SYSTEM WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE. THANK YOU. AND
YOUR WITNESSES. DAPHNA KOZANI
NATIONAL YOUTH LAWCENTER IN
DREI MELGOZA YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER. I HOPE I DIDN'T
BUTCHER THEIR NAMES TO BE. FILE
I'M- VERY TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
SO I WILL TURN IT OVER TO THE
YOUNGER TRADED CENTER. OKAY MY
NAME'S ANALLY VERY YOUNG WOMAN
FREEDOM FIGHTER ON THE POLICY
LIAISON AND PROGRAM MANAGER AND
I'M GOING TO BE READING WHAT
HAPPENED DREAM ALTHOUGH IT'S
NOT. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
JIM AGO THAT I'M A YOUTH
ORGANIZER WITH YOUNG WOMAN
SPEED INTERNET A CO SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY FIVE OH THREE. I AM A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED YOUNG
PERSON WITH THAT MY ENTIRE
TEENAGE YEARS HUNDRED
OPERATIONS. AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN OUR COLLABORATION FOR
NONVIOLENT CHARGE A MISDEMEANOR
WHICH WOULD HAVE ORIGINALLY PUT
ME ON PROBATION SUPERVISION FOR
SIX MONTHS BUT TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS LED ME. TO BE ON
PROBATION FOR SIX YEARS.
PROBATION NEGATIVELY. EVERY OF
MY LIFE. ALL FAMILY FRIENDSHIP
RELATIONSHIP AND MORE.
SOLIDIFICATION CONDITIONS I WAS
GETTING WITH AND WITH. THE FACT
THAT SOME XIN THE SYSTEM HAD
TO. DO TO WHAT I WORE HOW
IDENTIFIES GENDER
NONCONFORMING. WHERE I WAS
RAISED AND HEART WAS RELATED
FEEL. FROM CURFEWS HAVE GREAT
GOALTENDING SO THE COLORS I
WORE THE BRAND'S I WORKED WITH
THE MISSION TO RANCOR TO THE MY
LOAN AND MY POSSESSIONS. PILED
UP THAT THAT ONLY MY FAMILY IN
A DEEPER HOLE. TO THE MANDATED
PROGRAMS I WAS TOLD I HAD TO
DEAL ONLY BECAUSE THE PROGRAMS
ARE ACTUALLY FOR MY NEEDS WORK
FOR. A LIST OF OUR- I'VE BEEN
HERE BIG OUT OF SEVEN DAYS OF
MY FOR. PROGRAM I STRUGGLE. I
NO TIME FOR TO MY FOR AND THIS
DAY COULD BE AS TO HOW WITH THE
TO LEARN SELF. AND INDEPENDENCE
OUR LAW ON A THIRD THAT WOULD
CONCERN ME TO GET ME TO COME TO
WHAT IDEA OF WHAT MIGHT. WITH
BE. I WOULD CALL UNIFY HEALTH
COPING I. YEAH HOLD TOP DOWN
BROWN I CAN MYSELF WITH THEM.
ALL I HAVE LEFT OF MY IMMEDIATE
FAMILY WHICH IS COMPLICATED AYE.
PROBATION BECAUSE THE WEDGE
BETWEEN. THE NUMBER OF TIMES
WAS GONNA HAS THE FOR THE TECH.
KILEY ARE AT LEAST. WITH OUR
STRAINED. THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE
MAINTAINING ANY RELATIONSHIP OF
HOUSE ARREST. WHICH PILED EVEN
MORE DOWN MY FAMILY AND CAUSE
MORE STRESS THAN NEEDED. HOW
WOULD MY MOM AFFECTED A PAGE.
THAT OFF WITH THAT THE DROP ALL
THAT SHE HAD TO ATTEND MEETING.
MANDATED PROGRAM THAT TOOK AWAY
FROM HER WORK. ALMOST STRESSFUL
AND I WAS SO WILLING TO RISK MY
OWN WELL BEING BY OFFERING TO
DO TIME FOR MY PARENTS A HAPPY
BURDENED WITH MORE DEBT TO KEEP
HEALTH. UNTIL THE SYSTEMS THAT
COULD DAMAGE BY ASKING FOR BOTH
MY FREEDOM AND MY PARENTS
MONEY. MY PRIVATE LIFE MY
FAMILY FOR COMPLETELY INVADED.
PROBATION WAS OF THE GOLDEN
TICKET FOR THE SYSTEM TO TAKE
EVERYTHING WE HAVE LACKED.
THERE WERE TIMES MY MOTHER'S ON
PASSING THOMAS WERE BROUGHT UP
ONLY TO BE USED AGAINST THAT.
BUT THEY HAD NO IDEA WHAT IT
TOOK FOR HER TO GET OVER IT FOR
THE RETIREMENT AVIATION THAT
OCCURRED WITHIN THE PROOF I
NEED THE PARKING WAS FAILED TO
PROVIDE. I. COULDN'T EVEN FEEL
SAFE AT SCHOOL. MY PO MEETING.
THEY WERE THERE WHAT WHO. WHEN
THEY WERE THERE FOR AND WHAT
THEY WERE FOR. I CAN RECALL
TIME I WAS IN. AND FOR THE FACT.
I WORK EARLY. BE A LOT THREE
TIMES USE OUR PHONE. AND SAID I
TO WRITE A LETTER ENCOURAGE.
LOVED ONE WHEN THE TEACHER WALK.
AND WHAT I WAS. SHE AND IN
FRONT OF THE- CLASS SAID IS
THAT. YOU BE RIGHT IT IN THE
FALL INTO. LAST I. ARE YOU A TO
LEAVE HIM. THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE WAY THE I WOULD
TARGET BY THE FOREIGN MINISTRY.
DO PROBATE AND THE CAN. THAT
ALLOW THEM TO BE IN. EVERY.
ASPECT OF MY LIFE- IN MY
CONFIRMATION I. TOLD THESE CAN
BE. WERE TO. ME PUT ME BACK. ON
TRACK. HOWEVER I COULD HAVE
BEEN. A WITH. OF PENDING. TO
DEAL. IF I DID. EIGHT THE ONLY
KNOWLEDGE. I GOT WITH. THE YOU
THAT ACTUALLY. COOPER AND NOT.
EIGHT SIX. THAT I. SHOULD HAVE.
ABLE TO. BRING I HEARD YOU TO
PASS. BY WITH. DENTURE THAT YOU
FOR. ABLE TO. INTO FOCUS.
WITHOUT BECOMING INSTITUTION.
AND HAVING TO RELY ON. OTHERS
TO MAKE DECISIONS FOR THEM
WITHOUT LISTENING TO THEM
CONSIDERING THE ACTUAL. YOUNG
PEOPLE DO NOT DESERVE TO BE
TREATED LIKE CRIMINALS. BUT IS
THERE TO BE EMPOWERED AND GIVEN
APPROPRIATE SUPPORT WITH EXTRA
MERIT WITHOUT EXTRA BARRIERS.
THE CURRENT POLICIES HAVE
ALLOWED THOUSANDS OF YOU TO BE
HARMED BY DECEMBER. THE FED TO
SUPPORT THEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IT AND THAT WAS IT OKAY
THANK YOU- ANY. ANYBODY HERE IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT ANYONE LINE
ON VIDEO CONFERENCING IN IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTEEN T. PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE. WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE A PUBLIC COMING FROM
IS COMING FROM THE LINE UP TO
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS
CORRECT THOUGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES INSTRUCT THE
COURT THANK YOU THANK YOU. THEN
THE NEXT LINE IS TWO SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
TURN MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER
FROM NIELSEN LOOKS MORE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SURE MIKE THAT
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE AT NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING REBEKAH
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NOT DECIDE RULING ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES PROBATION
OFFICER UNION ASK MEDICAL SIXTY
FIVE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR WE HAVE ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ANGELIQUE EVAN WITH THE YOUNGER
FRIEDMAN CENTER AND IN AN
EFFORT TO EX BUT I BELIEVE WE
HAVE COMPILED A LIST FOR EIGHTY
FIVE WILL CARRY START DO I HAVE
YOUR PERMISSION SURE. GO AHEAD.
OKAY THANK YOU- OFF ALTERNATE
PUBLIC DEFENDER LOS ANGELES.
ARCHERY ONLY INJECTED NETWORK A
NEW UNIFIED FILTER BLACK GIRL
MAGIC. BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES A SPLEEN HAS.
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY DRAFT IS.
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET. CAPITAL OF
LOS ANGELES CHILDREN DOWN
CHILDREN VICTIMS ONE TALENT FOR
YOUNG BLACK OF ST JOHN. DR MY
ANGELO COMMUNITY HIGH SCHOOL
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER
AS WHAT CENTER FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS HARTNELL COLLEGE
STUDENT GOVERNMENT HELPING
EMPOWER YOU FOR BETTER LIVING.
HOLDEN CULTURE- BOB. ILLEGAL
ARE YOU PROGRAMS JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU JUSTICE LA
JBS VOEPEL KERN COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE LOS ANGELES
ALLIANCE FOR A NEW ECONOMY
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN. MICHAEL MAKING
FAMILIES MODERATE IS OF
BENEFITS COUNTY. THE NATIONAL
ACTION NETWORK LA NATIONAL
JUVENILE NETWORK OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH JDA THREE
CALCULATE THE VOLCANO. PUBLIC
CANCEL QUALITY MATTERS MODERATE
COUNTY THE MIGHT DETER. LONG
BEACH YEAH JUSTICE INITIATED
AND U. S. T. DAVID. THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM. UNDERGROUND
GREAT REPEAT INSTITUTE. YOUNG
WOMEN FRIEDMAN CENTER. JUSTICE
COALITION LA COMMUNITY FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE HEY WERE
BURNED AND KILLED HE THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS OF UNICOLOR
CHRISTIAN BAKERS JUVENILE
DETENTION- I'M WITH YOUR
PERMISSION AND READ OFTEN
INDIVIDUAL. I'M GOING TO ALLOW
GUARDED. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU I HAN DROPPED BY NINE. YOU
CALLED ME BACK OKAY I'LL HAVE A
LINE CAROLINE NIGHTSTAND
CAROLINGIAN PARK. ON A COLD
BOTH YOUR- THE ONLY A DAVID
TOLD ALL. KARINA DEL TORY.
ERICA PATTERSON HE NEEDS TO
KILL MORE JESSICA WALLY WALKER
THE YOUNG REPORTER JUANITA ADAM
JULIA PENA PLEASE WHILE CHILE'S
CERRO ORTEGA'S INTERNATIONAL
CAL YOUNG LUCAS JOHNSON WILLIS
A RADIO LISTENER HOW. AND IT'S
AFTERMARKET. THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU. THE NEXT LINE IS ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT
SURE HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF C.
H. CHEN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN
LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION REPORT
THANK YOU MISTER GEORGE. AND WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD ARE
NOT ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPUS
DISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
IN SUPPORT. THE LAST COMMENT
COMES FROM A LINE OF ONE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHEN NUMBERS GREGORY
PELOPONNESIAN JUST INSTRUCTED
PORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
NOW. IN OPPOSITION- OUR GOOD
FRIEND AND STAR OF THE DAY
LARRY MORSE CD A. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I HARDLY
FEEL THAT WAY BUT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB FIVE OH
THREE UNLESS IT IS AMENDED TO
ELIMINATE OR A MAN PROPOSED
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTION SIX OH TWO POINT ZERO
FIVE WHICH WOULD LIMIT TO SIX
MONTHS. OF PROBATION PERIOD IN
A JOB CASE NO MATTER HOW
SERIOUS OR VIOLENT A JUVENILE
CRIMINAL HISTORY IS THIS IS A
SWEEPING AND TROUBLING PROPOSAL
WHICH CONTAINS NO DISQUALIFYING
CRIMES AS WE READ THE BILL. IF
ENACTED A MINOR ON PROBATION
FOR MURDER SEXUAL ASSAULT ARMED
ROBBERY GANG SHOOTINGS OR
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER WOULD BE
TREATED THE SAME AS A MINOR ON
PROBATION FOR PETTY THEFT OR
ASSAULT. JUDGES SHOULD HAVE THE
SPECS WHAT THE BILITY
INDISCRETION TO TAILOR
SENTENCES AND PROBATION PERIODS
THAT ARE APPROPRIATE FOR EACH
JUVENILE OFFENDER A BLANKET SIX
MONTH PROBATION PERIOD
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE CRIME
CIRCUMSTANCE. SENATE DESTRY OF
THE JUVENILE OFFENDER WILL NOT
ADVANCE THROUGH CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM SIX MONTHS IS
FAR TOO SHORT A PERIOD TO
ENSURE THE REHABILITATION OF
KERR'S FOR THE CRIME VICTIMS
ARE PROTECTED. THE BILL PERMITS
EXTENSION OF THE SIX MONTH
PERIOD ONLY IF IT IS IN THE
MINORS BEST INTEREST GLARINGLY
ABSENT FROM THE BILL LANGUAGE
IS ANY CONSIDERATION OF PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR CRIME VICTIMS
INTEREST OR SAFETY. PROBATION
IS NOT PUNISHMENT TO THE
CONTRARY COURTS TO RULE THE
PROBATION IS AN ACT OF CLEMENCY
AND GRACE JUDGESCANNOT SIMPLY
IMPOSE ANY AND ALL PROBATION
CONDITIONS THE ESTABLISHED TEST
IS WHETHER THE PARTICULAR
PROBATION CONDITION IS BALLOT.
AND RELATES TO THE CRIME
COMMITTED TO CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
ITSELF OR TO THE PROBATIONERS
FUTURE CRIMINALITY SIX MONTHS
IS INADEQUATE TO ENSURE THE
REHABILITATION THE KURDS OR THE
CRIME VICTIMS ARE PROTECTED. IT
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE IN MANY.
CASES FOR A MINOR TO
PARTICIPATE IN MEANING RESULTS.
PROGRAM OR TO REPAY UP. OF THE
REST OF OWED A CRIME VICTIM.
EVEN MORE TROUBLING. TO MANY
CASES INVOLVING ASSAULTS B
JUVENILES NECESSARILY INCLUDE
PROBATION CONDITIONS THAT
REQUIRE THE OFFENDER TO STAY
AWAY FROM THE VICTIM. AGAIN AS
WE READ THE BILL GOES
PROTECTIONS WOULD DISAPPEAR
AFTER SIX MONTHS. THE INTERESTS
OF THE VICTIMS OF CRIME ARE NOT
PART OF THIS BILL'S QUESTION.
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST
THAT IF THERE IS TO BE AT THE
FALL PERIOD OF PROBATION IT
SHOULD BE FOR AT LEAST TWO
YEARS AND SHOULD NOT APPLY IN
CASES WHERE A MINOR IS
COMMITTED A SERIOUS FELONY. A
VIOLENT FELONY OR ANY OFFENSE
LISTED AND WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE SEVEN OH
SEVEN B. MOREOVER A JUDGE
SHOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY IN
EVERY CASE TO IMPOSE A
PROBATION PERIOD OF LONGER THAN
TWO YEARS BY STATING SE
REASONS ON THE RECORD. AND THE
STANDARD SHOULD CONSIDER MORE
THAN JUST WHAT IS IN THE MINORS
BEST INTEREST PUBLIC SAFETY AND
THE INTERESTS AND SAFETY OF
CRIME VICTIMS MUST BE FACTORS A
COURT IN THE WAY. OF PROVISIONS
THAT IS ABSENT FROM THIS BILL.
CDA BELIEVES THAT MEANINGFUL
REHABILITATION IS THE
CORNERSTONE OF OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. PROSECUTORS
FORCE MORE DISTINCT US THIS AND
THE SAFETY OF THE COMMUNITY IS
ARE THEY REPRESENT HAVE THE
GREATEST INTEREST IN ENSURING
THAT EVERYTHING POSSIBLE IS
DONE TO PREVENT JUVENILE
OFFENDERS. FROM BECOMING ADULT
OFFENDERS THAT GOAL IS BEST
ACHIEVED WITH CREATIVE AND
RESPONSIVE REHABILITATION
PROGRAM AND IMPLEMENTED DURING
A REALISTIC TIME FRAME WITH
JUDGES ALLOWED TO BALANCE AND
RECONCILE THE WELFARE OF THE
JUVENILE OFFENDERS. THE
INTEREST OF CRIME VICTIMS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. WE RESPECTFULLY OUTWARD
NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU MOORE. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESS ENOUGH
IS. AND SO THE ROOM. A. N. D
VIDEO CONFERENCING. AT&T WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES DO YOU
HAVE ANY THEIR IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. HAPPY ADDITION IS ONE
ADVANTAGE ZERO. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE QUEUING UP FOR
OPPOSITION AS OF RIGHT NOW.
OKAY THEN QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. C. EIGHTY
NINE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
REALIZE THIS IS FOR NON
CUSTODIAL WARSHIP PROBATION AND
THE FULL LENGTH OF TIME IS
REALLY VERY IMPORTANT AS OR
THEIR CONDITIONS BECAUSE YOU
THERE SOMETIMES SUBTLE WITH UP
TO FIFTY CONDITIONS ARE THEY
GOING TO VIOLATE THOSE SOMEBODY
TEENAGER PROBABLY WITHOUT
INTENSE. BUT THAT CAN THEN LEAD
THEM TO BE INCARCERATED THAT
CAN LEAD TO SORT OF ENDLESS
CYCLES OF PROBATION THIS IS
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
VENT IN THIS CASE BECAUSE
REHABILITATION ESPECIALLY OF
OUR YOUTH IS GIVING THEM A
CHANCE TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
BEING LOCKED DOWN. UNDER
PROBATION TERMS THAT THEY FIND
VERY IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET. JUST%
BECAUSE SOMEBODY IN A VERY
PATERNALISTIC MANNER WANTS TO
IMPOSE ON THEM IS REALLY NOT
THE PATH TO SUCCESS THE PATH TO
SUCCESS IS A LIMITED TIME LINE
A REVIEW OF THAT SITUATION AND
IF THAT CHILD NEEDS MORE
SERVICES THAN THAT CHILD WILL
GET MORE SERVICES AND THAT CAN
EXTEND. THE TIME INFORMATION
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE I APPRECIATE
THIS AND I WILL ALSO SAY THAT
WERE WORKING PRETTY CLOSELY
WITH THE POP THE PROBATION
CHIEFS. WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THIS BUT- UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND DON'T
DISAGREE. THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
ARE DEALING WITH THESE KIDS ON
A DAY TO DAY BASIS AND WHAT I
WANT TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS WORKABLE THE
PROBATION CHIEFS UNDERSTAND.
AND THAT THE COMMUNITIES WERE
WORKING WITH ALSO UNDERSTAND IN
WAYS THAT CAN LEAD TO SUCCESS
FOR THE CHILDREN THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW AS WE'RE REFORMING.
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
MOVING IT INTO THE HUMAN
SERVICES BROWN THIS IS PART IN
PARCEL TO THAT KIND OF A MOVE
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT. IGHT NOW AND I ASK
FOR YOUR HUSBAND'S. THANK YOU-
READ SIX. WE GOT A FIRST AND
SECOND MESSICK CALLED. ON
pMEMBERS STAND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER. A LACKEY. OUR QUE HAN
THANK YOU HIM HI CORK. CORK I
SAN DIEGO SANTIAGO I SEE- TO
SEE OUR TURNOUT WICKS HI WICKS
HI LI LI I. THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU BOB THIS IS
ERICA UDEN EUROPE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. TESTED IS
THE DISADVANTAGE TO BE HONEST
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE TO GO AFTER
THE BODY OF. SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FOR
HEARING AB FOUR NINE THIS
EVENING. THANK YOU ISRAEL IS A
SIMPLE ADDITION TO THE PENAL
CODE TO ENSURE VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES OF GAIN CRIMES REMAIN
SAFE. THE BILL ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE VICTIMS OR
WITNESSES OF GAME CRIMES TO
BRING EVIDENCE OF A THREAT TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN ORDER TO
HAVE THEIR NAMES REMOVED FROM
PUBLIC RECORDS. IN A RECENT
PAYMENTS STUDY NEARLY 40% OF
PARTICIPANTS LISTED FEAR
RETALIATION AS A REASON THEY
WERE NOT REPORTED CRIME. FOR
PROVIDE INFORMATION THEY KNOW
ABOUT A CRIME. WE KNOW THAT
COULD GAIN CRIMES ARE NOTORIOUS
FOR RETALIATION EFFORTS IN ARE
OFTEN DIFFICULT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO SOLVE AND I KNOW
THIS FIRST HAND. BY OFFERING
THIS COMMUNITY ARE BY OFFERING
THE COMMUNITY THIS SIMPLE
PROTECTION WE CAN HELP FOSTER
COOPERATION BETWEEN ITS
MEMBERS. AND OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AB FOUR NINE DOES
NOT PLACE ANY EXTRA BURDENS OR
NEW PROCEDURES ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT. EMPLOYEES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO INFORM VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULTS THAT THEIR
NAMES WILL BECOME PUBLIC RECORD
UNLESS OTHERWISE REQUESTED AND
THIS BILL FOLLOWS THE SAME
BASIC PROCEDURE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION I'D LIKE TO
PASS IT OVER TO RYAN SHERMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION WHO IS HERE TO SHOW
THEIR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IF
YOU MISTER MEMBERS BRIAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
COALITION SCHOOL SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS. THE LOS ANGELES
SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF THE PALACE
VERDES AT SANTA ANA POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. HE SAID
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENT SOUTH
BEACH DEDICATED CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS FOR PLEASED TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR NINE BILLS
SEEK TO IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES. OF GANG
CRIMES. THE COOLEY AB FOUR NINE
WOULD ALLOW THE VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES OF GANG CRIMES TO
PETITION LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PROTECT THEIR IDENTITIES
PURSUANT TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. YES THEY
FEEL THEIR LIFE COULD BE IN
SERIOUS DANGER BECAUSE OF THEIR
REPORTING INFORMATION RELATED
TO A GANG CRIME. AS THE AUTHORS
POINT OUT CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO INFORM
VICTIMS OF SEX OFFENSES BUT THE
RIGHT TO REQUEST WITH THEIR
NAME DOES NOT BECOME A MATTER
OF PUBLIC RECORD. HOWEVER THERE
IS NO SIMILAR PROTECTION FOR
WITNESSES OR VICTIMS REPORTING
ANY OTHER CRIMES. AB FOUR NINE
THIS COMMONSENSE MEASURE THAT
WILL IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY BY
PROTECTING WITNESSES AND
VICTIMS ARE WILLING TO COME
FORWARD AND REPORT CRIMINAL
GANG ACTIVITY. THE BILL ALSO
HELP REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
RETALIATION FROM THESE
DANGEROUS GANGS. PLEASE
REASONS. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FOUR NINE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU UNDER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES. IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANY ON THE- ON
THE VIDEO CONFERENCING. AND
AT&T HOW MANY DO WE HAVE ON. IT
SUPPORT READY TO TEST BY. IF
YOU AREN'T A PART IT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AND WE HAVE A WAR ON
THE LINE QUEUING UP IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. IT COMES FROM
THE LINE OF THE TWO EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES SIR MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS LARRY
MORSE YET AGAIN- ON SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO OTHER FIVE IN Q. AND
THEN. TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE NOT CO HERNANDEZ C. A. C.
J. MISTER HERNANDEZ IN
OPPOSITION. HERE I DO NOT SHOW
MISTER ON THE LINE I'M NOT SURE.
WE'LL GO TO AUDIENCE IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NONE GOING TO-
THE VIDEO CONFERENCING CNN AND
THEN MAYBE YOU CAN OPEN UP A
LINE FOR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
WE CAN HEAR THAT IN MAYBE
MISTER HERNANDEZ SO GET BACK TO
US IN. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION AND IT IS MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE TEACHER MEMBERS ARE NOT
CERTAIN AND IS ON BEHALF OF C.
AND J. IN OPPOSITION ISLAND I
AM HERE- JUST BRIEFLY- YOU KNOW.
OUR CONCERN IS THE WAY THE BILL
IS DRAFTED IS THAT IT IS
ACTUALLY NOT TO BE ALLEGED
VICTIM OF A GANG RELATED A
CHANCE THAT INITIATES THE
REQUEST TO KEEP HIS OR HER
NAME- OUT OF THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST. INSTEAD IT IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT MUST INITIATE
THEN ASK SOMEONE. ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT THEIR NAME BE
ACTED ON OR CONCERNS THAT THERE
COULD BE SITUATIONS ESPECIALLY
AN ALLEGED GANG RELATED CASES
MORE THAN SO MANY PROBLEMS WITH
INDIVIDUALS THE MESS IDENTIFIED
AS BEING MEMBERS OF THE GANG AT
POINT OF AROUND- THAT
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE ASKED. LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL SAY HEY YOUR
NAME CAN BE PUBLIC UNLESS YOU
SAY THAT YOU FELT THREATENED.
ARE YOU STILL AT YOU'RE NOT
SAFE AND WE FEEL THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE THERE WILL BE A
HANDFUL OF INDIVIDUALS A
PERCENTAGE OF ANIMALS WHO ARE
GOING TO RESPOND IN THE
AFFIRMATIVE EVEN IF THEY ARE
NOT CONCERNED SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY- WANT THEIR NAME. ARE THEY
DON'T WANT ANY PUBLIC AUTHORITY
OF REASONS- AND SO THE CONCERN
IS THAT WHAT HAPPENS TO THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A
PROBLEM WITH INDIVIDUALS BEING
MISIDENTIFIED AS GANG MEMBERS
THE CONCERN WOULD BE THAT IN A
CASE GOING FORWARD. THE
STATEMENT THAT THE ALLEGED
VICTIM CLAIMED IT HERE SHE
FEARED FOR HER SAFETY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE AFFIRMATIVE AT
ASK REQUEST OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER COULD BE
USED AGAINST THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS ARRESTED AD SO I THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
ASSURANCES THAT IT WON'T BE-
AND I THINK WE NEED TO. BE
CLARIFIED THAT IF IT'S AT THE
REQUEST OF THE INDIVIDUAL. AS
OPPOSED TO REQUIRING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ASK SOMEONE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY FEAR FOR
THE LIVES OF WHETHER OR NOT
TELLING THEM YOUR NAME WILL GO
PUBLIC AND LESS YOU TELL ME.
THAT YOU CALL FOR YOUR LIFE I
WOULD JUST THINK IT CREATES A
LOT OF PROBLEMS BECAUSE THIS IS
KIND OF A VERY UNIQUE TYPE OF
CRIME IT AS FAR AS THE
MISAPPLICATION OF GANG IDENTITY
IN SO MANY CASES. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE. CONCERNED A
COUPLE OF OTHER REASONS BUT I
PRIMARILY. THANK YOU MISTER
HERNANDEZ. I BELIEVE IT- NUMBER
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY.
MISTER JUST LIKE WHICH WE CAN.
NO ARE JUST LIKE TO SPEAK IN OF
THE BILL- IF I WERE YOU A
SITUATION- WITH LAUNCH I WOULD
HAVE NO IDEA. OF WHETHER OR NOT
MY NAME WOULD BE PUBLISHED I
MIGHT EVEN ASSUME THAT IT'S
KEPT PRIVATE. SO LETTING
SOMEONE KNOW SO THEY CAN MAKE
THE CASE. TO ME IS AN IMPORTANT
PROTECTION SO THANK YOU FOR
THIS BILL. THIS WAY. JUST ON
THE LETTER THAT OPPOSITION HAD-
SUBMITTED- THEY SAID EXISTING
LAW ALREADY ALLOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE WHOLE THE
DIS CLOSURE OF INFORMATION THAT
WOULD ENDANGER PERSON INVOLVED
IN THE INVESTIGATION. SO IT IS
IT TRUE THAT EXISTING LAW WOULD
ALREADY ALLOW FOR THIS. A LOT
OF A LOT OF LONG FOR. YES THIS
IS THE THIRD THING- WHAT. GO TO
IT TO DO IT AND ALLOW VICTIMS
AND WITNESS. TO PROVIDE
PARTICULARLY BRAND TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO IT IS MORE
PROACTIVE ON THE WITNESS OR
VICTIM WHO MAY KNOW THAT THERE
IS A THREAT TO NOTIFY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT GET LEFT
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT OKAY GO
DOWN. YEAH CAN THEY DO THAT NOW
THEY'LL- VICTIMS NOT ADVOCATE
ALONG CEMENT FOR NAME TO BE.
NOW THAT'S WHY THAT'S ONE OF
THE THAT ONE OF THE THAT A FOUR
NINETY TO HELP- PROTECT
THEMSELVES. IS AN SORRY IS IT
NOT SURE YOU SAW ON CAN YOU
RESPOND TO THAT. YES ON DOWN
THE LINE MY UNDERSTANDING THE
WAY THIS BILL IS CRAFTED. IT
SAYS YES- I THINK I BELIEVE IT
IS A PERMANENTLY REQUIRES LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ASK VICTIMS. IF
THEY ARE TO TELL THE VICTIM THE
CANONICAL PUBLIC UNLESS STATE
FAIR FEARFUL AND THAT TO
ACTUALLY GO THE OTHER WAY IT IS
INSTEAD OF GRANTS THE VICTIM.
SURVIVED TO TELL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF THE CAN CAN
CALDERON PERSON NOW SO I READ
IT DIFFERENTLY IF I'M READING
IT CORRECTLY AND HAPPY TO BE
CORRECTED BUT THAT. IS MY READ
OF IT- I'M LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
LOOK FOR THE WORDS ARTICULABLE
THREAT DESPITE. THANK YOU. YEAH
I WOULD SAY SHALL INFORM THE
VICTIMS AND THAT THAT'S ONE
THING IT'S AN AFFIRMATIVE DUTY
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT TO TELL THE
VICTIM THAT HEY YOU'RE YOUR
NAME COULD GO PUBLIC UNDER A
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST IT
IS ALSO USED UNDER THE SKINNER
BILL SO THAT'S THE OTHER ISSUE
GO OUT BUT NOT NOT IN THE
SUBDIVISION A OF TWENTY SIX
POINT THREE SEVEN WHICH IS
ADDED BY THIS BILL. OKAY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. YOU MAY CLOSE
HI I JUST- RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE AYE VOTE ON THIS THANK
YOU OKAY STICK TO A CALL THE
ROLL. AN EIGHTY FOUR OH NINE BY
SOME MEMBERS C. R. TO THE
MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. GENSER I LACKEY LACKEY
HI BARRICADE CAN GUARANTEE
HANNAH I WORK I WORK HI
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I SEE ARE
TO. THEY ARE TO I LICKS. WEEKS
NOT VOTING LEAVE. WE THE
MEASURE PASSES. AND FOR FINAL
BILL. ASSEMBLY WOMAN BUFFY
WICKS. THE SUN YEAH OKAY TO
MAKE THIS QUICK THANK YOU AT
SHERRIN COMMITTEE STAFFER YOU
WORK ON THIS BILL I'D ALSO LIKE
TO AMEND THE BILL TO INCLUDE
DECEMBER SANTIAGO IS A CO
AUTHOR WHO EXPRESSED INTEREST
TO MY STAFF ON THIS. CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES JUDGES TO IMPOSE A
SENTENCE FOR THE OFFENSE CARING
THE LONGEST POTENTIAL TERM OF
IMPRISONMENT WHEN A DEFENDANT
IS ACCUSED. OF MULTIPLE
OFFENSES DURING A SINGLE ACTS.
THIS TOUGH ON CRIME ERA POLICY.
REMOVED THE DISCRETION THAT
JUDGES PREVIOUSLY HAD TO CHARGE
THE DEFENDANT. WITH THE
SENTENCE DEEMED MOST
APPROPRIATE. CONTINUING TO PUT
PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR THE LONGEST
AMOUNT OF TIME REGARDLESS OF
THE CONTEXT OF THE CRIME. AND
HISTORY OF THE OFFENDER DOES
NOT RESULT OF THE PERSON. OR
GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO BE BETTER
IN THE FUTURE. OVER THE LAST
DECADE CALIFORNIA'S TAKEN STEPS
TO REVERSE. THE HARSH POLICIES
OF THE PAST BY RESTORING
JUDICIAL DISCRETION. AND
INDIVIDUALIZED SENTENCING. AB
FIVE EIGHTEEN RESTORES THE
DISCRETION THAT JUDGES
PREVIOUSLY HAD GIVEN THEM THE
ABILITY TO FAIRLY SENTENCE AND
TO EXERCISE DISCRETION WHEN
DETERMINING A SENTENCE. FOR AN
ACT PUNISHABLE IN DIFFERENT
WAYS BY DIFFERENT PROVISIONS OF
LAW. WE MUST CONTINUE FORWARD
AND WORK TOWARDS MODERNIZING
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM BY ENSURING
THAT SENTENCING SENTENCES ARE
APPROPRIATE TO THE ACT. FIVE
PHONE TODAY I HAVE STUFF ON
MONDAY HELP EXECUTOR OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIRMAN TOO MANY
MEMBERS MY NAME'S STEPHEN
MUNCUL ON THE SECOND RECTRICES
J. REGIONAL SPONSOR OF THE BILL
I'M ALSO CERTIFIED SPECIALIST
IN CRIMINAL LAW AND I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING FOR FORTY THREE
YEARS. SECOND SIX FIFTY FOUR IS
A PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
PROTECTIONS AGAINST DOUBLE
JEOPARDY AND EXCESSIVE
PUNISHMENT. OUR CONSTITUTION
PROHIBITS BEING TRIED MORE THAN
ONCE FOR THE SAME CRIME. AND
SECTION SIX FIFTY FOUR CREDITS
BEING PUNISHED MORE THAN ONCE
FOR THE SAME ACT. CONDITIONALLY
THE PROSECUTOR HAS THE POWER TO
DECIDE WHAT CHARGES TO FILE AND
HOW TO PROSECUTE A CASE. AFTER
CONVICTION THE COURT THEN
DECIDES INAPPROPRIATE SENSE
SPECIFICALLY PENAL CODE NINE
FIFTY FOUR ALLOWS THE
PROSECUTOR TO FILE AND PURSUE
MULTIPLE CHARGES BASED ON A
SINGLE CRIMINAL ACT. FOR
EXAMPLE IS A TOOL BOXES STOLEN
FROM GARAGE AND LATER RECOVERED
FROM THE SUSPECT SECTION NINE
FIFTY FOUR ALLOWS THEM TO BE
CHARGED AND CONVICTED OF BOTH
BURGLARY AND RECEIVING STOLEN
PROPERTY. BUT WHAT IN. IS
CONVICTED OF BOTH CHARGES
SECTION SIX FIFTY FOUR SAYS I
CAN ONLY BE PUNISHED OR ONE OF
THEM. BECAUSE THEY ARE RISE
FROM A SINGLE CRIMINAL ACT. OF
THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE
SENTENCING JUDGE HAVE
DISCRETION IN THE SITUATION TO
CHOOSE WHICH CRIME SHOULD BE
SENTENCED AND WHICH SHOULD BE
STATE. THE AMENDMENT IN NINETY
SEVEN REMOVE DISCRETION FROM
THE JUDGE AND INSTEAD REQUIRES
THAT SENTENCE TO BE IMPOSED. ON
THE CRIME WITH A LONGER
SENTENCE THIS CHANGE IN EFFECT
INCREASE THE POWER PROSECUTORS
GAVE THE MORE LEVERAGE IN PLEA
BARGAINING. DECREASED THE ROLE
OF THE COURTS AS A CHECK ON
PROSECUTORIAL ABUSE AND HELPED
FUEL THE RISING PRISON
POPULATION. AB FIVE EIGHTEEN IS
ONE SMALL STEP IN THE EVIDENCE
BASED REFORMS OF OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM TAKING US A LITTLE
FARTHER FROM THE FAILED
POLICIES OF MASS INCARCERATION.
IT WOULD RESTORE TO THE
SENTENCING JUDGE A BIT OF
DISCRETION IN CHOOSING A
PUNISHMENT APPROPRIATE TO THE
INDIVIDUAL DEFENDANTS IN THE
PARTICULAR CRIME BEFORE THE
COURT. ARGUMENTS BY OPPONENTS
OF THE BILL ARE YOUR THE PROVEN
HARMS OF EXCESSIVE SENTENCING
INCLUDING THAT LONGER SENTENCES
PRODUCE HIGHER RATES OF
REOFFENDING. THEY ALSO IGNORE
THE DETRIMENTAL IMPACT OF
SHIFTING POWER FROM THE COURT
TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH THIS IS
A SENSIBLE AMENDMENT AND WE ASK
FOR OUR VOTE. YOU THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. IN THE CHAMBER
OF THE ANY OTHER. INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. ON THE
VEHICLE COPSEY ARE THERE ANY
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN SUPPORT
AT&T COULD YOU OPEN UP LINES
FOR ANYONE I WANT TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. FINALLY
THERE IS ONE NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
THREE PLACE BECAUSE I HAD. GOOD
EVENING MICHAEL DR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THEN THE NEXT LINE IS ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING ANTHONY DIMARTINO
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
OBJECTIVES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. M. LINE NUMBER SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD
ARE NOW I'M HAVING THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LETTER LINE NUMBER. ONE TWENTY
NINE. MARCO GEORGE IN STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LANDLINE NUMBER. ONE NINETY
SEVEN. REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN Q. AS OF RIGHT
NOW. AND I BELIEVE TO END THIS.
OPPOSITION WE HAVE LARRY MARSH
TO START TODAY. FROM CD EIGHT
HELLO FONG. POURED OUT MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
LARRY MORRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSESS THE SOCIUS WITH GREAT
RESPECT FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHICH WE ARE- OPPOSED AB FIVE
EIGHTEEN THE PURPOSE BEHIND THE
CURRENT VERSION OF PENAL COD
SECTION SIX FIFTY FOUR IS TO
ENSURE THE PUNISHMENT FITS THE
CRIME AND TO ENSURE THAT T
OFFENDED RECEIVES NEITHER
EXCESSIVE PUNISHMENT NOR
INAPPROPRIATE LENIENCY WE ARE
UNAWARE OF ANY SIGNIFICANT
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS OR INJUSTICES
STEMMING FROM THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE. IN P. C. SIXTY FOUR
THE LANGUAGE THAT AB FIVE
EIGHTEEN SEEKS TO EXCLUDE WAS
SEVEN AND SB NINE FOURTEEN TO
PREVENT A DEFENDANT FROM
RECEIVING A WINDFALL THE
LEGISLATURE WAS CONCERNED
INDEPENDENT WHO COMMITTED A
MORE SERIOUS VIOLENT OFFENCE
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY CONCERT
COMMITTING A SECOND LET SERIOUS
PROBLEMS ARISING FROM THE SAME
COURSE OF CONDUCT THAT ESCAPE
PROPER PUNISHMENT ON THE MORE
SERIOUS OFFENSE. WHEREAS THE
DEFENDANT WHO ONLY COMMITTED
THE MORE SERIOUS OFFENSE COULD
NOT FOR EXAMPLE A DEFENDANT
CONVICTED OF KIDNAP FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ROBBERY WHICH
CARRIES A PUNISHMENT OF LIFE
WITH THE POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE
AND ALSO CONVICTED OF THE CRIME
OF ROBBERY WHICH CARRIES A
PUNISHMENT OF TWO THREE OR FIVE
YEARS THE ONLY BE SENTENCED FOR
THE ROBBERY. THE BILL ANALYSIS
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS AGO
NOTED THAT QUOTE IT DEFIES
COMMON SENSE THE DEFENDANT
CONVICTED OF A STRING OF CRIMES
COULD AVOID BEING STATENS ON
THE MOST SERIOUS CRIME BILL
WHICH HERE SHE IS CONVICTED AND
QUOTE THAT REASONING IS EQUALLY
COGENT TODAY IT IS EVEN MORE
APPARENT TO RETAIN THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE BECAUSE ELIMINATING IT
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE
THE BALANCE BETWEEN PUBLIC
SAFETY REAL DELEGATION
REFLECTED IN THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN. IT
PROVIDES IN RELEVANT PART QUOTE
ANY PERSON CONVICTED OF A
NONVIOLENT FELONY OFFENSE AND
SEVENTH ST PRESIDENT SHALL BE.
ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE
CONSIDERATION CONSIDERATION
HAVE COMPLETE THE FULL TERM OR-
FOR. OFFENSE AND- IN POP ROCK
FIFTY. VOTERS TO RELIGIOUS.
WHICH OFFENDERS WHO COMMIT BY
CRIMES AND THOSE WHO DO NOT.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IS
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING WHETHER A
PERSON CONVICTED OF BOTH THE
VIOLENT. AND NONVIOLENT
OFFENSES ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY
PAROLE. IF THE COURT DECIDES
THE PERSON WHO'S SIMULTANEOUSLY
CONVICTED OF BOTH THE VIOLENT
AND NON VIOLENT OFFENSE IS ONLY
ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY RELEASE ON
PAROLE. WHEN THE NON SERIOUS
OFFENSES THE TERM AND CLOSE.
THE CHANGING THE LANGUAGE OF PC
SIX FIFTY FOR HIS PROPOSED BY
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN A
DOUBLE WHEN THE BALL FOUR
DEFENDANTS CONVICTED OF BOTH
VIOLENT AND NONVIOLENT OFFENSE.
STEMMING FROM THE SAME CONDUCT.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE COURT
IMPOSING A SENTENCE ON THE NON
VIOLENT OFFENSE NOT ONLY
POTENTIALLY ALLOWS THE OFFENDER
WHO COMMITS BOTH OF OUR
NONVIOLENT. AND VIOLENT OFFENSE
TO BE GIVEN LESS TIME THAN AN
OFFENDER WHO ONLY COMMITS A
VIOLENT OFFENSE IT ALLOWS FOR
THE OFFENDER WHO COMMITS BOTH
THE NONVIOLENT AND VIOLENT
OFFENSE TO OBTAIN. EARLIER ALL
DAY. THEN THE OFFENDER WHO ONLY
COMMIT A VIOLENT OFFENSE.
MOREOVER EVEN IF THE SUPREME
COURT HOLD THE PERSON WHO IS
SERVING A SENTENCE ON BOTH
VIOLENT AND NONVIOLENT OFFENSE.
IS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY
PAROLE UNDER PROPOSITION FIFTY
SEVEN. UNLESS THE COURT
CLARIFIES WHETHER A SENTENCE
THAT IS IMPOSED BUT STAYED
UNDER PC SIX FIFTY FOUR IS
QUOTE UNQUOTE SERVING A
SENTENCE. AB FIVE EIGHTEEN WILL
CREATE ANOTHER NEW LEGAL ISSUE.
BECAUSE UNDER PROP FIFTY SEVEN
THE FULL TERM FOR THE PRIMARY
OFFENSE MEANS THE LONGEST TERM
OF IMPRISONMENT IMPOSED BY THE
COURT FOR ANY OFFENCE. AND OF
THE PATENT FOR THE CRIME WITH
THE LONGEST TERM OF
IMPRISONMENT. CAN BE IMPOSED
BUT STAYED. THE QUESTION OF
WHAT CONSTITUTES THE FULL TERM
FOR THE PRIMARY OFFENSE. WILL
BE VERY DIFFICULT TO ANSWER AND
CREATE NEW. WE WOULD RISK URGE
YOU DISPLAY. BE THE- UNTIL THE
CAL. SUPREME DECIDE THE K. WITH
IN REYES. SO THAT IF NECESSARY
THE LANGUAGE MODIFYING SECTION
SIX FIFTY FOUR CAN BE CRAFTED
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
INTERPRETING PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
WE HOPE YOU WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE POTENTIAL
UNFAIRNESS AND UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION. THAT WILL BE
CREATED BY REMOVAL OF THE LONG
STANDING COMMONSENSE LIMITATION
CURRENTLY EXISTING IN SECTION
SIX FIFTY FOUR. WE ASK FOR THE-
BOOK. OKAY YOU HAVE ANYBODY-
AT&T TO HAVE ANYBODY ONLINE
WANTS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION IT WOULD BE ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE CHEERING UP AS OF RIGHT
NOW FOR OPPOSITION. ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY HAVE THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR I ALWAYS FIND THAT EVEN
WITHIN ONE COMMITTEE HEARING
HOW WE CANNOT REMAIN CONSISTENT
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT WE TRUST
USUAL DISCRETION OR NOT- BUT MY
ISSUE EARLIER TODAY WITH AB
THREE TWENTY NINE WAS ARE
TAKING AWAY JUDICIAL DISCRETION
FOR JUDGES WHOM WE TRUST WITH
INCREDIBLE RESPONSIBILITY TO
DECIDE WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN TO
PEOPLE WHO COMMITTED CRIMES.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE WHICH IS PUTTING
YOUR FAITH BACK INTO JUDGE WHO
IS MATHIS DEFENDANT HEARD THIS
CASE GETS TO MAKE THAT DECISION
BY ALL MEANS YOU'RE LEAVING
WITHIN THE POWER OF THE JUDGE
TO GIVE THE MORE THE HARSHER
SENTENCE YOU'RE JUST PUTTING IT
INTO THE DISCUSSION OF THE
JUDGES WHICH AGAIN. WE OFTEN DO
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS. JOIN
THE CLUB I APPRECIATE THAT
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S-
COMMENTS ALSO APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES- IS A MEMBER OF OUR
K. AND- IN FACT JUDGES CAN
STILL CHOOSE ALONG SOME PERSON
PERSON AND IF THAT IS WHAT THEY
DEEM TO BE NECESSARY BASED ON
THE CONTEXT OF THE CRIME. AND
THE IDEAS THAT WE'RE NOT
FORCING THEIR HAND TO DO THAT
BUT ACTUALLY HAVING THEM TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT ALL OF THE FACTS
OF THE CASE TO THEN MAKE THE
BEST DECISION- SO WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THE BUSES ARRIVED.
YES AND REYES. HE HAS BEEN ABLE
ONE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER WICKS THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY NO
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE CAN I A
QUIRK ALL RIGHT QUIRK I SAN
DIEGO SAN DIEGO I SEE YOUR
TOTAL C. R. TO KNOW WICKS HI
WICKS BY LEE. LEAI THAT MEASURE.
NEXT WE WILL DO. ADAM FOR BOTH
CHANGES. CAN BE ON MEASURE IN
MY OWN TIME OF TRY THIS AGAIN
NEXT WILL DO ANY ADD ONS OR
VOTE CHANGES AND THE ON CALL
MEASURES MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
GO THROUGH ALL THE MEASURES
TAKEN UP TODAY. ON THE
COMMITTEE ROLES SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I AND THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
THE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO
SIXTY THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER
BONTA SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI. I
ITEM NUMBER THREE THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL AB THREE TWENTY
NINE BY BONTA BARRICADE HAND.
BALLOT EXCUSE ME PARA QUE. IT'S
A LITTLE THE BARRICADE HAD NOT
VOTING SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
THAT MEASURE PASSES. ITEM
NUMBER FOR A BI AB THREE OH
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
BARRICADE HAN DARKIE HAD ICE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO NOT VOTING.
THE OKAY. CORRECTION APRIL
EIGHTH SANTIAGO HI. I DON'T
NUMBER FIVE BY SIMILAR CHEN
WITHOUT CONSENT. I DON'T NUMBER
SIX EIGHTY FOUR NINETEEN I MISS
DAVIS SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I DON'T
NUMBER SEVEN BY AB FIFTY SEVEN
WITH A CONSENT ITEM FORTY EIGHT
EXCUSE ME I DON'T NUMBER EIGHTY
WITH. ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY SIX BY SEVEN MEMBER
HOLDEN BLACKIE. NO LACKING NO
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WICKS WIXII
THAT MEASURE PASSES. ITEM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY THREE THREE
ONE WAS ON CONSENT ITEM. ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE
WITHOUT CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO FIFTY SIX
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL BY THE
MEMBER KALRA SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI WICKS. WICKS HI THAT MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
EIGHTEEN BY SUMMER LACKEY
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI WICKS
WICKS I AM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
THREE NINETY FIVE AYE MR LACKEY
WAX. WICKS NOW. THE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN
WAS A CONSENT. I DON'T NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB FIVE NINETY FOUR HAS
BEEN DISPENSED WITH THAT
PASSED. I DON'T NUMBER
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO FIFTY
THREE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
THAT PASSED. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO SIXTY TWO
WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO TWO EIGHT WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEE OUR TOWN
THAT HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
THAT PASSED. I DON'T NUMBER
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TO NINETY TWO
BY SEVEN MEMBER STONE LACKEY
LACKEY NO WICKS WICKS HI THAT
MEASURE PASSES. I DON'T NUMBER
TWO. TWENTY TWO EXCUSE ME
EIGHTY FIVE OH THREE BY SEVEN
MEMBER STONE LACKEY. LACKEY NOW.
AND ITEM TWENTY THREE HAS
ALREADY BEEN DISPENSED WITH
THAT PASSED. THIS CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.